WELCOME TO THE ASSEMBLY PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMITTEE -- WE WILL
BEGIN AT THE SUBCOMMITTEE UNTIL
WE GET ONE MORE MEMBER --
INTERESTS OF TIME AND THE
INTERESTS OF THE SENATORS WHO
ARE HERE ON TIME -- WILL WILL
BEGIN AS A SUBCOMMITTEE AND AND
TAKE VOTES AFTER THAT -- TODAY.
WE ARE HONORED TO HAVE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER DEVON MATHIS WHO WILL BE
PLACING ASSEMBLY MEMBER DIE
TYLER DEEP.
ON THE ASSEMBLY PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE FOR TUESDAY JUNE
TWENTY FIFTH HEARING ONLY.
CAN'T DO THAT.
AND FOR THE OFF CALENDAR ITEMS
THAT WERE PULLED BY.
AUTHOR -- ITEM NUMBER TWENTY SB
FOUR OH NINE WILK PULL BY AUTHOR.
AND ITEM NUMBER SIX SB ONE
TWENTY STERN POLL BY AUTHOR.
SO WE WILL BEGIN WITH TESTIMONY.
FROM THE SENATOR HILL SB.
THREE OH FOUR THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN I APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR
PROMPTNESS TODAY IN YOUR
COMMITTEES THANK YOU
[inaudible]
WE'LL.
I'M SORRY HE I'M SORRY HE'S NEW
TO THE COMMITTEE JUST HILL.
THANK YOU THE I LIKE THAT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR HEARD AND
CALL IF YOU GIVE ME A SECOND IS.
WE CAN ESTABLISH A QUORUM MR
MATHIS -- MOTION WE TOTALLY IN
ORDER AFTER THAT.
JONES SAWYER HERE LACKEY
[inaudible]
BARRICADE HAND [inaudible]
MATHIS.
KAMLAGER-DOVE HAVE.
QUIRK [inaudible]
SANTIAGO [inaudible]
X..
A QUORUM IS PRESENT I BELIEVE
WITH THE MATHIS YOU HAVE
SOMETHING YOU ONE THING
[inaudible]
SECOND.
THANK YOU MAY BEGIN THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR -- GOOD MORNING
SENATE BILL THREE OR FOUR ALLOWS
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS TO
CONSOLIDATE FELONY ELDERLY
INDEPENDENT ADULT FINANCIAL
FRAUD CASES THAT SPAN MULTIPLE
COUNTIES.
INTO A SINGLE PROSECUTION UNDER
THIS LEGISLATION ELDERLY OR
DEPENDENT VICTIMS OF A SERIAL
PERPETRATOR WOULD NOT HAVE TO
COPE WITH THE CHALLENGES OF
TESTIFYING MULTIPLE TIMES.
IN A MULTIPLE LOCATIONS
IMMOKALEE AS PROSECUTORS TRY
THEIR CASE.
DEPENDENT ADULT AN ELDER
FINANCIAL ABUSE IS THE FASTEST
GROWING CRIME OF CRIMES IN THE
UNITED STATES.
IS THE BABY GENERATE BABY BOOMER
GENERATION AGES FINANCIAL CRIMES
AGAINST THE ELDERLY WILL ONLY
CONTINUE TO INCREASE SB THREE OH
FOUR WILL ALLOW THIS GROWING
POPULATION. TO BE GIVEN MORE
PROTECTION AND CONSIDERATION AS
VULNERABLE VICTIMS UNDER PENAL
CODE SECTION THREE EIGHTY SIX A
IT ENSURES THAT THE PROSECUTION
WILL CONTINUE TO HAVE.
A PRESIDENT WRITTEN EVIDENCE FOR
THE WRITTEN EVIDENCE THAT ALL
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS IN DIFFERENT
JURISDICTIONS AGREE TO ONE
COUNTY BEING SELECTED.
ADDITIONALLY A JUDGE'S REQUIRED
TO WAY WHEN DETERMINING WHETHER
THE CASES SHOULD BE TRIED IN ONE
COUNTY FOR PROSECUTION THE
LOCATION COMPLEXITY OF THE
LEAGUE LIKELY EVIDENCE WHERE THE
MAJORITY OF THE OFFENSES OCCUR
THE RIGHTS OF THE DEFENDANT AND
THE PEOPLE IN THE CONVENIENCE OF
HARDSHIP.
THIS MEASURE HAS ENJOYED
UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT --
I THINK THEY'RE WITNESSES HERE
AND I APPRECIATE THE MOTIONS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU TERRY ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN RESOLUTION MUCH
LEARN WE HAVE THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
WE LET THIS YOUNG MAN THROUGH
ASKED ME.
WE'RE SEEING A CAN WE MOVE THE
MIKE UP SO WE CAN.
SO EVERYONE CAN HEAR YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
LARRY MORSE THE CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
AT ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
.
MARGOT GEORGE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR AND SENATOR FOR NARROWING
THE BILL TO FELONIES ONLY
INITIALLY INCLUDED MISDEMEANORS
AS WELL SO WE APPRECIATE THAT --
HOWEVER WE STILL CONTINUE TO
OPPOSE THE BILL.
OF THIS CLUB INCLUDES BOTH ELDER
ABUSE AND FINANCIAL CRIMES.
OF FINANCIAL CRIMES ARE TOTALLY
DIFFERENT FROM THE OTHER TYPES
OF OFFENSES LIKE SEXUAL ABUSE OR
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND WHICH
CALIFORNIA.
ALLOWS MULTI JURISDICTIONAL
PROSECUTION.
CONSOLIDATION IS PROBLEMATIC FOR
THE DEFENSE FOR OBVIOUS REASONS
IT'S INCONVENIENT FOR DEFENSE
WITNESSES AND IT'S TOTALLY
UNWORKABLE FOR COUNTY PUBLIC
DEFENDER'S WHO DEFEND THE
MAJORITY OF THESE CASES.
WHO HAVE NO POLICE OR OTHER
PROSECUTORS TAURIEL
INVESTIGATORS TO INVESTIGATE
OFFENSES OCCURRING IN ANOTHER
JURISDICTION?
JURISDICTIONS NOT ONLY IS THAT
CONSOLIDATION PROBLEMATIC FOR
THE DEFENSE BUT IT GIVES THE
PROSECUTION AN UNFAIR ADVANTAGE.
THEY WILL GET CONVICTIONS IN
CASES WHERE THE INDIVIDUAL
WASN'T GUILTY BECAUSE WE CASES
WILL BENEFIT FROM THE SHEER
WEIGHT OF AGGREGATING THE
CHARGES.
ADDITIONALLY SOME PROSECUTORS
WILL ATTEMPT TO CHERRY PICK THE
COUNTY FOR TRIAL SO THAT THEY
CAN GET JURIES MORE LIKELY TO
CONVICT.
AND I TRIED TO THINK OF IF I HAD
EVER HAD A CASE WHERE CHARGES
HAD BEEN CONSOLIDATED.
AND I COULDN'T THINK OF ONE
BECAUSE NO. ONE TO MY KNOWLEDGE
HAS CHOSEN TO CONSOLIDATE CASES
FROM OTHER COUNTIES IN ALAMEDA
COUNTY -- PERHAPS SAN FRANCISCO
BY BUT OTHER THAN THAT.
FURTHERMORE THE GENERAL AND TIME
HONORED RULE IN THIS COUNTRY IS
THAT CRIMINAL TRIAL TRIAL SHOULD
BE HELD IN THE AREA WHERE THEY
OCCURRED.
WE RECOGNIZE THERE ARE SOME
EXCEPTIONS TO THAT RULE BUT THEY
SHOULD STATE JUST THAT
EXCEPTIONS.
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR NO
VOTE ON SB THREE OR FOUR THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
THEY BRING YOU BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR ANY QUESTIONS.
COMMENTS.
YOU MAY CLOSE YOUR I WAS LIKE OH
YEAH AND RIVAL PLEASE ADDRESS
SOME CONCERN BUT I'D BE HAPPY TO
IN WE DID NARROW THE BILL OF THE
ISSUE RELATED -- TO EXPANDING
THE JURISDICTIONAL REQUIREMENTS
YOU KNOW IT IT'S IT'S HARD TO
LOOK AT FINANCIAL ABUSE ANY
DIFFERENT THAN ELDER ABUSE WHEN
WHEN IT'S STILL.
YOU HAVE A OF A VULNERABLE
POPULATION THAT IS.
AS FALLING VICTIM TO SO MANY OF
THOSE THOSE CRIMES AND THOSE
ATTEMPTS AT TRYING TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THEM BECAUSE OF
THEIR VULNERABILITY AND THAT'S
WHAT THIS BILL IS LOOKING AT THE
POPULATION.
NOT NECESSARILY THE CRIME THAT'S
COMMITTED AGAINST AND WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT A VULNERABLE PART
POPULATION AND THEY SHOULD BE
PROTECTED FROM THOSE THOSE
ACTIONS SO I FEEL THAT IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT THAT WE THAT WE MOVE
FORWARD WITH THAT OF IT AND WHEN
YOU LOOK AT THIS THIS IS NOT.
IT'S IN THE INTEREST OF JUSTICE
TO TO TO PROSECUTE THIS IN THE
SINGLE JURISDICTION WE PUT A
NUMBER OF PROTECTIONS IN PLACE.
OF THE LOCATION AND COMPLEXITY
THE LIKELY EVIDENCE WHERE THE
MAJORITY DEFENSES OCCURRED THE
RIGHTS OF THE DEFENDANT AT THE
END OF THE DAY.
IT'S UP TO THE JUDGE TO MAKE THE
DECISION AND TO ALLOW THIS OR
NOT ALLOWED THIS BASED ON THE
AFFECT IT WOULD HAVE ON ALL
PARTIES INVOLVED.
IN ALL POPULATION SO I THINK
WE'VE NARROWED IT AND IT IT.
I BELIEVE PROVIDES THE THE
PROTECTION NECESSARY AND I DO
HAVE A WITNESS HERE WHO IS --
FROM SAN MATEO COUNTY IS THE
TRAFFIC A LITTLE TOUGH GETTING
IN HERE THIS MORNING AND WE DO
HAVE TO MOTIONS AND I THINK
WE'RE THE TO GO TO YOUR
DISCRETION STRUCTURE.
AND I BELIEVE BOTH PARTIES ARE
THANKS I KNOW WHO YOU ARE AND I
KNOW WHO YOU ARE THAT YOU
DEFINITELY DO NOT WANT.
PEOPLE CHERRY PICKING OR
PROSECUTED -- BUT WE JUST THIS
WHOLE THING OF ELDER ABUSE IS
REALLY -- SIGNIFICANT ESPECIALLY
FINANCIAL ELDER ABUSE AND SO WE
REALLY DO NEED TO MOVE FORWARD
AND DO SOMETHING I BELIEVE THAT
THE COURT AND IN THEIR
DISCRETION HOPEFULLY WILL BE
ABLE.
TO DISTINGUISH BETWEEN THE TWO
AND HOPEFULLY EVEN THIS OUT AND
SO THE CHURCH RECOMMEND AN AYE
VOTE.
AND I THINK IF THERE IS A
PROBLEM I THINK YOU CAN TALK TO
THE SENATE ABOUT CORRECTING
ANYTHING INEFFECTUAL LICKS.
ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR WE HAVE A MOVED A SECOND
CALL PAROLE.
ON SB THREE A FOR THE MOTION IS
TO PASS JONES SAWYER DENSER
IRAQI -- CAM PACKING AND I
MATHIS.
MATHIS I KAMLAGER-DOVE HAVE.
QUIRK AYE QUIRK AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO HI WICKS.
WICKS I THE MEASURE PASSES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR TEACHER
THANK YOU COLLEAGUES.
VERY MUCH SO IN ADDITION -- WE
ALSO HAVE ITEM NUMBER FOUR SB
FIVE FIVE JACKSON ALSO POOL BY
AUTHOR.
I'M QUICKLY GOING TO GO TO THE
THE PROPOSED CONSENT CALENDAR.
ITEM NUMBER TWELVE SB TWO THREE
NINE CHIANG CRIMINAL PROCEDURE
LIMITATIONS OF ACTIONS ITEM
NUMBER TWELVE SB TWO FIVE NINE
NIELSEN.
OUR DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE CRIMES
DETECTIVES REPORTING.
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY ONE SB FOUR
SEVEN ONE STERN SUBPOENAS
FOREMAN SERVICE AND ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY FIVE SB -- SEVEN EIGHT
ONE PUBLIC SAFETY PUBLIC SAFETY
I'M US.
CALL THE ROLL.
ON THE SECOND LINDER JONES
SAWYER JONES SAWYER HI LACKEY.
BARRICADE HAN BARRICADE HAD HI
MATHIS
MATHIS I KAMLAGER-DOVE.
QUIRK.
QUIRK I SAN DIEGO SAN DIEGO I
WICKS.
WICKS I IT'S CONSENT CAL IS A
TOPIC ABOUT SENATOR BELL.
I DON'T NUMBER.
NUMBER FOURTEEN SB.
TWO EIGHT TWO OKAY I GET.
GET THE IDEA [inaudible]
CHAIRMAN -- MEMBERS GOOD MORNING --
THIS BILL CREATES THE SUPPORT OF
HOUSING PROGRAM FOR PERSONS OF
ON PAROLE. TO BETTER SERVE
INDIVIDUALS ON PAROLE WITH
MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS.
OF FACING HOMELESSNESS -- WE
HAVE AN EXISTING PROGRAM
ESSENTIALLY -- THERE WAS A STUDY
DONE BY UCLA ON THIS PROGRAM.
WE SHOW THAT IT FAILED TO REDUCE
RECIDIVISM.
IT'S NOT EFFECTIVE IT DOES NOT
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THE MEDICARE
ALL.
OF PROGRAM AND WE'RE REALIGNING
THIS PROGRAM SO IT DOES TAKE A
PHOTO OF USE OF THE MEDICAL
PROGRAM.
AND HAS A HIGHER DEGREE OF
EFFECTIVENESS I HAVE SOME
WITNESSES ALTERNATE OVER THEM.
AND THEY CAN -- TESTIFIED IN
FAVOR SO I'M GOING TO CUT MY
REMARKS SHORT.
TURNER LET ME LET ME LISTEN TO
THE WITNESSES MISTER CHAIRMAN
THANK.
THANK YOU SENATOR THE MORNING
SHARON REPORT WITH THE
CORPORATION FOR SUPPORT OF
HOUSING WE KNOW THAT
INCARCERATION HOMELESSNESS AND
RECIDIVISM ARE CLOSELY LINKED --
ABOUT TEN TIMES IS -- PEOPLE WHO
ARE COMING OUT OF INCARCERATION
ARE ABOUT TEN TIMES AS LIKELY TO
BECOME HOMELESS IS PEOPLE WHO
ARE NOT -- AND EVEN MORE
COMPELLING PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS OR SEVEN TIMES MORE
LIKELY TO RESET OF EIGHT THAN
PEOPLE WHO ARE HOUSE.
THE STRONG LINK -- A FOR FORMER
CARS SERRATION AND HOMELESSNESS
ALSO CONTRIBUTES TO IN EQUITY --
AMONG OUR HOMELESS POPULATION
WITH 40% OF OUR HOMELESS
POPULATION BEING AFRICAN
AMERICAN INEQUITIES IN OUR
JUSTICE SYSTEM CONTRIBUTE
DISPROPORTIONATE REPRESENTATION
OF PEOPLE OF COLOR.
AMONG CALIFORNIANS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS.
ENDING HOMELESSNESS IMPROVES OF
FORMALLY INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS CHANCES OF STAYING
OUT OF PRISON.
RECOVERING FROM MENTAL ILLNESS
AND ACCESSING TREATMENT FOR
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDERS.
MULTIPLE JURISDICTIONS INCLUDING
SEVERAL STATES ACROSS THE
COUNTRY ARE FUNDING PERMANENT
HOUSING OR HOUSING WITHOUT
LIMITS OF LINT LIMITS ON LENGTH
OF STAY.
WITH INTENSIVE SERVICES THAT
PROMOTE HOUSING STABILITY THE
COMBINATION ON THE SUPPORT OF
HOUSING. FOR PEOPLE ON PAROLE OR
PROBATION -- SEVERAL OF THESE
STATES INCLUDING OHIO AND NEW
YORK HAVE DONE THE VALUATIONS OF
THESE PROGRAMS AND THE COP FOUND
SIGNIFICANT REDUCTIONS IN
RECIDIVISM OF 4260%.
AS WELL AS SIGNIFICANT INCREASES
IN MENTAL HEALTH TREATMENT AND
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER TREATMENT.
I NAY ARE PEOPLE FOR A NEAR
PROGRAM FOR PEOPLE CYCLING
BETWEEN RYKER'S ISLAND AND
HOMELESS SHELTERS PHONE SUPPORT
OF HOUSING.
NOT ONLY REDUCE RECIDIVISM BY
60%.
IT ALSO REDUCE PUBLIC SECTOR
COSTS AND RESULTED EVEN IN COST
SAVINGS TO HEALTH CARE AND
EMERGENCY RESPONSE SYSTEMS.
PARTICIPANTS WERE LESS LIKELY TO
ABUSE SUBSTANCES AND MORE LIKELY
TO ACCESS TREATMENT FOR MENTAL
L..
COMPARED TO A CONTROL GROUP.
DOZENS OF LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
INCLUDING HEARING CALIFORNIA
REPORT DECREASED JAIL DAYS
RECIDIVISM AN IMPROVED HEALTH AS
A RESULT OF SUPPORT OF HOUSING.
SB TWO EIGHTY TWO WILL NOT ONLY
PROVIDE THIS EVIDENCE BASED
MODEL TO SOLVE HOMELESSNESS. FOR
PEOPLE ON PAROLE IT WILL CONTENT
CAN ACT PARTICIPANTS MENTAL
HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE DISORDER
TREATMENT SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
TREATMENT THROUGH COUNTY MEDI
CAL BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PROGRAMS.
WHICH WILL HELP THOSE COUNTIES
ACCESS 5290% FEDERAL
REIMBURSEMENT FOR THE COSTS OF
THIS TREATMENT.
AS SENATOR BELL SAID RIGHT NOW
UNDER THE EXISTING PROGRAM WE'D
LIKE TO SEE THE FUNDING RE
DIRECTED FROM.
THAT PROGRAM IS PAYING A 100% OF
THE COST MENTAL HEALTH TREATMENT.
SB TWO EIGHTY TWO WILL ALSO MOVE
FUNDING TO THE STATE DEPARTMENT
THAT HAS THE GREATEST COMPETENCY
IN ADDRESSING HOMELESSNESS WHICH
IS THE DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT.
SB TWO EIGHTY TWO WILL ESTABLISH
AN EFFECTIVE EVIDENCE BASED
APPROACH TO REDUCING RECIDIVISM
AMONG CALIFORNIANS MOST LIKELY
TO BE SET OF EIGHT AND IT WILL
NOT ONLY TRANSFORM THE STATE'S
RESPONSE TO HOUSING NEEDS FOR
PEOPLE ON PAROLE IT WILL REDUCE
AND EQUITIES AND OUR RESPONSE TO
HOMELESSNESS.
I URGE YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU
ARE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
DOUBLE DIN MIGHT NAME IN
[inaudible]
ORGANIZATION PLEASE.
MARGOT CHORES FROM THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU --
HAIRS WITH DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
SHOP EARLY FOR CALIFORNIA
FRIVOLOUS BUT HE'S ADVOCACY FROM.
ELIZABETH ESPINOSA ON BEHALF OF
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND THE
COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES IN SUPPORT --
MICHAEL RATIGAN ON BEHALF OF THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS SANTA CLARA
COUNTY AND SPORT.
TYLER IN THE WITH THE COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
LOUIS BROWN JUNIOR POLICY LIKE
IN SUPPORT.
CHRIS MARTIN HOUSING CALIFORNIA
COSPONSORED SUPPORT.
ARCHERY TAKE CHECK FOR SEX
SACRAMENTO COUNTY IN SUPPORT.
SASHA HERNDON WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY AND SUPPORT.
AND WHERE'S THE ELEVATOR CENTER
FOR HUMAN RIGHTS IN SUPPORT.
ACTUALLY CHAMBERS WITH ELLA
BAKER CENTER FOR SUPPORT.
LOUIS MANTE WITH CALIFORNIA BEEN
SUPPORT.
AND I'M I APOLOGIZE A CENTER I I
THOUGHT YOU TO SENATORS CHIEF OF
STAFF FOR YOU.
OKAY [inaudible]
OWN.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS LENDING
CROWDY AND I'M AN ADVOCATE FOR
LEGAL SERVICES FOR PRISONERS
WITH CHILDREN AND ALL OF US AND
THEN.
A NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION
EMPLOYING AND WORKING TO UPHOLD
THE DIGNITY OF FORMALLY
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS.
I'M ALSO FORMALLY INCARCERATED.
I LIKE TO SHARE MY STORY ABOUT
THE DIFFICULTY OF FINDING AND
KEEPING HOUSING AS A PERSON RE
ENTERING SOCIETY AND PRE -- POST
INCARCERATION.
WHEN I WAS INCARCERATED I TOOK
THE TIME TO WORK ON MYSELF I
TOOK NUMEROUS CLASSES
FACILITATED CLASSES?
ADDRESS THINGS ROB PASS AND
FOCUS ON BEING A BETTER ME.
I REALIZE THAT IT WAS MY POOR
CHOICES THAT LANDED ME IN MY
SITUATION AND I WAS READY TO
MOVE FORWARD IN MY NEW BEGIN AND
BE IN A BETTER ME.
THAT WAS ONE OF THE MOST.
POWERFUL THINGS THAT KEPT ME
MOTIVATED AND GROUNDED --
PLANNING FOR MY FUTURE.
AFTER A LITTLE OVER EIGHT YEARS
MY DAY HAVE FINALLY COME AND I
WAS READY TO BE A PRODUCTIVE
CITIZEN.
EAGER TO BUILD A PRODUCTIVE LIFE.
I WAS GIVEN FOUR MONTHS INSIDE A
TRANSITIONAL HOME IS SEEM LIKE
THE MOMENT I STEPPED THROUGH
THOSE DOORS.
I WAS GREETED WITH A HARSH
REALITY.
USUALLY WHEN PEOPLE FIND OUT
THAT YOU JUST CAME HOME ONE OF
THE FIRST QUESTION IS -- HOW DO
YOU FILL?
YES I WAS EXTREMELY GRATEFUL TO
BE HOME BUT I WAS FULL OF
ANXIETY WORRY AND FEAR.
I QUICKLY LEARNED UPON MY
RELEASE THAT THE AVERAGE RENT
WAS AT LEAST A THOUSAND DOLLARS
OR MORE.
I KNEW THAT FINDING ADEQUATE
HOUSING WAS A VITAL COMPONENT IN
THE SUCCESS OF MY FUTURE.
BUT I WAS GIVEN JUST FOUR MONTHS
TO FIGURE THIS OUT.
WE'RE TRYING TO FIND A LIVABLE
WAGE JOB CLOTHING AND MONEY FOR
FOOD I FOUND MYSELF LIVING
LOSING CONFIDENCE IN MYSELF.
LIVING IN A COLD WET HOME THE
MAIN TOPIC OF CONVERSATION WAS
HOUSING I QUICKLY LEARNED THAT I
WAS FAR FROM ALONE FOR MY
ANXIETY AND WORRIES.
OUR CASE MANAGERS HAVE LITTLE TO
NO RESOURCES SO SAYS SAYS SO WE
WE WERE ALONE IN FIGURING IT OUT.
ONE OF MY ROOMMATES WHO WAS OPEN
ABOUT HER MENTAL HEALTH ILL NAY
SHARE WITH ME THAT THIS WAS HER
SECOND TIME IN A TRANSITIONAL
HOME.
SHE SAID THAT WHEN SHE WAS THERE
FOR THE FIRST TIME SHE RAN OUT
OF TIME BEFORE FINDING HOUSING
SO SHE HAD TO LIVE IN A CAR FOR
A WHILE.
DUE TO HER MENTAL HEALTH SHE WAS
GRANTED ANOTHER FOUR MONTHS
INSIDE THE TRANSITIONAL HOME.
I WATCH MY ROOMMATES SEARCH
FRANTICALLY FOR HOUSING
OFTENTIMES ENGAGE IN WHAT I
THOUGHT WAS GET SKETCHY
SITUATIONS.
RESOURCES THE FINE ROOMMATES
SOMETIMES A LOOK LIKE SHE WILL
FIND GOOD LEADS BUT THEY WILL
LEAVE -- NEVER CALLED HER BACK
AFTER MEETING HER.
OTHER TIMES I WE HEAR HER
COMMUNICATING WITH MEN WHO WERE
RENTING AND SOMETIMES HERE RED
FLAGS.
THERE WAS NO ONE THERE WAS NO
ONE REALLY THERE TO HELP HER AND
HER SPECIAL NEEDS FOR THOSE OF
US WHO ARE FACING HOMELESSNESS.
AFTER TRANSITIONAL HOUSING.
AT THE FOUR MONTHS IN
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING I WAS
FORTUNATE TO FIND A PROGRAM THAT
HELPS OF HOUSE FORMALLY
INCARCERATED PEOPLE.
IN THE COMMUNITY FOR UP TO SIX
MONTHS BUT AFTER THAT TOM MIKE
OTHER FORMALLY INCARCERATED
PEOPLE I WILL AGAIN FACE THE
POSSIBILITY OF HAVING TO SECURE
HOUSING.
AND ONE OF THE MOST EXPENSIVE
AREAS IN THE COUNTRY AND IN THE
STATE IN WHICH IT IS GENERALLY
LEGAL TO DENY HOUSING TO PEOPLE
SOLELY.
BECAUSE THEY HAVE A CRIMINAL
RECORD.
BECAUSE OF THESE CHALLENGES I
FACE THE REAL POSSIBILITY
ABILITY OF NOT SECURING SAFE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AT ALL.
MANY OF MY HOUSE MAY SUFFER FROM
SOME SOME FORM OF MENTAL ILLNESS
INCLUDE IN THE TRAUMA OF
INCARCERATION AND THE MENTAL
EMOTIONAL SCARS OF THE
EXPERIENCE WITH TOM ALSO DEAL
WITH IN HEALING FROM. FOR US
FINING HOUSING IS EXTREMELY
DIFFICULT WITH A CRIMINAL
CONVICTION NOT TO MENTION THE
EXTREME COSTS OF HOUSING.
WITH ALL DESIRE TO MAKE IT ON
OUR OWN AND MOVE FORWARD IN A
PRODUCTIVE WAY HOUSING IS NOT A
PRIVILEGE IT'S A NECESSITY.
PLEASE WELL YES FOR SB TWO
EIGHTY TWO AND THANK YOU FOR
GIVING ME THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT THIS IMPORTANT
BILL.
THANK YOU -- ANY OTHER WITNESSES.
IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
BASED.
IN CHICAGO.
THIS CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE BY NELSON ON BEHALF OF
THE AMERICAN FEDERATION OF STATE
COUNTY MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES -- WE
RESPECT THE INTENT OF THE AUTHOR --
AND AND WHAT THE PROBLEM HE'S
TRYING TO ADDRESS WE THINK IS A
CRITICAL ISSUE IN THE COMMUNITY --
BUT AT THIS TIME WE HAVE STATE
WORKERS -- WHO -- I WILL
INTRODUCE A SHORTLY -- TO MY
LEFT WHO -- ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES THAT THE
BILL MIGHT HAVE AND THE IMPACT
ON EXISTING POSITIONS IN THE
STATE -- AND STATE CIVIL SERVICE --
SO AT THIS TIME I LIKE TO TURN
OVER TO OF DUAL JOHNSON FROM
CASA.
FIFTY SEVEN THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE -- A BILL JOHNSON
PRESIDENT OF ASKED ME COUNCIL
FIFTY SEVEN I JUST LIKE TO
INTRODUCE -- OUR MEMBERS WHO
WORKS DIRECTLY WITH DEPARTMENT
OF PAROLE OPERATION CDC ARE --
WHO'S A SENIOR PSYCHOLOGIST
pSPECIALISTS AND WORKS DIRECTLY --
TO LIAISE BETWEEN.
CDC ARE AND ISN'T IT PROGRAM SO
A DOCTOR RESERVOIR.
GOOD MORNING -- I'M BATMAN
RESERVE FOR I'M A SENIOR
PSYCHOLOGIST FOR THE DEPARTMENT
OF CORRECTIONS.
AND I HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH THE
PAROLE POPULATION PEOPLE
PREVIOUSLY INCARCERATED FOR THE
PAST EIGHTEEN YEARS.
I'M HERE IN OPPOSITION OF THE
BILL -- SB TWO EIGHTY TWO FOR A
VARIETY OF REASONS -- ABOVE ALL
IT -- NEGATIVELY IMPACTS THE
POPULATION THAT WE ARE SAVING --
ALSO IMPACTS NEGATIVELY THE CDC
OUR EMPLOYEES.
AND IN MY OPINION THIS BILL IS
PREMISED ON INACCURATE DATA.
WHEN THE BILL WHEN I READ THE
BILL THEY WERE REFERRING TO A
UCLA STUDY?
THAT WAS FROM THE YEAR TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN WORD THE IS ME
DOLLARS WORSE AND WORSE SPEND
ABOUT -- THIRTY TWO HUNDRED PER
MONTH FOR HOUSING PURPOSES.
AS OF OF MAY OF TWENTY NINETEEN
THE AMOUNT THAT.
LOS ANGELES COUNTY -- THE PAROLE
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY EXPENSE
IN HOUSING ONLY.
IS OVER FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS.
AND I BELIEVE THAT IF ANYTHING
WE NEED MORE RESOURCES FOR
HOUSING PURPOSE IS NOT TO
REDUCING OR GIVING IT TO A
DIFFERENT DEPARTMENT WHICH I
HAVE NOT SEEN.
A SHRED OF EVIDENCE THAT HAS THE
ABILITY TO MANAGE THE PART THE
POPULATION WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
SO.
THE BILL WAS BASED ON THE
INFORMATION THAT WAS LIKE.
THE IS ME DOLLARS WERE SENT
ABOUT THIRTY TWO HUNDRED BASED
ON THE UCLA STUDY.
NOW WE'RE SPENDING FIFTY TWO
THOUSAND THIS IS NOT REFLECTED
IN THE BILL AND I BELIEVE THIS
IS THE AT OWN USE FOUNDATION.
SO I AM OPPOSING.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
YES -- MY NAME IS JAMES SWEENEY
I'M WITH BAY PACKED THE BLACK
AMERICAN POLITICAL ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA.
AND WE OPPOSE THIS -- BILL FOR
THREE FUNDAMENTAL REASONS THE
FIRST REASON THAT WE OPPOSE THIS
BILL IS BECAUSE THAT IS THE
SMITH PROGRAM IS FOR THOSE WHO
ARE SEVERELY MENTALLY ILL.
AND TO MERELY **** THESE DOLLARS
FROM CDC BREAK THE CONTRACT AND
GO TO TRADITIONAL HOUSING
PROVIDERS IS NOT GOING TO DEAL
WITH THE ISSUE OF THE DUALLY
DIAGNOSED SEVERELY MENTALLY
DISABLED.
SECONDLY -- AND CANDIDLY -- THIS
IS ONE OF THE FEW PROGRAMS THAT
AFRICAN AMERICANS -- AND
MINORITIES ARE PLAYING A
SIGNIFICANT ROLE IN RUNNING.
OPERATING AND HAM DILLON.
AND WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
NOT ONLY ARE THEY ABLE TO
PROVIDE SERVICES FOR THIS
PARTICULAR POPULATION BUT THAT
THE EMPLOYMENT PIECE.
IS IS RIGHT AND FINALLY -- MY
COLLEAGUE THE PSYCHOLOGIST HERE
IS TELLING YOU.
WHAT THE FUNDAMENTAL ISSUE IS I
BELIEVE THIS IS A RECIPE FOR
FAILURE I BELIEVE THE INTENT?
IS GOOD BUT I THINK IT'S A
RECIPE FOR FAILURE BECAUSE THIS
PARTICULAR POPULATION -- THE
DUALLY DIAGNOSED SEVERELY
MENTALLY DISABLED.
ARE YOU ARE NOT GOING TO BE ABLE
TO PROVIDE SERVICES FOR THEM THE
INFRASTRUCTURE IS NOT IN PLACE
TO PROVIDE THESE SERVICES AND
MANY OF THESE PEOPLE -- NEED THE
WRAPAROUND SERVICES THAT THE
OTHER HOUSING PROVIDERS MAY NOT
BE IN A POSITION TO PROVIDE.
AND FINALLY YOU JUST SNATCHING
THIS IS THE THIRD TIME THIS BILL
HAS COME BEFORE YOU.
AND I WOULD IMPLORE YOU TO DO
WHAT YOU DID THE PREVIOUS THREE
TIMES AND THAT IS OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
COMPARING QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITMENTS THERE QUIRK YES --
WITH REGARD TO THE OPPOSITION.
YOU REALLY SHOULD PUT IN THE
LETTER BECAUSE COMING UP AT THE
LAST MINUTE LIKE THIS.
WE DON'T HAVE A WAY OF CHECKING
WHAT YOU'RE DOING.
THE OTHER THING IS THERE WAS A
TWENTY SEVENTEEN STUDY FROM UCLA
YOU SAID THE LAST STUDY WAS MANY
YEARS AGO.
WHICH SHOWED THAT THIS DOES NOT
SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCE RECIDIVISM.
AND IN ADDITION ONCE YOU'VE GOT
HOUSING IF THE PERSON IS
MENTALLY ILL THEY GET THEIR
SUBJECT TO MEDI CAL.
AND THE REASON I FIRMLY BELIEVE
THAT THIS IS A GOOD.
HAS BEEN MOVED YET.
NOW ALL MOVED TO BAIL.
I'M SORRY IT'S BEEN MOVED.
AND SECONDED RIGHT OKAY.
ALL RIGHT OKAY.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
YES MISTER LACKEY.
A FIRST OF ALL I'D I FIND THE I
HOPE WHEN YOU CLOSE YOUR
ADDRESSING THESE CONCERNS
BECAUSE OUR NEW TO ME.
AND THEY SEEM TO BE QUITE THE
GENTLEMAN AS YOU KNOW ALL THE
THE DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED --
SERVICE NETWORK IS CLEARLY IN
JEOPARDY.
WITHOUT THE INCARCERATED PIECE --
THIS BODY IS NOT DOING A GOOD
JOB OF FUNDING.
THAT SERVICE ASPECT AND THIS
JUST ADDS TO THE DISTRESS TO
THAT THAT WHOLE.
A SERVICE MODEL THAT. ONE OF THE
OTHER QUESTIONS I HAD IS -- THE
DURATION OF ELIGIBILITY BECAUSE
IT SEEMS TO BE SOME.
SOME NEXT -- INDICATORS IN THE
ACTUAL BILL.
AND IN ONE PORTION OF THE BILL
IT INDICATES THAT -- THEY'RE
ELIGIBLE SO LONG AS MEDICALLY
NECESSARY.
THEN JUST FURTHER IN THE BILL.
AS SAYS THE ELIGIBILITY LAST AS
LONG AS A PARTICIPANT NEEDS THE
ASSISTANCE.
AND THEN IN THE THIRD.
JUST A LITTLE BIT FURTHER DOWN
AT SAYS THAT THEY'RE ELIGIBLE SO
LONG AS A PARTICIPANT NEEDS THE
SERVICES OR THE GRANT PERIOD
DOWNS.
SO IT SEEMS TO BE A LITTLE BIT
CONFUSING TO ME.
AND IF YOU COULD TRY TO BRING
SOME CLARITY TO THAT PIECE I
WOULD APPRECIATE THAT ALSO.
THE RAINY OTHER.
QUESTIONS [inaudible]
OKAY GOOD.
THE ONE OKAY -- ESSENTIALLY
HERE'S THE DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS IN CARS RICH PEOPLE
IN THE STATE FACILITIES.
ONCE THEY LEAVE THE STATE FOR SO
THERE IN THE COMMUNITY AND
THEY'RE ON A ROLL IN THE PAROLE
SYSTEM.
AND IF THEY HAPPEN TO NEED.
MENTAL HEALTH -- PROGRAMS --
THEY SHOULD BE ELIGIBLE AND ARE
ELIGIBLE -- UNLESS THEY HAVE A
LOT OF MONEY IN INCOME.
WHICH IN THAT CASE THEY WOULD
HAVE PRIVATE INSURANCE THEY
WOULD BE IN THE MEDICAL SYSTEM.
THE MEDICAL BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SYSTEMS RUN BY THE COUNTY.
AND I WILL QUOTE A LETTER FROM
THE COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES FOR
YOU -- THE COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF
MENTAL HEALTH NOTICES THE
COUNTY'S INVOLVEMENT IN THIS
NEWLY CREATED PROGRAM WOULD
FACILITATE CONNECTING PAROLEES.
THAT NEED MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
TO LOS ANGELES COUNTY NETWORK OF
RESOURCES AND SUPPORT OF
PROGRAMS.
SO THE IDEA OF THIS PROGRAM IS
TO GET HIM INTO THOSE COUNTY
SYSTEMS.
PROVIDE THAT HOUSING.
AND THEN CONNECT THEM WITH THE
EXISTING COUNTY MENTAL HEALTH
SYSTEMS WITCHER THE SYSTEMS THAT
PROVIDE MENTAL HEALTH IN THE
COMMUNITY.
SO THAT'S THAT'S THE THAT'S
ESSENTIALLY WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT
THE EXISTING.
PROGRAM WHICH IS A SEGREGATED
OUTSIDE THE COUNTY.
MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM THAT WE THE
STATE ARE PAYING FOR A 100% OF
THE MENTAL HEALTH.
COST SO SEND MY OPINION THE BILL
IS AN IMPROVEMENT.
IN A IN A AN IMPROVEMENT AND AND
AND AND ESTABLISHES A
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN THE COUNTIES.
IN THE STATE.
FOR A PROPERLY HANDLING.
OF PAROLEES LEAVING THE
INCARCERATED SYSTEM IN
CALIFORNIA SO.
THAT'S THAT'S KIND OF HOW.
THE COUNTIES TO MILL HEALTH.
YOU KNOW THE DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTION DOESN'T DO MENTAL
HEALTH.
SO WE WANT TO LINK THESE PEOPLE
UP WITH THE COUNTY SYSTEM AND
THAT'S THE MOST EFFICIENT THING
WE CAN DO AND THAT'S WHAT THIS
PROGRAM DOES.
IF I COULD JUST ADD OF SLAUGHTER
TO TO THAT -- ON THE MENTAL
HEALTH PIECE THE THE
PARTICIPANTS TO HAVE TO BE
SERIOUSLY MENTALLY ILL TO BE
ELIGIBLE FOR THE NEW PROGRAM AS
WELL -- ENDS THE UCLA STUDY --
AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK POINTED
OUT THERE'S JUST TWO YEARS AGO
FOUND THAT -- PARTICIPANTS IN
THE CURRENT PROGRAM ARE ONLY
ACCESSING MENTAL HEALTH
TREATMENT FOR AN AVERAGE OF NINE
TO TEN MONTHS.
IN WHICH THAT TIME THEY TRY THEY
BASICALLY DROP OUT OF THE
PROGRAM THEY'RE NO LONGER
RECEIVING MENTAL HEALTH
TREATMENT.
EVEN IF THEY DO CONTINUE TO
RECEIVE MENTAL HEALTH TREATMENT
THROUGH THE TERM OF THEIR PAROLE
THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE A BREAK
AND TREATMENT BECAUSE THEY'RE
GONNA BE DROPPED FROM THE
PROGRAM AND THEN THEY HAVE TO
SEEK MENTAL HEALTH TREATMENT
FROM THE COUNTY.
BECAUSE THAT AS SENATOR PELL
SAID THAT IS THE OF THE
JURISDICTION THAT PROVIDES
MENTAL TREATMENT UNDER MEDICARE
ALL SO THIS PROGRAM IS REALLY
TRYING TO PREVENT.
THE BREAKING TREATMENTS TRYING
TO PROVIDE EVIDENCE BASED SOLID
MENTAL HEALTH CARE TO PEOPLE
WITH SERIOUS MENTAL ILLNESS --
IN ANSWER TO YOUR QUESTION
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LACKEY ABOUT THE
INCONSISTENCY IN THE LANGUAGE.
THE FIRST CITATION THE FIRST
LANGUAGE YOU CITED ABOUT -- AS
LONG AS MEDICALLY NECESSARY THAT
IS HOW LONG I COUNTY HOUSE TO
PROVIDE.
MEDICARE ALL MENTAL HEALTH
TREATMENT TO THE PARTICIPANTS SO
THEY HAVE TO THEY CANNOT CUT THE
PARTICIPANT OFF AT ANY TIME AS
LONG AS THEY HAVE MEDICAL NEED
FOR MENTAL HEALTH TREATMENT
UNDER MEDICARE ALL.
OUR PROGRAM -- THE OTHER TWO
CITATIONS YOU MENTIONED WE DO WE
DID RECOGNIZE THAT THERE'S AN
INCONSISTENCY IN THOSE -- TWO
PROVISIONS AND SO WE ARE GOING
TO ADDRESS THAT AND AMENDMENTS
AND LATER COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU FOR RAISING.
OKAY.
YOU MAY CLOSE WITH BETTER QUOTE --
MISTER CHAIRMAN DR DREW THIS
WEEKEND ATTACKED.
THE HOUSING FIRST MODEL HE SAID
THAT'S NOT REALLY THE SOLUTION
TO HOMELESSNESS.
HE SAID WE NEED TO HAVE
SUBSTANCE ABUSE TREATMENT
PROGRAMS AND MENTAL HEALTH
TREATMENT.
WELL I HAPPEN TO AGREE WITH DR
DREW BUT I ALSO AGREE WITH THE
FACT THAT WE NEED.
SUPPORT OF HOUSING THIS PROVIDES
BOTH THIS IS THE KIND OF PROGRAM
THAT WILL PROVIDE BOTH AND IT
WILL BE SUCCESSFUL HAS BEEN
SUCCESSFUL.
IN A LOT OF OTHER STATES OF
PROVEN SUCCESS AND IN NEW YORK
AND OTHER STATES I REGION I VOTE
ON THIS.
SO.
LET ME JUST JUST FROM A
PROCEDURAL.
STANDPOINT AND ONE JUST AS
COMMITTEE CHAIR AND JUST. ONE IS
JUST MY PERSONAL.
PREFERENCE I'M FROM A PROCEDURAL
IT'S NOT FAIR TO THE OPPOSITION.
IF YOU COM.
AT THE LAST MINUTE. TO MAKE.
STATEMENTS BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE
TIME TO BETTER.
THIS HAS BEEN I WENT TO SENATE.
I HAVE I HAVE SOME TO I DO HAVE
THE BEST.
POLICY STAFF MONEY ASSEMBLY SIDE.
I WILL SAY ALSO ON THE SENATE
SIDE BECAUSE MOST OF THOSE
PEOPLE CAME FROM THE ASSEMBLY
BUT THAT'S A WHOLE.
OKAY AND SO I HAVE PEOPLE THAT
CAN THOROUGHLY BET.
ANYTHING.
I ME THOROUGHLY VETTED SO THAT.
WE CAN WE CAN.
LAKE CREDENCE TO WHAT'S GOING ON
ON THE OTHER SIDE SO THAT IF HIS
OPPOSITION -- I HAVE STAFF HERE
THAT CAN THOROUGHLY VETTED --
AND SO IT'S IT'S NOT FAIR TO
COMMITTEE MEMBERS -- IT'S NOT
FAIR TO YOUR MEMBERS DOES THAT
COME IN THAT DILUTES THE
ELEVENTH HOUR.
FROM A PERSONAL STANDPOINT AS AN
AUTHOR.
WHO?
HAS HAD BILLS COME OVER.
AND ON THE FLOOR OF THE SENATE
HAVE PEOPLE FRIENDS OF MINE
ALLIES MIGHT COME IN AT THE LAST
MINUTE.
WITH PROBABLY SOME VALID POINTS.
BUT IT WAS AT THE LAST MINUTE
HAVE SABOTAGE ONE OF MY BILLS SO
I PERSONALLY.
IT PERSONALLY BOTHERS ME WHEN
THAT HAPPENS ESPECIALLY WHEN.
PEOPLE HAVE AT MY OFFICE IS
ALWAYS OPEN PEOPLE HAVE ACCESS
TO MY OFFICE TWENTY FOUR SEVEN
IS NOT BIKE WERE HIDING AND YOU
CAN'T GET TO US -- AND IN A
THIRD THING I KNOW.
THE AUTHOR MYSELF AND MANY
MEMBERS HERE WERE NOT IN THE
BUSINESS.
OF TRYING TO PUT PUBLIC SECTOR
EMPLOYEES OUT OF BUSINESS AND IN
FACT WE PROBABLY NEED ALL OF
THEM.
NOT ONLY WITHIN CDC ARE WE MAYBE
NEED MORE IN C. D. C. R. MAY
EVEN BE MORE ON THE OUTSIDE SO.
I I I I DON'T BELIEVE YOU'RE
LOOKING AT THE A DECREASE IN
AMOUNTS STAFFING.
ON BOTH SIDES YOU'RE LOOKING AT
A WAY THAT WE CAN ADDRESS TO
POPULATION WITH MORE RESOURCES
BECAUSE THAT'S I'VE I'VE HEARD
YOU SENATOR BILL.
TALK ABOUT THIS ALL THE TIME
THAT WE JUST DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
RESOURCES AND SO I DON'T THINK
YOU'RE INTENT.
WITH THIS BILL OR ANY OF YOUR
BILLS IS -- TO IS TO REDUCE
STAFFING ON ON ANY LEVEL AND A
AND THEN THE LAST THING I JUST
LEAVE IT LEAVE YOU WITH.
AS PEOPLE DO WHAT IT'S A PEOPLE
START LOOKING AT REHABILITATION
WE'RE ALL LOOKING AT WAYS TO
MAKE IT BETTER.
RALPH LOOKING AT WAYS TO CURB
WAY THROUGH ALSO LOOKING AT WAYS
THAT.
ROOMS THAT AREN'T FUNCTIONING
THAT WE DO THINGS DIFFERENTLY.
AND NOT TO USE A MENTAL HEALTH
PHRASE BUT WERE YOU CALL SOMEONE
TO DO THE SAME THING OVER AND
OVER AND OVER AGAIN EXPECT A
DIFFERENT RESULT.
OKAY.
SO LET'S.
CONTINUE THIS DISCUSSION ON
CHAIRS RECOMMEND AN AYE VOTE AND
THAT WE MOVE THIS ALONG.
AND THAT THE D..
THE OPPOSITION.
IF THEY HAVE SUGGESTIONS OF WAYS
WE CAN IMPROVE -- RELATIONSHIP
WITH THE MEMBERSHIP THAT THEY
HAVE THEIR INSIGHTS YOU SEE ARE
THAT WE CAN PROVIDE MORE
RESOURCES AND WE CAN BOLSTER
THAT.
THEM PLEASE COME TO THIS
COMMITTEE COME TO THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE WHICH I ALSO SAID ON
M. BUT I THINK.
CENTRE BELL AND I WILL WORK TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE BOTH SAID THAT
PART TOO BECAUSE THAT'S A
SIGNIFICANT PART OF MAKING THIS
WHOLE SYSTEM WORK WE SHOULD NOT
BE BITING AT POINT.
GOING AT ONE ANOTHER WE SHOULD
BE WORKING TOGETHER TO CREATE A
HOLISTIC APPROACH AND AND
GETTING THIS DONE -- MISTER
CHAIRMAN I GREW UP TO OF A AYE
AYE I'M SORRY I'M THE LAST ONE
TO SPEAK YOU'RE THE LAST YES.
I'D LIKE TO REASON REASON I HAVE
TO DO THAT BECAUSE I'VE CUT OFF
REPUBLICANS AND GOTTEN INTO
TROUBLE SO.
I HAVE TO CUT YOU OFF.
TO SB TWO EIGHTY TO THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO THE HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE
JONES SAWYER.
CHEN SIR IRAQI.
LACKEY NOT BOATING BARRICADE
HAND BACKING AND I AM MATHIS.
MATHIS I KAMLAGER-DOVE.
QUIRK QUIRK I SANTIAGO
[inaudible]
WICKS.
SO CALLED ME AS ONE MORE THANK
YOU.
YEAH.
BUFFY LEFT THE MEMBERS NOW SIR
WITH.
SIR WE HAVE A MEMBER SO WE NEED
[inaudible] FIVE FIVE SENATOR
NIELSEN TO JUMP OUT REAL QUICK.
YOU'RE AT THE BOTTOM PRODUCES NO
ONE ELSE.
ALL THE EQUIPMENT INSTRUMENTS.
YOU LUCKED OUT THANK YOU FOR
THAT INDULGENCE.
AT NO YOU'RE HERE SO THE THIS
BILL HELPING US KIND OF EXPANDS
ON THOSE.
WHO INGEST NITROUS OXIDE?
CAN FACE DIRE CONSEQUENCES THIS
WAS BROUGHT TO MY ATTENTION BY
TWO FAMILIES WHOSE.
YOUTH.
WE'RE USING NITROUS OXIDE.
THEY WERE OVER.
EIGHTEEN AND WE'RE SEVERELY
HARMED FORTUNATELY THEY SURVIVED
IN.
CAME BACK ONE IS STILL ONLY ABLE
TO MOVE AROUND WITH.
SOME HELP.
BUT WHAT THIS DOES IS TRY TO
MAKE.
LESS AVAILABLE. TO CITIZENS TO
OUR YOUTH.
END SMOKE SHOPS.
THESE NITROUS OXIDE CANISTERS.
AND THE WEAPONS WHICH ARE
INDUSTRIAL CREAM DEVICES THAT
ARE MODIFIED. TO ALLOW THE
ATTACHMENT OF THE NITROUS OXIDE
CANISTERS.
THE FATHER REFUSE ME THE MOTHER
OF ONE OF THE YOUTH THAT WAS
[inaudible]
SO ADDICTED.
SHE FOUND TWO HUNDRED CANISTERS.
HIS CAR.
AND I'M INFORMED THAT THIS IS A
VERY BRIEF HIGH.
DOES NOT LAST LONG HENCE THE
OVER USE OF THEM.
SMOKE SHOP TO BECOME VERY
POPULAR [inaudible]
AND FREQUENTED.
MANY DIFFERENT THINGS ARE SOLD
THERE IN.
INCLUDING VARIOUS AND SUNDRY
SMOKING DEVICES.
THIS BILL THEN WOULD MAKE THAT A
MISDEMEANOR. TO SELL THESE
CANISTERS.
MAKE AVAILABLE TO THE PUBLIC.
AND THAT'S WHAT OUR INTENT.
IS TO DO. TO MAKE THEM LESS
AVAILABLE TO THE PUBLIC.
THAT I DID I HOPE WE HAVE
WITNESSES BUT IT WAS ON CONSENT
SO I DIDN'T ASK ANY WITNESSES SO
THAT'S ALL I HAVE TO PRESENT
MISTER CHAIRMAN.
THANK YOU MEMBERS WE HAVE A
MOTION SECOND AND ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
ANY.
SOMEBODY GOT UP.
WE DO HAVE SOMEONE HERE.
GOOD MORNING MAPPERS ALL ON
BEHALF OF LOS ANGELES COUNTY
SHERIFF IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
AND I AND ARE YOU QUESTIONS AND
I KNOW.
MR MATHIS FIRST [inaudible]
SURE.
QUIRK -- I THINK THIS IS A VERY
MEASURED BILL YOU'RE ONLY --
PREVENTING YOU FROM PLACES THAT
PEOPLE MIGHT GO TO AND TRY AT
YOUR ALLOWING THE LEGAL USE I
THINK IT'S VERY MEASURED BILL
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING IT
FORWARD.
THANK YOU SOME LIMóN.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
I KNOW -- DE IN.
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER THAT PULLED
IT IS NOT HERE AND I HAVE NO
IDEA WHAT.
THEIR QUESTION WAS.
OF YEAH.
SO -- YOU MAY CLOSE I WOULD
INDULGE WITH THE I VOTE.
WITH MY APPRECATION.
AND I'M RECOMMENDED AYE VOTE.
CALL ROLE ON AS THE ONE NINETY
THREE THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
THE BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER OPTIONS
ARE IRAQI.
LACKEY AYE BARRICADE HAN PARKING
CAN I MATHIS.
MATHIS I KAMLAGER-DOVE.
QUIRK.
QUIRK I SANTIAGO.
WICKS WICKS I THAT MEASURE
PASSES THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
THANK YOU MEMBERS [inaudible]
WIENER PORTANTINO [inaudible]
MADALENA DORADO.
JEFF STONE'S STEVE GLAZER CHIANG.
CABALLERO.
GALGIANI WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD
SENATORS RIGHT NOW
.
IF MR PORTANTINO SHOWS OUT WE
GET RID OF FOR HIM ONE PERSON
.
WE HAVE A SIXTEEN MORE BILLS.
SEVEN NOVEMBER BETWEEN WIENER
AND PORTANTINO.
IF DOES TO SHOW UP WILL BE
FINISHED WITH HALF.
OF THE REMAINING WE HAVE
[inaudible]
WE HAVE [inaudible]
YES.
YES WE WILL CLOSE.
THE COMMITTEE AT ELEVEN THIRTY
MANDATORY MEETING.
THAT WE NEED TO GO.
TO HEY WE WANT RECONVENE.
UNTIL FOR THIS AFTERNOON.
AND I WON'T BE HERE IT FOR SO IF
ANYONE WANTS A BILL PASSED.
THEY BETTER GET HERE SOONER.
THE STONE PLEASE [inaudible]
SOUNDS GOOD.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN OF
MORNING AUDIBLE SOME WOMEN --
I'M VERY HAPPY TO PRESENT THE SB.
THREE NINETY THREE CALIFORNIA
LAW CURRENTLY PROVIDES THAT A
SOMEONE IS CHARGED WITH DRIVING
UNDER THE INFLUENCE THEIR
VEHICLE CAN BE IMPOUNDED UP TO
THIRTY DAYS.
WELL THE LOS CLEAR ABOUT THE
RULES FOR IMPOUNDING A VEHICLE
THAT WAS USED BY SOMEONE DRIVING
UNDER THE INFLUENCE OF LAW IS
LESS CLEAR.
ON THE RULES FOR BOATING THAT
HAS BEEN USED IN A BOATING UNDER
THE INFLUENCE ACCIDENT OR A. B.
YOU AYE.
THIS WAS DISCOVERED WHEN TALKING
TO ONE OF MY CONSTITUENTS
BELINDA MARGIE ODA.
WHILE ENJOYING A BOARDING TRIP
WITH HER FAMILY AND FRIENDS ON
THE COLORADO RIVER.
THEY WERE HIT BY A VEHICLE THE
WHOLE BOAT GOING THIRTY FIVE
MILES PER HOUR.
BELINDA AND THREE OTHERS
SUFFERED INJURIES INCLUDING THE
DRUNK DRIVER.
SERRA MELINDA'S DAUGHTER DIED.
SHE WAS ONLY TEN YEARS OLD.
ALTHOUGH THE PERPETRATORS BUT
ALCOHOL CONTENT WAS NEARLY THREE
TIMES THE LEGAL LIMIT.
HE NEVER LOST OWNERSHIP OF HIS
BOAT WHICH WAS ULTIMATELY HIS
WEAPON.
SB THREE NINETY THREE STATES
THAT OF A VESSEL ISSUES IN THE
COMMISSION OF A B. Y. INVOLVING
THE UNLAWFUL KILLING OF A PERSON
THAT THAT VESSEL.
WILL BE SUBJECT TO THE SAME
SEIZURE AN IMPOUND RULES AS A
VEHICLE USE IN A D. YOU ARE.
SB THREE NINETY THREE IS A
SIMPLE MEASURE TO ALIGN OUR
WATERWAYS B. Y. LAWS WITH OUR
ROADWAY DO YOU I LAWS.
AND IS PASSED OUT OF THE SENATE.
UNANIMOUSLY -- WITH ME TODAY NOT
SURE SHE'S HERE -- LARRY MORSE
THE DIRECTOR OF LEGISLATION FOR
THE CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION.
NICE TO SEE YOU THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE AND RECALL ONE OF A
REQUEST -- ABOUT.
MISTER MORRIS PLEASE DON'T TALK
PAST YES.
THANK YOU -- GERMAN MEMBERS
LAURIE MORSE CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION WE ARE
PLEASED TO SUPPORT SENATOR
STONE'S SB.
THREE NINETY THREE WHICH WILL
ESTABLISH THAT A VESSEL IF USED
IN THE COMMISSION OF A VOTING
UNDER THE INFLUENCE CRIME THE
VESSEL WILL BE SUBJECT TO THE
SAME.
SEARCH AND SEIZURE IMPOUND RULES
AS A VEHICLE USED IN A DO YOU
WHY.
AS WE MOVE INTO THE HEIGHT OF
THE SUMMER SEASON WE ALSO MOVE
INTO BOATING AND WATER SPORTS
SEASON ON CALIFORNIA'S WATER
WAYS.
UNFORTUNATELY EACH YEAR BRINGS
ANOTHER ROUND OF TRAGIC
ACCIDENTS OF LOSS OF LIFE.
CAUSED BY THOSE WHO OPERATE
THEIR VESSELS WHILE UNDER THE
INFLUENCE OF ALCOHOL DRUGS OR
BOTH IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
ALCOHOL WAS THE A CONTRIBUTING
FACTOR.
IN ONE HUNDRED AND TWO BOATING
DEATHS AND DRUG USE WAS A
CONTRIBUTING FACTOR FOR ANOTHER
TEN TO US ACCORDING TO THE COAST
GUARD.
CALIFORNIA LAW PROPERLY AND
APPROPRIATELY RECOGNIZES THE
SAME STANDARD OF INTOXICATION TO
THOSE OPERATING A VESSEL AS A
SOMEONE OPERATING THE VEHICLE ON
OUR STREETS NAMELY A BLOOD
ALCOHOL LEVEL OF POINT. ZERO
EIGHT FOUR ABOVE.
THIS BILL WOULD FURTHER CONFORM
THOSE LAWS BY ALLOWING FOR THE
SEIZURE AND IMPOUNDING OF ABOUT
WHAT IT HAS BEEN INVOLVED IN THE
UNLAWFUL KILLING OF A PERSON.
SIGNIFICANTLY IT DOES NOT
MANDATE THE SEIZURE OR IF ON
IMPOUNDING OF A BOAT A JUDGE MAY
STILL CONSIDER THE LOSS OF
EMPLOYMENT.
ABILITY TO PAY IMPOUND FEES OR
UNFAIR INFRINGEMENT UPON
COMMUNITY PROPERTY RIGHTS IN
DETERMINING WHETHER TO SEIZE THE
VESSEL.
R. D. Y. LOS AND A CLEAR AND
UNMISTAKABLE MESSAGE ABOUT OUR
IN TOLERANCE FOR THOSE WHO GET
BEHIND THE WHEEL OF VEHICLES
WHILE UNDER THE INFLUENCE OF
ALCOHOL AND DRUGS.
OUR B. Y. LOS MISS ON THE SAME
MESSAGE IN SB THREE NINE THREE
IS AN IMPORTANT CONTRIBUTION. TO
PROTECTING THE HEALTH AND SAFETY
OF ALL THOSE WHO USE
CALIFORNIA'S WATER WAYS WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
YOUR ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
MORNING MR MEMBERS RANCHERA WITH
THE RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S
ASSOCIATION SUPPORT THANK YOU
ARE ANY WITNESS IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
SEEING NONE.
IT BY A BRICK HELLO MEMBERS
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF COMMITTEE
BRAKE LIGHT FELT THE WITH.
THE CALIFORNIA HARBOR MASTER'S
IMPORT CAPTAINS THE MARINE
RECREATION ASSOCIATION AND ALSO --
THE OPERA BECAUSE IS ASSOCIATION
E JUST HAVE A SLIGHT CAN WE ARE
IN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
PRIMARILY FOR A RELEASE OF
LIABILITY FOR THE PRIVATE MARINO
AND THEY'RE SO.
RIGHT NOW THERE'S NO LANGUAGE IN
THERE TO GIVE A THEM I DENIM
IDENTIFICATION ON THAT SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH [inaudible]
OKAY.
THE NEW ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION ANY QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEBERS YES MISTER
QUIRK YES -- SENATOR SENATOR HAD
THE OPPOSITION COME TO YOU
BEFORE ON THIS ISSUE.
OUR OUR STAFF HAS BEEN MEETING
WITH THEM -- WE'RE GONNA
CONTINUE TO MEET WITH THEM AND
TRY TO REACH A APPROPRIATE
COMPROMISE I THINK WHAT THEY'RE
ASKING FOR IS NOT UNREASONABLE.
ALRIGHT WELL I WILL CERTAINLY BE
SUPPORTING YOUR BILL EVEN THOUGH
YOUR WITNESS TALK PAST YES
[inaudible]
I APOLOGIZE.
YES SIR ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
YES AND I GUESS YOUR DRESS TO BE
Y. BOATING UNDER THE INFLUENCE.
LATER YES SIR THANK YOU FOR IT
YOU MAY CLOSE THANK YOU I JUST --
THIS THIS HAPPENED AFTER A
TRAGIC INCIDENT AS YOU KNOW --
RIVERSIDE COUNTY THE EASTERN
PORTION -- ALLIANCE WITH THE THE
COLORADO RIVER SO OUR OUR
SHERIFF IS -- PATROLLING THOSE
WATERS ON THAT SIDE OF THE RIVER --
UNFORTUNATELY WE SEE THE THE
NEEDLESS LOSS OF LIVES EVERY
SINGLE YEAR ON THE RIVER BECAUSE
OF PEOPLE -- DRINKING OR
UTILIZING DRUGS FALL --
RECREATIONALLY BOATING AND SO
I'M HOPING THAT -- WE CAN --
CURB SOME OF THE SENSELESS LOSS
OF LIFE.
AND FOR THOSE REASONS I REQUEST --
EURO YOU'RE ON A BOAT TODAY
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
OF JEFF RECOMMEND AYE VOTE.
CHOLERA.
ON SB THREE NINETY THREE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER HI JOHN SIR HI LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE BARRICADE HAN.
BARRICADE HAND HI MATHIS.
MATHIS I'D KAMLAGER-DOVE
[inaudible]
QUIRK [inaudible]
I SANTIAGO.
WICKS WICKS I THE MEASURE PASSES
THANK YOU MISTER SOME
[inaudible]
PORTANTINO.
I SENATOR DORADO.
SB THREE SEVEN FIVE ITEM NUMBER
[inaudible]
SIXTY THE CAMPAIGN.
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY OKAY GOOD
MORNING.
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS AND OF
MISTER CHAIR I WANT TO BEGIN BY
SAYING THAT I HAVE AGREED TO THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS WHICH ARE
REFLECTED IN THE ANALYSIS.
SO AS PROPOSED TO BE AMENDED SB
THREE SEVENTY FIVE EXTENDS FROM
THREE YEARS TO TEN YEARS THE
TIME LIMIT FOR CRIME SURVIVORS
TO APPLY FOR HELP.
FROM THE CALIFORNIA VICTIMS
COMPENSATION BOARD IN PAIN FOR
BILLS AND EXPENSES THAT RESULT
FROM VIOLENT CRIME.
UNDER THE CURRENT LAW SURVIVORS
WHO ARE UNAWARE OF THE PROGRAM
OR WHO ARE NOT YET READY. TO
APPLY OR REWARD ADDRESSING THE
TRAUMA YEARS AFTER THE
VICTIMIZATION.
MAY BE LEFT WITH NO FINANCIAL
SUPPORT OR ACCESS TO THE
RESOURCES THEY NEED.
YOUNGER VICTIMS LATINO AND BLACK
VICTIMS ARE MORE LIKELY TO BE
UNAWARE.
BUT INTERESTED IN VICTIMS
COMPENSATION ASSISTANCE WELL WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THE RESTITUTION
FUND IS GOING THROUGH CHANGES WE
ARE COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH
CAL B. C. B. AND THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE.
AS CONVERSATIONS AROUND FUNDING
CONTINUE.
BUT ONE THING IS FOR SURE.
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA CANNOT
IGNORE THE THOUSANDS OF
SURVIVORS IN OUR STATE WE
PROVIDE.
BILLIONS TO THE PRISON SYSTEM WE
NEED TO SHOW A SIMILAR RESOLVED
FOR THOSE WHO HAVE SURVIVED THE
CRIMES.
PASSING AS BE THREE SEVENTY FIVE
IS ONE OF MANY STEPS WE MUST
TAKE TO ENSURE THAT MEN WOMEN
AND CHILDREN WHO HAVE SURVIVED
TO CRIME ARE SUPPORTED AND HAVE
ACCESS TO THE SERVICES THEY NEED.
TO HEAL WE WANT TO CONTINUE
MOVING FORWARD IN OUR STATE WE
CANNOT CONTINUE WITH INEFFECTIVE
POLICIES.
THE FAILED TO MEET THE NEEDS OF
SURVIVORS WITH ME TODAY I HAVE
TWO WITNESSES DENISE HOLLINS THE
STATE DIRECTOR FOR CRIME
SURVIVORS FOR SAFETY AND JUSTICE.
AND ANDREA PERRY POLICY ADVOCATE
FOR CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE.
THANK YOU YOU HAVE FIVE MINUTES
TOTAL AND SPLIT UP ANYWHERE YOU
WANT.
THANK YOU SENATOR DRAWS A FREE
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ITEM FOR
SHARING THIS TIME WITH ME TODAY
GOOD MORNING TO ALL OF YOU.
MY NAME IS TO NEEDS HIGHLANDS
AND THE CALIFORNIA STATE
DIRECTOR FOR CRIME SURVIVORS WHO
SAFETY AND JUSTICE.
I'M HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
TWELVE THOUSAND CALIFORNIA CRIME
SURVIVORS IN MY NETWORK.
WHO ARE ADVOCATING TO REMOVE
THEIR YEARS FIRM VICTIMS
COMPENSATION INTO INCREASE
ACCESS TO HEALING IN TERM
RECOVERY SERVICES?
I'M A MOTHER I'M A LONG TIME
ADVOCATE FOR VIOLENCE PREVENTION
MY COMMUNITY.
AND I'M A CRIME SURVIVOR. SIX
YEARS AGO TODAY ON JAN ON JUNE
TWENTY FIFTH.
TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN MY BROTHER
JAMES SMITH.
WE SHOT AND KILLED IN SAN
FRANCISCO.
AT THE TIME OF HIS DEATH I WAS A
COUNTY SOCIAL WORKER.
SUPPORTING FAMILIES IN CRISIS.
BUT WHEN MY BROTHER WAS KILLED.
MY FAMILY SPIRALED INTO CRISIS.
I BECAME INTIMATELY FAMILIAR
WITH TRAUMA AND WHAT IT DOES.
MY TERM RESPONSE MY BROTHER'S
DEATH WAS TO BECOME A FIRST
RESPONDER TO MY REVIEW FAMILY.
JAMES IS MOTHER'S TRAUMA
RESPONSE WAS TO ISOLATE HERSELF
FOR MONTHS AFTER HIS FUNERAL SHE
REFUSED.
TO SPEAK TO ANYONE AND ACCESS
THEIR P..
SHE REFUSED ANY SERVICES WERE
CONNECTED TO OUR SON'S DEATH.
MY FOR SURVIVING SIBLINGS WERE
STRUGGLING EMOTIONALLY AND
FINANCIALLY THE LAST JOBS WERE
THREATENED WITH EVICTION.
SOME EXPERIENCE MENTAL HEALTH
EPISODES.
THEY ALL NEEDED IMMEDIATE
SUPPORT.
AND WERE DENIED VICTIMS
COMPENSATION FOR SAFETY REASONS
WHEN THEY LEARNED THAT THOSE
SERVICES WERE CONNECTED TO THE
DA'S OFFICE. FOUR YEARS AFTER
LOSING GAMES ALLOWS THE SECOND
BROTHER TO HOMICIDE ON JANUARY
FIRST.
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN MY
BROTHER MITCHELL WAS KILLED.
WHATEVER FRAGMENTS WERE HOLDING
OUR FAMILY TOGETHER AFTER JAMES
IS DEATH WERE NEARLY DESTROYED
AFTER MITCHELL.
I KNEW THAT I DIDN'T HAVE THE
BAND WITH TO HOLD MYSELF
TOGETHER MY FAMILY TOGETHER
THROUGH THIS TRACK THROUGH A
TRAGEDY OF THIS MAGNITUDE FOR
THE SECOND TIME.
AS OUR TO RECOGNIZE THE SYMPTOMS
OF TRAUMA AND PTSD THAT I WAS
EXPERIENCING.
AND THE TRAUMAS THAT MY FAMILY
HAD EXPERIENCE THAT IT LED TO
THOSE TWO DEATHS.
I WAS LUCKY ENOUGH TO MAKE THE
DECISION TO START RECEIVING THE
SUPPORT THAT I NEEDED FOR MYSELF
AND MY CHILDREN.
I WISH THAT I COULD SAY THAT THE
REST OF MY FAMILY MEMBERS HAVE
DONE THE SAME.
I'M HERE TODAY TO MAKE SURE THAT
WHEN THEY ARE READY THEY HAVE
ACCESS TO THOSE SERVICES.
SEEING SB THREE SEVENTY FIVE IS
ABOUT MORE THAN A TIME TABLE IS
ABOUT PUBLIC SAFETY.
IT'S ABOUT CENTERING THE NEEDS
OF PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN MOST
IMPACTED BY CRIME BECAUSE IF
WE'RE ABLE TO ADDRESS THE TRAUMA
THAT THEY'VE EXPERIENCED.
AND ALLOW THEM TO STABILIZE
THEIR LIVES THE LIKELIHOOD THAT
THEY'LL BE SAFE IN THE
COMMUNITIES OF THE SAFE WILL BE
GREATER WHAT DO WE KNOW TO BE A
FACT ONE TO THREE ONE IN THREE
PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA EXPERIENCE
CRIME.
THE BIGGEST PREDICTOR OF BEING A
VICTIM OF CRIME IS THAT YOU'VE
BEEN A VICTIM BEFORE AS IN THE
CASE OF MY FAMILY.
THE PEOPLE EXPERIENCING CHRONIC
A REPEAT VICTIMISATION.
ARE LEAST LIKELY TO ACCESS ANY
KIND OF HELP.
AND THAT MEANS THAT WE NEED TO
CHANGE THE WAY THAT WE THINK
ABOUT WHO NEED SUPPORT AND HOW
THESE RULES WORK FOR THEM.
WE AS A STATE OR IN THE PROCESS
OF BECOMING MORE TRAUMA INFORMED.
WE UNDERSTAND AND KNOW SO MUCH
MORE ABOUT WHAT THAT MEANS AND
WE'RE WORKING EVERY DAY TO BE
MORE RESPONSIVE TO THE NEEDS OF
OUR COMMUNITY.
THE VAST MAJORITY OF VICTIMS
DAHLE ACCESS VICTIMS
COMPENSATION BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT
CONNECT TO THE JUSTICE SYSTEM
AND EVEN REPORTING CRIME.
BUT THAT DOESN'T MEAN THAT THE
TRAUMA DOESN'T EXIST IN THAT WE
DON'T NEED TO MAKE IT A PRIORITY
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE DOING
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO ADDRESS IT.
WITHOUT REPEATEDLY IN STUDIES
THAT PEOPLE ARE MORE LIKELY TO
REPORT TO THEIR FRIENDS OR TO A
HOSPITAL THEN TO THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM THIS IS
ESPECIALLY TRUE FOR PEOPLE OF
COLOR IN COMMUNITIES.
THAT EXPERIENCE REPEAT
VICTIMISATION SO WE MUST MAKE
THE WHOLE SYSTEM MORE ACCESSIBLE
AND MORE COUNTABLE.
OVER THE CHANGES THAT NEED TO
HAPPEN FOR VOTER WILL BEGINS IN
CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU -- MY NAME IS ANDREA
TERRY ON THE POLICY ADVOCATE FOR
CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE AND WE ARE EXTREMELY
GRATEFUL TO SENATOR ALSO FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD AS WELL AS
THE CHAIR.
AND COMMITTEE STAFF WHO WORKED
WITH US ON THIS BILL -- CRIMES
RIVERS FOR SAFETY AND JUSTICE IS
PROUD TO SPONSOR THIS BILL -- WE
THINK THAT SOME OF THE SERVICES
THAT ARE PROVIDED BY CAL THE CB --
SUCH AS PHYSICAL AT BEING
PHYSICALLY INJURED OR THREATENED
WITH INJURY IT ALSO PROVIDES
REIMBURSEMENTS FOR MEDICAL
TREATMENT MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
FUNERAL EXPENSES -- HOME
SECURITY -- THIS BILL WILL
DECREASE BARRIERS FOR CRIMES
REVERSED ACCESS NECESSARY TRAUMA
RECOVERY RESOURCES THAT SUPPORT
AND COUNSELING THE FISCAL IMPACT.
OF NOT HELPING THE MOST
VULNERABLE ARE FAR GREATER THAN
THE SPECIFIC COST OF PROVIDING
COMPENSATION THE FISCAL IMPACTS
ARE PART OF WHAT HAPPENS WHEN
CHRONIC TRAUMA GOES AND DRESSED
INCLUDING COST OF HEALTH CARE
THE COST OF THE HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM FOR PEOPLE THAT FALL
THROUGH THE CRACKS.
SELF MEDICATING CANNOT MAINTAIN
STABLE EMPLOYMENT -- EMPLOYMENT
AND CANNOT MAINTAIN FAMILY
STABILITY OR FALL INTO A HOLE
AND THEY MAY FINALLY FALL INTO
HOMELESSNESS WE JUST WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU SINCE MY TIME IS
PROBABLY UP THANK YOU.
THANK YOU BYE MINUTES EXACTLY.
THE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT NAME AN ORGANIZATION.
GOOD MORNING DEREK MORGAN FOR
THE ELEVATOR CENTER FOR HUMAN
RIGHTS HERE IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ARIANNA POSTO HERE THE ELEVATOR
CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS HERE IN
SUPPORT.
IF THE POLITE NICK FROM THE ELLA
BAKER CENTER AND THE BERKELEY
AND NAY H. C. P. AND SUPPORT.
KHLOE ENGLISH FROM THE ELEVATOR
CENTER IN SUPPORT.
LARA HAYWORTH FROM THE ELEVATOR
DYLAN THOMAS FROM THE ELLA BAKER
CENTER IN SUPPORT.
I FIND THE DRAU ELLA BAKER
CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS IN
SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
RAIN SHERMAN ON BEHALF OF CRIME
VICTIMS ACTION ALLIANCE IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ARE ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
CNN ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
MR LACKEY YEAH I JUST HAVE A
COMMENT THIS IS CLEARLY.
GREATLY APPRECIATED THAT YOU
BROUGHT THIS FORWARD BUT I HAVE
TO REMIND.
THIS COMMITTEE AND THIS
INSTITUTION.
THAT -- THE VICTIMSCOMPENSATION
RESTITUTION FUND IS ON THE FAST
TRAIN FOR INSOLVENCY.
AND WE BETTER DRESS AS WE'RE
DOING ALL THESE VERY NOBLE --
POLICY BILLS RELATING TO THIS
BUT IF WE CAN'T DELIVER -- AND
THIS IS CRUEL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MS WORKS.
I JUST WANTED TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR THE BILL AND THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY IT'S
GREATLY APPRECIATED HERE -- WHEN
AT MYSELF AS A CO AUTHOR THANK
YOU?
MR QUIRK YEAH I HAVE THE SAME
CONCERNS MISTER LACKEY THAT'S
I'M SCORE SUPPORTING THE BILL.
AND THE AMENDMENT THAT WAS TAKEN
BASICALLY MAKES THE STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS ON HOW FAR YOU CAN
GO BACK UNIFORM. FOR THE WHOLE
SYSTEM WHICH I THINK IS VERY
APPROPRIATE NOW A GREAT WAY TO
SIMPLIFY.
BUT WE DO HAVE A PROBLEM A
MISTER CHAIR YOU'RE IN THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE JUST SAYING.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS. EIGHT YOU
MAY CLOSE CENTER.
THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
COMMENTS IN SUPPORT AND I ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE I ALSO WANT TO
THANK THE WITNESSES FOR YOU
COURAGE FOR BEING HERE.
THE TWO A THANK TO WITNESSES AND
THE CHAIRS RECOMMENDING AN AYE
VOTE IN THE CHAIR WILL BE
WORKING ON FUNDING.
THE WAR.
VICTIMS COMPENSATION FUND.
AND SO WE SUCCESSFUL BUT I AM
GOING TO WORK ON ON SB THREE
SEVENTY FIVE THE MISSION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER.
BY JONES -- I LACKEY LACKEY I
OUR QUE HAN BARRICADE HAD AYE
MATHIS.
MATHIS I KAMLAGER-DOVE.
QUIRK AYE QUIRK AYE SANTIAGO.
WICKS WICKS I THE MEASURE PASSES
THANK YOU CENTER CHIANG
.
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
OF A DESPITE YEARS A COMMENDABLE
EFFORTS TO COMBAT SLAVERY AND
TRAFFICKING THIS IS STILL CRIME
THAT CALIFORNIA'S FIGHTING TODAY.
HUMAN FROM.
HUMAN TRAFFICKING REMAINS
WIDESPREAD IN CALIFORNIA
EIGHTEEN YEARS AGO CALIFORNIA'S
I WAS THE FIRST CALIFORNIA LINES
COMBAT TRAFFICKING SLAVERY TASK
FORCE.
THE FIRST REPORT LAID THE
GROUNDWORK FOR COORDINATED
COLLABORATIVE RESPONSE COMBATING
SEX AND LABOR TRAFFICKING
CALIFORNIA.
THERE IS MUCH MORE WORK TO BE
DONE IN PARTICULAR THIS TASK
FORCE WILL PROVIDE A ROADMAP FOR
A PREVALENCE STUDY IN CALIFORNIA.
WE NEED TO UNDERSTAND THIS
CRIMINAL ENTERPRISE MORE DETAIL
LEVEL AND THE TIME IS RIGHT TO
RECONVENE THESE LEADERS AND
REALIGN OUR HUMAN TRAFFICKING
SUPPRESSION STRATEGY.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR SUPPORT
TODAY IN WITH ME TO EXPAND ON
WHAT THIS TASK FORCE IS ABOUT IS.
KNOWING HE QUIT WAS REPRESENTING
THE COALITION TO ABOLISH SLAVERY
AND TRAFFICKING.
TURN MEMBERS MELANIE CUEVAS WITH
CAN TANA WATSON HURT MAN ON
BEHALF OF CAST THE COALITION TO
ABOLISH SLAVERY AND TRAFFICKING
CAST AS AN LA BASED GROUP WITH
THE LARGEST ANDLONGEST RUNNING
COMPREHENSIVE SERVICE PROVIDER
TO VICTIMS OF MODERN DAY SLAVERY.
AND ALSO WAS A REPRESENTATIVE ON
PRIOR TASK FORCES I'D LIKE TO
START BY THANKING THE SENATOR
FOR HER LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE
AND FOR RECOGNIZING THE DIRE
NEED FOR DATA -- IN THIS REALM --
AS THE SENATOR EXPLAINED SB
THIRTY FIVE RECONVENES AN
ALREADY ESTABLISHED TASK FORCE
UNDER THE AUSPICES OF RECORD OF
AN EXAMINING AND RECOMMENDING TO
THE LEGISLATURE SPECIFIC ISSUES
RELATED TO HUMAN TRAFFICKING --
I'D LIKE TO SHARE SOME PRIOR
FINDINGS WITH THE COMMITTEE TO
ILLUSTRATE THE IMPORTANCE OF
RECONVENING THIS TASK FORCE.
I'M IN TWO THOUSAND SEVEN A
REPORT REVEALED THAT SHELTER IS
A VICTIMS MOST CRITICAL NEED.
AND THAT CALIFORNIA LOCKED
APPROPRIATE FACILITIES TO
ADDRESS THIS NEED.
SINCE THEN THE LEGISLATURE HAS
RECOGNIZED THE IMPORTANCE OF
FINDING SPECIALIZED SERVICES FOR
VICTIMS OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING IN
Q. CLOTHING SHELTER -- AND WE
HAVE ESTABLISHED THE HUMAN
TRAFFICKING VICTIMS ASSISTANCE
FIND OUT THROUGH THE BUDGET
PROCESS NOW TWENTY ONE AN NGO
SERVICE PROVIDERS HAVE RECEIVED
GRANTS TO THE SOURCE OF FUNDING
IN THE PROVIDE NOT ONLY SHELTER
BUT COMPREHENSIVE WRAPAROUND
SERVICES TO VICTIMS OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING IN CALIFORNIA.
AND AND IN FACT THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET INCLUDED A TEN MILLION
DOLLAR ON GOING APPROPRIATION TO
THE SPOT.
AND THE ORIGINAL REPORT FIRST
FINDING ALSO SEE THAT THAT
CALIFORNIA LACKS COMPREHENSIVE
DATA ON HUMAN TRAFFICKING AND
UNFORTUNATELY THIS IS STILL TRUE.
SB THIRTY FIVE TAKE SOME
PRACTICAL STEPS TOWARD THE
DRESSING NOT GAP BY RECONVENING
THE TASK FORCE AND ASKING TO
MAKE DEFINITIVE RECOMMENDATIONS
ON DATA ON SH SEX TRAFFICKING
LABOR TRAFFICKING FORCED
CRIMINALITY AND R. C. AND TRAUMA
INFORMED APPROACHES TO BOTH.
ENFORCEMENT AND APPROACHING
VICTIMS -- IT IS OUR SINCERE
HOPE THAT THIS WILL LEAD TO MORE
POWERFUL AND IMPACTFUL POLICY
AND THAT IT WILL EMPOWER THE
LEGISLATURE TO ALLOCATE
RESOURCES TO TARGETING VICTIMS
GREATEST NEEDS.
ON BEHALF OF THE VICTIMS WE
SERVE IN THOSE STILL IN SLAVE IN
CALIFORNIA WE RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ORDER ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
NAME AN ORGANIZATION.
AND A KELLY WITH THE ALAMEDA
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
RANGER WITH THE RIVERSIDE
SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION AND ALSO
ON BEHALF OF CRIME VICTIMS
EXCELLENCE AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
LEARN MORE CDA IN SUPPORT OF
BILL.
THANK YOU.
JONATHON FELDMAN CALIFORNIA
POLICE CHIEFS ASSOCIATION
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE ANY QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS COMMENTS.
WITH SO LACKEY.
DID YOU WANT VOTERS.
YEAH I JUST HAD A REAL QUICK
QUESTION ON THIS THIS IS CLEARLY --
A VERY COMMENDABLE.
POSTAL BUT IT IS STILL SEEMS
UNCLEAR IS WHO'S GOING TO CHAIR
THIS TASK FORCE AND I THINK THAT.
IS SUCCESS.
KIND OF DEPENDS ON THAT
DESIGNATION SO IF YOU COULD HELP
ME UNDERSTAND THAT I WOULD LOVE
THAT RIGHT SO -- THAT AMENDMENT
WAS MADE IN THE SENATE -- BUT
IT'S IMPLICIT THAT THE COMMITTEE
SHOULD BUT WILL BE CHOOSING THE
CHAIR [inaudible]
BUT IF YOU.
SO DESIRE WE CAN PUT IT BACK IN
IF.
WHO ORGANIZES ALL THAT TIME
CONFUSED BY THAT?
I'D BE HAPPY TO ADD ON TO THAT
PREVIOUS TASK FORCE WERE CONVENE
BY THE ATTORNEYS GENERAL OFFICE
AND THAT WAS STRIPPED IN THE
SENATE APPROPRIATION AMENDMENTS
WE ARE NOW LOOKING.
TO HE IS FOR A POTENTIAL CHAIR
OF IT -- AND ONE OF THOSE IS CAL --
YES WHO ADMINISTERS THE HUMAN
TRAFFICKING VICTIMS ASSISTANCE
FINE AND WE'VE RECEIVED RAVE
REVIEWS OF THEIR ORCHESTRATION
OF THANK YOU.
OUR K. AND I JUST WANT TO THANK
SENATOR CHIANG FOR BRINGING THIS
MEASURE I HEAR FROM THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S IN THE COUNTIES I
REPRESENT ALL THE TIME ABOUT HOW
THIS IS A BATTLE AND WE'RE
LOSING IT.
WE SEE MORE AND MORE VICTIMS ALL
THE TIME AND SO YOU KNOW WE
SHOULD BE MAKING MORE DATA
DRIVEN DECISIONS AND SO YOUR
EFFORT TO GET DATA I THINK IS
REALLY VALUABLE AND I THINK CAST
SO IF YOU'RE PARTNERSHIP IN THIS
AND I WOULD LOVE TO BE A CO.
AUTHOR [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THE OTHER COMMENTS YOU
[inaudible]
MIKLOS.
IT JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE THANK YOU THANK YOU
CHAIRED RECOMMEND AYE VOTE OR
THE ROLE.
ON SB THIRTY FIVE THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER HI JOHN
SIR I LACKEY.
LACKEY HI BARRICADE HAND BACK A
HAND I MATHIS.
MATHIS I KAMLAGER-DOVE.
QUIRK.
QUIRK I SANTIAGO.
SAN DIEGO I WICKS WICKS HI.
THE MEASURE PASSES
CONGRATULATIONS.
SO I'M GONNA CALL.
MISS GALGIANI UP NEXT AND THEN
RIGHT AFTER DISCOVERY OF YOU
JUST.
JUST INDULGENCE JUST FOR A
MINUTE.
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS SB FIVE
NINETY ONE AUTHORIZES A
PRACTICING PSYCHIATRIST OR
PSYCHOLOGIST FROM THE STATE
DEPARTMENT OF STATE HOSPITALS OR
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION.
TO HAVE PROMPT AND UNIMPEDED
ACCESS TO AN INMATE WAS
TEMPORARILY HOUSED AT A COUNTY
CORRECTIONAL FACILITY.
A COUNTY MEDICAL FACILITY OR A
STATE A SIGN OF MENTAL HEALTH
PROVIDER.
THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW STATE
PSYCHIATRISTS OR PSYCHOLOGISTS
TO HAVE PROMPT ACCESS TO INMATES
RECORDS FOR THE PERIOD OF
CONFINEMENT AT THAT FACILITY IN
ORDER TO COMPLETE A MENTALLY
DISORDERED OFFENDERS EVALUATION.
TO ENSURE THAT MENTALLY
DISORDERED OFFENDERS ARE
PROPERLY EVALUATED AND TREATED
PURSUANT TO PENAL CODE SECTION.
TWO NINE SIX TWO IT IS
IMPERATIVE THAT PSYCHOLOGISTS
AND PSYCHIATRISTS EMPLOYED BY
CDC ARE IN THE DEPARTMENT OF
STATE HOSPITALS HAVE ACCESS TO
THE INMATES HEALTH RECORDS.
AND ACCESS TO THE INMATE.
I UNDERSTAND THERE'S BEEN
CONCERN WITH THE DELETION OF
SECTION.
THREE THOUSAND THREE E. TWO AND
I AM COMMITTED TO RETAINING THAT
SECTION IN THE BILL I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
MY NAME IS DOCTOR ALLISON
STANLEY I AM AND AM DO EVALUATOR
WHICH MEANS AN EVALUATOR
PURSUANT TO PENAL CODE TWENTY
NINE SIXTY TWO FOR CDC ARE --
IT'S COULD YOU SPEAK A LITTLE
MORE LOW YES TO THE MICROPHONE
YES.
AND I'M DOCTOR ALLISON STANLEY I
AM AND A AND M. DO EVALUATOR FOR
CDC ARE WHICH MEANS AN EVALUATOR
PURSUANT TO PENAL CODE.
TWENTY NINE SIXTY TWO IT
SOMETIMES DOES HAPPEN THAT ARE
CDC ARE INMATES.
GO OUT TO COURT FOR SOME TYPE OF
HEARING DEPENDING ON WHATEVER A
PENDING CHARGE A PREVIOUS CHARGE.
A CHILD SUPPORT HEARING WHATEVER
THE CASE MAY BE THEY'RE STILL IN
OUR CUSTODY BUT THEY SIT IN JAIL
AND WAIT FOR THEIR HEARING TO
OCCUR AND THEY CAN BE IN JAIL.
FOR MONTHS IT DEPENDS HOW
IMPACTED THE COURTS ARE.
WHILE THEY'RE IN JAIL IT CAN
OCCUR THAT THEIR PAROLE DATE
HAPPENS THEY'RE REQUIRED BY
STATUTE.
PC TWENTY NINE SIXTY TWO TO BE
EVALUATED FOR POSSIBLE CONTINUE
TREATMENT.
IN A STATE MENTAL INSTITUTION
PRIOR TO THEIR PAROLE DATE.
IN ORDER FOR US TO EVALUATE THEM.
AGAIN THEIR NCDC ARW CUSTODY BUT
THEY'RE SITTING IN A JAIL IN
ORDER FOR US TO EVALUATE THEM
PROMPTLY WE NEED TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THEM WHILE THEY'RE IN THE
JAIL.
THAT DOESN'T ALWAYS HAPPEN THERE
ARE NUMBER OF ROAD BLOCKS THAT
ARE OFTEN ESTABLISHED AND SO IT
MAKES IT VERY DIFFICULT FOR US
TO HAVE THE TOOLS THAT WE NEED.
TO IT HERE TO THE STATUTE AND
SEE THOSE INMATES PLEASE KEEP IN
MIND THAT INMATES WERE EVALUATED
UNDER. TWENTY NINE SIXTY TWO ARE
VIOLENT THEY'VE COMMITTED
VIOLENT OFFENSES AND THERE
POTENTIALLY SEVERELY MENTALLY
ILL.
SOIT'S IMPERATIVE THAT WE HAVE
AN IMPUTED ACCESS TO THOSE
INMATES AND TO THEIR RECORDS.
WHETHER THEY'RE IN CDC ARE OR
WHETHER THEY'RE IN OUR CUSTODY
BUT SITTING IN A COUNTY JAIL.
AS I SAID THAT CURRENTLY DOESN'T
ALWAYS HAPPEN.
AND THAT'S THE INTENT OF THE
BILL WE REALLY NEED TO HAVE
THOSE TOOLS IN ORDER TO ACCESS
THE INMATES TO CARRY OUT THE JOB
THAT WERE.
REQUIRED TO DO.
MISS CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE BY NELSON -- WITH THE
AMERICAN FEDERATION OF STATE
COUNTY MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES.
PLEASE BE TO SPONSOR THE BILL
FOR THE REASONS THAT WERE STATED
BY.
ODD -- DOCTOR STANLEY THINK THIS
A CRITICALLY IMPORTANT PIECE OF
LEGISLATION ENSURING THAT THE
WORKERS WHO ARE HAVE BEEN TASKED
WITH PERFORMING A STATE SERVICE
CAN IN.
DEED AND HAVE THE TOOLS TO
INDEED PERFORM THAT SERVICE --
REGARDLESS OF THE CIRCUMSTANCES --
THAT THEY MIGHT FIND THEMSELVES
OR THAT THEY MAYES MY FIND
THEMSELVES AND THESE CRITICAL
THAT WE HAVE ACCESS -- TO THE
SEMIS -- SO FOR THERE ARE THOSE
REASONS WE LIKE TO ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
.
MARCO GEORGE FROM THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION --
I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHORS AND
HER STAFF FOR THE DISCUSSIONS WE
HAVE A BETTER ABOUT THE BILL
HOWEVER WE STILL REMAIN OPPOSED
TO THIS BILL BECAUSE IT WOULD
ACTUALLY EXPAND.
THE MENTALLY DISORDERED OFFENDER
POPUATION.
ON BAD IS THE NUMBER OF FOLKS
WHO ARE DETAINED.
AN INVOLUNTARY LEE COMMITTED TO
STATE HOSPITALS AFTER THEY HAVE
SERVED THEIR PRISON SENTENCE
[inaudible]
AND THE IT ALL WILL EXPAND SAID
BIO DOT WOWING CDC OUR DOCTORS.
TO BOTH NOT ONLY EVALUATE PEOPLE
WHO ARE INITIALLY RELEASED ON
PAROLE AS THE DOCTOR HAS
DESCRIBED TO MIGHT BE OUT TO
COURT.
BUT IT ALSO ON MAY BE AN
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCE WOULD
ALLOW -- PAROLEES WHO WERE IN
COUNTY JAIL FOR TECHNICAL OR
MINOR VIOLATIONS OR WHO ARE
ALREADY OUT ON PAROLE AND
PERHAPS A BEEN. FIFTY ONE FIFTY
TO THE LOCAL -- COUNTY HOSPITAL
TO BE EVALUATED [inaudible]
AND THE MTO LAW TWENTY NINE
SIXTY WAS FIRST ENACTED OVER
TWENTY YEARS AGO TO DETAIN
PRISONERS WHOSE MENTAL ILLNESS
PLAYED A SIGNIFICANT ROLE IN
THEIR OFFENSE.
AND WHO WERE DEEMED TOO
DANGEROUS TO RELEASE.
ALTHOUGH IT INITIALLY WAS
LIMITED TO A SPECIFIC NUMBER OF
VIOLENT FELONIES.
IT HAS NOW BEEN EXPANDED.
BY CASE LAW INTERPRETING.
PC TWENTY NINE SIXTY TWO
SUBSECTION E. SUBSECTION TWO
SUBSECTION QUEUE SO THAT IT
INCLUDES THREATS BOTH IMPLICIT
OR EXPLICIT.
AND I'M GOING TO TELL YOU ABOUT
ONE OF MY CLIENTS -- I'M GONNA
CALL IN JOHN SMITH -- HE'S
PARANOID SCHIZOPHRENIC.
AND HE THREATENED A JUDGE HE
SHOWED UP IN HER NEIGHBORHOOD AT
FIVE O'CLOCK IN THE MORNING AND
YELLED I'M GOING TO KILL YOU --
WHICH SHE NOW REFERS TO AS HER
NEIGHBORS WAKE UP CALL IT
ALARMED HER NEIGHBORS SHE'S
PRETTY BLASE ABOUT IT HERSELF --
HOWEVER.
OF JOHN SMITH RECEIVED TWO YEARS
STATE PRISON -- DURING PRISON HE
BECAME OBSESSED WITH THE GOLD
STANDARD FOR US CURRENCY.
AND HE WAS EVALUATED AND FOUND
TO BE A MENTALLY DISORDERED
OFFENDERS.
SINCE THIS CRIME THREATEN
VIOLENCE HE REMAINED.
MENTALLY ILL SINCE HE STILL HAD
DELUSIONS.
BAT MORE CONTROLLED BY HIS
MEDICATION.
SO HE WAS SENT TO A STATE
HOSPITAL HE WAS SENT TO
ATASCADERO.
ALMOST TWENTY YEARS LATER.
HE STILL BELIEVES IN THE GOLD
STANDARD.
AND HE HAS BEEN IN AND OUT OF
THE STATE MENTAL HOSPITAL AND
OUT ON CONDITIONAL RELEASE TO
THE COMMUNITY.
HE HAS NEVER HEARD ANYONE HE HAS
NEVER BEEN VIOLENT -- HE IS
STILL ARGUING THAT THE GOLD
STANDARD APPLIES AND WISHES TO
PROTEST BEING FORCED TO PAY
IMPERFORATE PAPER CURRENCY ARTS
OVER GOING TO RIDE THE BUS AND
BART.
AND FOR THAT HE GETS VIOLATED IN
GOES BACK AND FORTH TO THE
MENTAL HOSPITAL HE'S NOW IN THE
SEVENTIES
HE HAS NUMEROUS PHYSICAL
PROBLEMS -- THIS IS AN EXPENSIVE
WAY TO DEAL WITH MENTAL HEALTH
FOR EXAMPLE THE ANNUAL COST OF
KEEPING SOMEONE AT AN INDIVIDUAL
AND VOLUNTARILY AT THE TASK OF
DARRYL STATE HOSPITAL IS ALMOST.
TWO HUNDRED AND FORTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR.
THERE ARE OVER FIVE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY FOUR M. DO INDIVIDUALS
JUST DONE ATASCADERO.
I'M 48% OF THAT HOSPITAL'S
PATIENT POPULATION THERE ARE
FIVE STATE HOSPITALS THAT
EMBRYOS ARE SET.
TO WE WOULD CONTEND THAT MDO IS
SHORT SIGHTED PUBLIX POLICY.
THE UNDERLYING POLICY RATIONALE
OF DEALING WITH MANSON KARCHER
CARTS RATIONS BY NOW HAVING MASS
INVOLUNTARY COMMITMENT.
IS FLAWED.
OTHER COUNTRIES AND THE WORLD
HEALTH ORGANIZATION.
PROMOTE A MODEL OF TREATMENT IN
THE COMMUNITY OR IN SMALL
PROTECTED FACILITIES LOCATED IN
THE COMMUNITY CLOSER TO FAMILY
AND FRIENDS.
IN PERIODS OF ACUTE
HOSPITALIZATION ARE NEEDED AND
THIS AND IT IS SOMETHING THAT
HAPPENS PEOPLE'S MEDICATIONS
STOP WORKING OR THEY NEED A
CHANGE IN MEDICATION -- LARGE
PSYCHIATRIC INSTITUTIONS LIKE
ATASCADERO STATE HOSPITAL.
REGARDLESS OF THE BEST
INTENTIONS OF THE STAFF.
END UP FOCUSED ON KEEPING THE
PATIENTS LOCKED UP [inaudible]
YOUR SECOND.
CAN I BUY ALL RIGHT RESEARCHERS
HAVE SHOWN THAT THOSE THOSE KIND
OF INSTITUTIONS DON'T WORK AND
COMMUNITY.
HOSPITALIZATION DOES.
WITH ASKS FOR RESPECTFULLY FREER
NO VOTE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
IT'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES
OPPOSITION.
ARE THERE ANY COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM MISTER QUIRK AND
START.
IF THE CURRENT SYSTEM WERE
WORKING.
FINE BUT IT'S CLEARLY NOT HALF
THE PEOPLE IN THE JAILS AND THE
PRISONS HAVE MENTAL PROBLEMS --
AND FURTHER -- HALF THE PEOPLE
ON THE STREETS HAVE WELL MAYBE
NOT HALF MAYBE A QUARTER BUT
IT'S A LARGE NUMBER -- WHERE WE
CLEARLY ARE NOT CATCHING ALL THE
PEOPLE WHO NEED HELP?
AND FOR THAT REASON I'LL BE
SUPPORTING THIS BILL ARE YOU
MAKING A MOTION MISTER COURT I I
MADE OUR ENVIRONMENT.
OF YES YEAH HE MADE IT AND I WAS
SECOND.
YOU MAY CLOSE -- CAN I ALLOW MY
SPONSOR TO RESPOND TO THE
CONCERNS THAT WERE RAISED AS MY
CLOTHES THANK YOU.
YEAH ME TOO WE WILL CONTINUE OUR
CONVERSATION WITH OUR INTENT IS
JUST TO ENSURE THAT WE HAVE
ACCESS TO AND MASON MIGHT BE OUT
IN COURT AS THE MEMBER DESCRIBED
OR NOT CURRENTLY HOUSING CDC ARE
SO WE APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE --
IN THE ANALYSIS IS DONE THE BILL --
PARK.
WE ARE CONTINUING TO AND WOULD
LIKE TO EXPRESS OUR DESIRE TO
CONTINUE TO WORK TO SEE IF WE
CAN -- ADDRESS OUR CONCERNS BUT
AT THIS TIME.
WE BELIEVE THAT THIS BILL JUST
ONLY SPEAKS.
TO THE OUR MEMBERS WHO ARE GOING
OUT INTO -- FACILITIES ARE BEING
DENIED ACCESS WE WANT TO ENSURE
THAT THEY HAVE THE ACCESS TO
CONDUCT.
THE EVALUATIONS THAT THEY'RE
REQUIRED TO DO UNDER CURRENT LAW
THAT SAID THANK YOU THANK YOU.
AND HOPE YOU CONTINUE WORKING
RIGHT I THINK.
IN A CHAIR FOR A COMMITTEE I BUT
BASIC BECAUSE OF WE GOT HAVES
CONTINUING OF CARE.
AND WE GOT PEOPLE WHO ARE FAST
YOU FAMILIAR WITH THE PATIENT TO
CONTINUE. TO TO WORK WITH THEM
NO MATTER WHERE THEY'RE LOCATED
AND SO THAT'S VERY VERY -- I
THINK IT'S I THINK IT'S JUST SIX
CENTRAL ON THAT WE DO THAT AND
THE OPPOSITION'S CONCERNS WELL
BALLOT IN AND WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT THERE AREN'T ANY.
I WILL CALM ABUSES BUT AREN'T
ANY THINGS THAT HAPPENED A COULD
KEEP SOMEONE.
WITHIN THE SYSTEM A NATION.
OF CHURCH RECOMMEND AND I ON SB
FIVE NINETY ONE THE MISSION IS
TO PASS TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER HI JONES --
I LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE BARRICADE HAND
BACKHAND I AM MATHIS MATHIS AYE
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
QUIRK.
QUIRK I SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I WICKS WICKS I THAT
MEASURE PASSES THANK YOU.
AND NOW SB TWO THREE ZERO ITEM
NUMBER ELEVEN SENATOR CABALLERO.
MOVE THE BELL [inaudible]
THAT THAT.
I CAN.
I CAN TAKE THE DURING I HAD A
WHOLE BUNCH OF SO.
I AM LIKE I SAID I GOOD MORNING --
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS I THINK
VERY MUCH THE OPPORTUNITY HERE
TODAY AND AND I I CAN TAKE A
HINT -- SB TWO THIRTY REALLY IS
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO MAKE A
MAJOR INVESTMENT IN -- IN OUR
POLICE FORCES AND REQUIRED THAT
THE GUIDELINES AND THE
RESPONSIBILITIES AND RIGHTS THAT
THEY HAVE TO FOLLOW -- ARE
ADEQUATELY -- FUNDED AND THAT
ARE SET OUT IN -- IN STATUTES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
TODAY ARE YOU.
PROPOSED TO MEN I YES SO I'M
YEAH SEE WAS SO SURE -- LET ME
JUST SAY THAT -- THERE ARE SOME
CONFORMING AMENDMENTS THAT
ENSURE THAT SB TWO THIRTY
REFLECTS THE NEGOTIATIONS THAT
TOOK PLACE IN AB -- THREE NINETY
TWO AND SINCE THE TWO ARE JOINED
IT IT'S IMPORTANT THAT THEY THAT
THEY WORK TOGETHER AND THEY
RESOLVE CONFLICTS AND
DEFINITIONS AND ALSO MAKE
TECHNICAL CHANGES TO MURDER THE
LANGUAGE THAT WAS ADOPTED IN IN
AB THREE NINETY TWO THAT WAS
AGREED.
TO BY THE PARTIES AND SO -- I WE
ARE ACCEPTING THOSE AMENDMENTS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
YEAH WITH THIS GERMAN MEMBER
RANDY PERIOD ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION HI
PATROLMAN PORAC RUN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL WE'VE DONE A LOT OF
RESEARCH BEEN ELEVEN MONTHS
DRAFTING THIS BILL.
AND WE LOOK AT BEST PRACTICES
FROM ALL OVER THE COUNTRY
INCLUDING BALTIMORE SEATTLE SAN
FRANCISCO LOS ANGELES AND THIS
IS WHAT WE HAVE PUT TOGETHER WE
ASK FOR YOUR ABOUT.
THANK YOU YOUR MEMBERS JONATHON
FELDMAN CALIFORNIA POLICE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION I MEAN THE DEBATE
THAT WE'VE BEEN HAVING OVER THE
LAST YEAR ON POLICE USE OF
DEADLY FORCE HAS BEEN DIFFICULT
I THINK FOR ALL OF US BUT
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT IN THE
POLICY THAT WE PUT FORWARD HERE
TODAY AND IN.
AB THREE NINETY TWO IS GONNA
MAKE A HUGE DIFFERENCE AND LEAD
THE NATION AND WE'RE PROUD OF IT
WE ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU.
YES SIR NAY MORNING GENRE WITH
THE CALIFORNIA PEACE OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN WAS NOT THE SIZE
REALLY ANY HALF THE LOS ANGELES
POLICE PROTECTIVE LEAGUE ANY
ASSOCIATION FOR LOS ANGELES
DEPTY SHERIFF'S BOTH IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
RANGER WITH THE RIVERSIDE
SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION ALSO IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING CARE ROSS ON BEHALF
OF THE CITY OF GLENDALE IN
SUPPORT.
CATHERINE ARE GONNA ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY OF CARLSBAD IN SUPPORT.
NICOLE ORNAMENT ON BEHALF OF THE
SAN BERNARDINO COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND SUPPORT.
QUESTION PM.
MATT VERS ALL ON BEHALF THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY SHERIFF IN
SUPPORT.
GENERAL SANCHEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
G. PROBATION OFFICERS OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
WE SHOW MUCH HARM YOU HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ARE.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS PETER B. RING
FROM THE ACLU OF CALIFORNIA IN
OPPOSITION -- I WANT TO START BY
THANKING THIS COMMITTEE FOR THE
IMPORTANT WORK IT HAS DONE ON
POLICE USE OF FORCE BOTH ON THIS
BILL AND ON A. B..
THREE NINE TWO CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITIES HAVE BEEN DEMANDING
CHANGE AND LAWMAKERS LEGISLATIVE
LEADERSHIP THE GOVERNOR HAVE
WORKED TIRELESSLY TO CRAFT
STRONG FAIR AND MEANINGFUL
REFORMS.
AND I WANT TO RECOGNIZE THE
BILL'S AUTHOR IN LAW ENFORCEMENT --
THAT THROUGH THIS BILL THEY ARE
MAKING IMPORTANT CHANGES TO BY
PLACING REQUIREMENTS ON AGENCIES
USE OF FORCE POLICY SO THAT
EVERY AGENCY REQUIRES DE
ESCALATION.
REQUIRES OFFICERS TO REPORT AND
INTERVENE IN EXCESSIVE USE OF
FORCE AND ACQUIRES OFFICERS TO
PROVIDE MEDICAL AID FOLLOWING
THE USE OF FORCE AMONG OTHER
REQUIREMENTS.
HOWEVER.
UNFORTUNATELY THIS BILL EVEN
WITH THE AUTHOR'S LAST MINUTE
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS -- WHICH WE
ARE PROVIDED WITH JUST THIS
MORNING.
RETAIN SOME SERIOUS PROBLEMS
THAT UNDERMINE REFORMS SOUGHT BY
AB -- THREE NINE TWO AND THESE
MUST BE ADDRESSED AND WE REMAIN
OPPOSED AND LESS AMENDED.
FIRST AND MOST IMPORTANTLY THE
BILL DEFINES THE WORD FEASIBLE
IN A WAY THAT UNDERMINES THE DE
ESCALATION REQUIREMENTS IN THIS
BILL AND KEY ELEMENTS OF AB
THREE NINE TWO BY DEFINING
FEASIBLE. TO MEAN IT AN ACT THAT
CARRIES NO INCREASE IN RISK TO
AN OFFICER THAT IS NOT A
REALISTIC DEFINITION FEASIBLE
DOES NOT MEAN ZERO RISK IT MEANS
REASONABLE RISK.
AS LAW ENFORCEMENT OFTEN NOTES
OFFICERS FACE SOME RISK IS PART
OF THE JOB.
IN THE CASE OF DEADLY FORCE THE
SAFEST ROUTE WILL ALWAYS BE FOR
OFFICERS TO SHOOT ANY POTENTIAL
THREAT AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE.
ANY OTHER COURSE OF ACTION
INCREASES THE RISK TO OFFICERS
TO SOME DEGREE BUT THAT SHOULD
NOT BE THE MEASURE WE MUST
REQUIRE OFFICERS TO TAKE TIME TO
DE ESCALATE WE'RE DOING SO DOES
NOT UNREASONABLY.
INCREASE THE RISK TO OFFICER.
THE DEFINITION OF FEASIBLE AS
WRITTEN NOT ONLY MAKES THE DE
ESCALATION REQUIREMENT IN THIS
BILL EXTRAORDINARILY WEAK BUT
UNDERMINES KEY LANGUAGE IN AB
THREE NINE TWO THAT WAS ADDED TO
ACHIEVE.
LEGISLATIVE COMPROMISE.
SECOND THE BILL IN SECTION ONE
SUBDIVISION AFTER CLAIRE'S THAT
NO POLICY CAN ANTICIPATE EVERY
CONCEIVABLE SITUATION OR
EXCEPTIONAL CIRCUMSTANCES WHICH
OFFICERS MAY FACE.
THIS SUGGESTS THE DANGEROUS IDEA
THE POLICIES ARE NOT DESIGNED TO
APPLY TO ALL SITUATIONS IMPLIES
THAT THERE MAY BE EXCEPTIONS TO
AN AGENCIES USE OF FORCE POLICY
IN EXTRAORDINARY CIRCUMSTANCES.
BUT THE VERY POINT OF USE OF
FORCE POLICIES AND OF THIS BILL
IS TO REGULATE OFFICERS USE OF
FORCE AT ALL TIMES INCLUDING
EXTRAORDINARY SITUATIONS WHERE
DEADLY FORCE IS REQUIRED.
AND THE BILL LANGUAGE SHOULD NOT
MONEY THAT.
THIRD IN SECTION ONE G. THE BILL
CONTINUES TO INCLUDE THE
DECLARATION THAT A LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES USE OF
FORCE POLICY IN TRAINING SHOULD
BE ADMISSIBLE IN EVIDENCE IN ANY
PROCEEDING INVOLVING A USE.
AN OFFICER'S USE OF FORCE.
THIS LANGUAGE UNFORTUNATELY
CREATES A PERVERSE INCENTIVE TO
HAVE POLICIES IN TRAINING ON USE
OF FORCE THAT ARE AS LACKS AND
PERMISSIVE AS POSSIBLE.
SO THAT OFFICERS CAN BE SHOWN TO
BE IN COMPLIANCE WITH THE POLICY
IN TRAINING.
IS INTRODUCED INTO EVIDENCE IN
ORDER TO REDUCE LIABILITY FOR
OFFICERS AND THE COSTS OF
AGENCIES THAT INDEMNIFY THEM.
INDEED THIS CRITICISM WAS LEVIED
AGAINST LAST YEAR'S AB NINE
THREE ONE IN AN OPINION PIECE
WRITTEN JOINTLY BY THE LAPD'S
HEAD OF CONSTITUTIONAL POLICING
AND A LEADING EXPERT IN POLICING.
THIS SHOULD BE REMOVED.
FINALLY IN SECTION TO BE TWO THE
BILL WOULD MANDATE A
PROPORTIONALITY REQUIREMENT THAT
MISSTATES THE CONSIDERATIONS FOR
THAT TEST.
THE BILL MAKES FORCE
PROPORTIONAL TO THE SERIOUSNESS
OF A SUSPECTED OFFENSE A
CONSIDERATION THAT SHOULD
ABSOLUTELY AFFECT THE OFFICERS
ASSESSMENT OF THE THREAT.
POSED OR THE NEED TO OVERCOME
RESISTANCE BUT THAT SHOULD NOT
BE AN INDEPENDENT CONSIDERATION.
AN OFFICER MAY RIGHTLY EXPECT TO
USE MORE FORCE RESPONDING TO A
REPORTED SHOOTING INTO A NOISE
COMPLAINT BUT AN OFFICER TRYING.
TO MY APOLOGIES BUT AN OFFICER
TRYING TO APPREHEND.
AN ELDERLY ON ARM SUSPECT IN A
FORTY YEAR OLD MURDER CASE WOULD
CONSIDER MORE IN EVALUATING THE
THREAT THAN JUST THE SERIOUSNESS
OF THE SUSPECTED OFFENSE.
AND FORCE USED TO GAIN
COMPLIANCE SHOULD CONSIDER THE
SERIOUSNESS OF OFFENSE AND
DEGREE OF RESISTANCE TO AVOID
USING SIGNIFICANT FORCE AGAINST
AN INDIVIDUAL SUSPECTED OF ONLY
A MINOR INFRACTION.
BUT SHOULD ALSO CONSIDER
MITIGATING SUBS CIRCUMSTANCES OR
VULNERABILITIES OF THE SUBJECT
AN OFFICER SHOULD NOT USE
SERIOUS FOR FORCE AGAINST AN
ELDERLY PERSON OR PREGNANT WOMAN
EVEN IN THE FACE OF A
CATEGORICAL REFUSAL TO COOPERATE.
THE PROPORTIONALITY TERM SHOULD
BE AMENDED TO REFLECT THAT.
FINALLY IN OUR LETTER WE HAVE
MADE A NUMBER OF SUGGESTIONS WE
BELIEVE WOULD INCLUDE PROVEN
CLARIFY THE BILL CLARIFYING THE
MANDATE ON POLICIES REQUIRING DE
ESCALATION -- THAT THAT SHOULD
INCLUDE LESS LETHAL FORCE THAT
THE REPORTING REQUIREMENTS FOR
DEADLY FORCE SHOULD NOT REQUIRE
OFFICERS TO MAKE A CALL ON
WHETHER FORCES EXCESSIVE.
AND LEAVE THAT TO THEIR
SUPERVISORS THE TRAINING
REQUIREMENTS ON DE ESCALATION
AND COMMUNICATION SHOULD BE
SEPARATED FOR CLARITY.
THESE ARE NOT THE BASIS OF OUR
OPPOSITION BUT OUR EFFORTS TO
IMPROVE THE BILL.
WE KNOW WITH AN INCREDIBLE
AMOUNT OF ENERGY HAS GONE INTO
THIS ISSUE THIS LEGISLATIVE
SESSION BUT WE SHOULD NOT LET.
WE SHOULD NOT UNDO THE GOOD WORK
THAT HAS BEEN DONE BY LETTING
HARMFUL POLICIES IN AT THE
ELEVENTH HOUR AND WE URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO MAKE THESE
MODIFICATIONS.
THANK YOU ARE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON KAELIN DEAN WITH
THE ALLIANCE FOR BOYS AND MEN OF
COLOR AT POLICY LINK -- WE ARE
OPPOSED UNLESS AMENDED AND WE
APPRECIATE THE PROGRESS THAT THE
AUTHOR HAS MADE TO ADVANCE THE
BILL HOWEVER WE FEEL THERE ARE
STILL SEVERAL ISSUES WHICH
UNDERMINE AB -- THREE NINETY TWO
AND SO WE LOOK FORWARD TO THE
CHANCE TO CONTINUE WORKING WITH
YOU -- TO ADDRESS THESE ISSUES
AS WE MOVE FORWARD THANK YOU.
OUR MAJORITY ON BEHALF OF THE
FIFTY LA FARMER POSITION.
ANDREW MISS FISHER WITH THE
LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS OF
CALIFORNIA IN OPPOSITION.
JUST A JOB EMPLOYEES OF THE
COMEDIAN OPPOSITION.
BUT ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS BURKE.
YES I BELIEVE IF THE ACLU WOULD
READ THE AMENDMENT STATE FIND
THAT THIS IS IN LINE WITH.
TWO NINE TWO IF WE WERE TO
REJECT THIS TUESDAY IT WOULD SET
THE WHOLE THING BACK -- I KNOW
YOU DIDN'T LIKE TO NINE TWO FOR
VARIOUS REASONS AS THREE NINETY
THREE NINE TWO FOR VARIOUS
REASONS SINCE DID SOME OF THE
OPPOSITION -- I'M JUST SAYING
THAT -- THIS IS HAT WE'VE GOT.
WE SHOULD NOT HOLD UP THIS BILL
AND I URGE ALL MY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS TO VOTE I THANK YOU.
AND YOUR QUESTION.
WHICH CENTER HE JUST ADDRESS THE
THE CONCERNS RAISED THIS
UNDERMINE.
THREE NINETY TWO YES I'M THE
THIS IS BEEN IN AN EXTENSIVE --
VERY INTENSE NEGOTIATION PROCESS --
IT'S MY BELIEF -- AFTER.
THAT AS WE SIT HERE TODAY THAT
IT DOES NOT.
BETTY IT -- WE MADE THE
CONFORMING CHANGES THAT'S THE
REASONTHAT WE HAVE CHANGES
TODAY IS BECAUSE WE MADE SOME --
CONFORMITY CHANGES A THREE
NINETY TWO AND FRANKLY THAT --
THIS BILL HAS BEEN -- HAS HAD
HEAVILY INVOLVEMENT FROM
LEADERSHIP IN BOTH HOUSES AS
WELL AS THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
AND THIS IS THE AGREEMENT THAT
ALL.
PARTIES HAVE HAVE AGREED TO WITH
THE EXCEPTION OF SOME OBJECTIONS
BY ACLU BUT QUITE FRANKLY.
THE LIST THAT I HAVE.
HEARD TODAY IS LONGER THAN THE
LIST THAT WE WERE GIVEN THE LAST
TIME THAT WE WE HAD AROUND HAVE.
OF NEGOTIATIONS SO IT TO ME IT
SEEMS THAT THE LIST KEEPS
GROWING LONGER AND LONGER AND
AND AND FRANKLY -- I'M NOT SURE
WHERE WE'RE EVER GOING TO GET.
TO A YES WITH THE ACLU MUCH AS
I'D LIKE TO DO THAT -- I DON'T
BELIEVE.
THAT THIS UNDERMINES AB THREE
NINETY TWO AND I AM ALL OF A THE
BILL FOR TODAY -- I AGREE WITH
MY COLLEAGUE HERE BUT I DO WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE DON'T
UNDERMINE THREE TWO AND THAT'S A
LOT OF WORK PUT INTO THAT -- AND
I KNOW YOU HAVE RECEIVED A LOT
OF WORK TO AS WELL BUT I WANT TO
KEEP HONORING THAT THE
COMMITMENTS IT WE MADE.
THANK YOU.
MISS BARKING.
YESTERDAY WE STOOD ON THE FLOOR
AND WE HAD A MOMENT OF SILENCE
FOR TERROR O'SULLIVAN WHO PASSED
AWAY JUST LAST WEEK AFTER BEING
SHOT IN THE LINE OF DUTY.
AND I THINK THAT IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT WE REMEMBER THE LIVES THAT
ARE TAKEN ON THE LAW ENFORCEMENT
SIDE AS WELL AND I THINK THE
DEAL THAT WAS STRUCK.
ON SB TWO THIRTY AND AB THREE
NINETY TWO HONORED.
THE LIVES LOST ON BOTH SIDES AND
I THINK THAT IS WHAT WE AS A
COMMITTEE.
AND LEADERSHIP AND THE AUTHORS
WORKED SO HARD TO GET TO TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE HAD A BILL THE
MAJOR THAT.
USE DEADLY FORCE WAS ONLY USED
WHEN NECESSARY.
WE GAVE LAW ENFORCEMENT THE
TRAINING THEY WERE ASKING FOR
THE ONLY TIME.
I'VE ONLY BEEN HERE SIX MONTHS
BUT ONCE SOMEBODY'S COMING TO MY
OFFICE AND SAID.
WE COULD DO BETTER WE WANT TO DO
BETTER GIVE US TRAINING AND I
SAID WOW WHO'S WE HAVE SOMEBODY
WHO'S ADMITTING THEY WANT TO DO
BETTER AND I WILL HAPPILY JOIN
YOU IN MAKING SURE YOU DO BETTER
AND THAT IS WHAT THIS BILL DOES.
AND SO I HOPE WE CAN MOVE
FORWARD TOGETHER ON A BIPARTISAN
BASIS TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
DOING WHAT PROTECTS BOTH THE
CITIZENS OF CALIFORNIA BUT ALSO
OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT WHO SERVICE
EVERY DAY AND I THINK THAT'S
WHAT THESE TWO BILLS DO.
SO I ALSO URGING A VOTE.
YES MISTER LACKEY.
YEAH I WOULD LIKE THIS FIRST OF
ALL JUST SAY.
THANK YOU TO THE AUTHOR.
THANK YOU TO THE REMARKS THAT
HAVE BEEN MADE -- BY THIS
COMMITTEE.
AND I FIND.
THE ACLU'S OBJECTIONS.
NOT ONLY UNREASONABLE BUT
INSULTING TO THE PROCESS AND THE
THE PROGRESS THAT WE'VE MADE IN
THIS VERY DELICATE DISCUSSION --
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF GOOD WILL
THAT'S BEEN GENERATED THROUGH
THIS.
THIS VERY -- DIFFICULT
DISCUSSION.
THAT ACTUALLY AS WAS MENTIONED
BY [inaudible]
THIS REMARK.
WE HAVE LOSS OF LIFE RELATED TO
THIS VERY VERY DELICATE TOPIC
AND IT SHOULD BE GIVEN -- VERY
VERY DEEP THOUGHT BEFORE WE
EXPRESS.
OURSELVES TONIGHT I JUST WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR THAT AND
SAY THAT I'M VERY DISAPPOINTED
IN ACLU THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER COMMENT.
SENATOR YOU MAY CLOSE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR -- FIRST
LET ME THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP IN THIS AREA --
IT'S GREATLY APPRECIATED THIS
HAS BEEN A DIFFICULT AND VERY
DIVISIVE -- IT TOPIC AND I GOT
INVOLVED BECAUSE I'VE SERVED IN
A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT ROLES --
FIRST AS A MOTHER BUT ALSO AS A
LOCAL GOVERNMENT -- ELECTED
INDIVIDUAL AS A MAYOR WHERE I
WAS RESPONSIBLE FOR EVERYBODY IN
THE COMMUNITY AND AND SO I TOOK
VERY SERIOUS -- THAT THE
CHALLENGE TO TRY TO KEEP
EVERYBODY AT THE TABLE AND TO
KEEP TALKING ABOUT HOW WE CAN --
MAKE THE BEST -- CHANGES THAT WE
NEED TO KNOWING THAT THE SYSTEM
ISN'T WORKING FOR US AND AND WE
NEED WE NEED CHANGE -- I ALSO
WON AT REX RECOGNIZE --
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FROM SAN DIEGO
WHO DID AT A STELLAR JOB ON AB
THREE NINETY TWO AND AND AND
THANK HER FOR HER LEADERSHIP IN
THIS WE HAD MANY CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT.
HAVING OUR BILLS WORK TOGETHER
AND I APPRECIATE EVERYTHING THAT
SHE'S DONE AS WELL -- THIS THIS
BILL REALLY IS ABOUT --
CAREFULLY COMING UP ALONG SIDE
AB THREE NINETY TWO AND
REFLECTING THE VALUES THAT ARE
EMBODIED IN THAT BILL.
AND CREATING RESPONSIBILITIES
AND OBLIGATIONS USING BEST
PRACTICES FROM ACROSS THE
COUNTRY IN A WAY THAT
FUNDAMENTALLY CHANGES THE
CULTURE IN OUR FIVE HUNDRED PLUS
POLICE DEPARTMENTS ACROSS THE
STATE.
SO THAT THERE IS A AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR FOR THE CHANGE
THE OUT THAT WE ALL WANT TO SEE
BUT ALSO TO KEEP THEM SAFE AS
THEY DO THEIR DAY A JOB ON A JOB
THAT GETS THE MORE DIFFICULT
EVERY DAY.
AND SO -- IS THE BILL ARE ARE
THE TWO BILLS PERFECT NO --
WHERE WE CONTINUE TO WORK ON
THEM AND -- AND AND AND I
BELIEVE WE'VE GOT THE THAT WE'VE
DONE EVERYTHING THAT WE COULD TO
HAVE THE LANGUAGE.
IN BOTH BILLS LINE UP WITH EACH
OTHER AND TO MAKE SURE THAT --
THAT WERE MAKING THE CHANGE THAT
WE REALLY WE REALLY WANT TO SEE
SO WITH THAT I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE AND I AND I AS I SAID.
THIS IS NOT.
JUST A DOCTOR WEBER AND CENTER
COME OUT YET -- YOU KNOW OFTEN A
ROOM ALL BY OURSELVES THERE BEEN
MANY MANY PEOPLE INVOLVED IN IN
THE LANGUAGE OF THIS BILL AND
AND IT HAS BEEN.
VETTED WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE AS WELL AS LEADERSHIP IN
BOTH HOUSES SO I RESPECTED
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
TODAY.
AND THANK YOU AND SO LET ME JUST.
LET ME JUST START WITH -- JUST
SOME CLARIFYING.
THINGS WITH THE COMMITTEE JUST A
COMMITTEE IN GENERAL -- AND JUST
SO YOU KNOW WHEN I TALK.
IN MEASURED TONES.
GOOD MEN GENERALLY MEANS I AM
PISSED.
BUT I CAN'T SAY WHAT WE REALLY
WANT TO SHAKE OFF.
SELECT TO START WITH.
AMENDMENTS WAS SENT TO A QUE
BAKER.
YOU KNOW WHO THAT IS FROM THE
ACLU ON FRIDAY JUNE TWENTY FIRST.
AT TWO OO SEVEN PM. FOR THE
OPPOSITION TO SAY THEY DIDN'T
RECEIVE THESE AMENDMENTS UNTIL
THIS MORNING IS AN INSULT TO
THIS COMMITTEE.
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND IT'S
VERY DISINGENUOUS IN A RECENT
OUTBREAK BRING IT UP BECAUSE I
TOLD MEMBERS OF THE OPPOSITION.
THE DAY CAME INTO THIS COMMITTEE
WITH SOME LAST MINUTE STUFF.
I PROVIDENCE A STUFF.
THAT I WOULD BE VERY VERY UPSET.
I RESPECT TO THE AUTHOR.
ANY AUTHORED IN ON THIS SITE BY
THE ASSEMBLY THIS PRACTICE OF
BRINGING.
FIRE BOMBS AT THE END IT'S GOT
TO STOP.
SPECIALLY SINCE I KNOW THIS
AUTHOR OF THREE NINETY TWO
DOCTOR WEBER I KNOW SHE'S BEEN
GOING THROUGH FOR THE LAST TWO
YEARS. TO GET THIS ACROSS THE
FINISH LINE.
AS I TOLD THE OPPOSITION.
IN MY OFFICE.
I WOULD DO EVERYTHING IN MY IN
MY POWER TO ENSURE THAT WE GIVE
HER ACROSS THE FINISH LINE TO
GET YOU ACROSS THE FINISH LINE.
AND WE'RE NOT GOING TO LET.
THE PERFECT DESTROY SOMETHING
THAT NEEDS TO HAPPEN.
AFTER AMERICAN MALE.
PERFECT IN ZERO DOESN'T WORK
NEVER WORKS NEVER WILL.
THIS IS DICK SIGNIFICANT FIRST
STEP.
AND WE WERE GOING WE'RE GOING TO
MAKE THAT HAPPEN TODAY.
WE'RE GOING TO MAKE THAT HAPPEN
TODAY JUST COMMITTEES GOING TO
MAKE THAT HAPPEN TODAY
[inaudible]
AND WITH THEIR HELP WE'RE GOING
TO MAKE IT HAPPEN ON THE FLOOR.
WITH EVERYBODY PULLING TO MAKE
THIS HAPPEN BECAUSE CALIFORNIA.
IS NOW THE LEADER IN THIS I
DON'T THINK YOU UNDERSTAND WE'RE
NOW THE LEADER IN WHAT EVER THIS
IS RIGHT NOW.
WE ARE THE STANDARD BETTER
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
EVERYBODY ALL EYES ARE ON US.
EVERYBODY'S WATCHING TO SEE WHAT
WE'RE GOING TO DO.
AND THE FACT THAT WE'RE GOING TO
DO SOMETHING.
IS UNBELIEVABLY SIGNIFICANT AND
WE NEED.
TO TAKE CREDIT FOR IT.
AND STOP IN FIGHTING WITH ONE
ANOTHER AND FIGURE OUT A WAY TO
MAKE SURE THIS IS THE MOST
SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM.
BECAUSE THE MOST IMPORTANT PART
IS THE IMPLEMENTATION.
WITHOUT A DOUBT WE DON'T
IMPLEMENT THIS RIGHT.
ALL THE ALL THE PHONE CALLS ALL
THE HE THE THREATS ALL OF THE
THE THINGS THAT EVERY LAST ONE
OF US WENT THROUGH ON THIS
COMMITTEE.
EVERYONE HAS LOOKED AT BOTH
BILLS HAD LOOKED AT THE AT EVERY
WORD.
AND WHEN I SAY WE DEBATED EVERY
YOUR PEOPLE GIGGLING.
WE DEBATED EVERY WORD IN BOTH
BILLS.
SO THIS BILL HAS BEEN THOROUGHLY
VETTED BY EVERYBODY ON THIS
COMMITTEE.
AND PRAGUE BY EVERYBODY IN THE
ASSEMBLY AND THE SENATE.
AND SO WE HAVE ABSOLUTELY NO
EXCUSE FOR AN FOR THIS NOT TO
HAPPEN.
AND SO THE CHAIR STYLING
RECOMMEND IN HIGH VOTE.
I AM SUGGESTING THAT IS
UNANIMOUS AS WE SEND IT TO THE
FLOOR.
MEANT SECTOR CALL THE ROLL.
ON SB TWO THIRTY THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER AYE JONES SAWYER AYE
LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE BARRICADE HAND
BACKING HANNAH HI MATHIS.
MATHIS HI KAMLAGER-DOVE UP.
QUIRK HI QUIRK I SANTIAGO.
WICKS WICKS I THAT MEASURE
PASSES THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU TO
THE COMMITTEE [inaudible]
OKAY.
WE'RE WAITING FOR MR WIENER
BECAUSE HE WAS THE NEXT BUT NEXT
ONE IS MISTER PORTANTINO WITH
ABOUT.
SEVENTEEN BILLS JUST A FEW.
I WOULD LOVE TO PUT MISTER
GLAZIER NEXT BUT WOULD WOULD YOU
LET HIM GO NEXT HE ONLY HAS ONE
OR TWO ONE SHORT.
ONE IS A SHORT ONE YES IF THE
CHAIR I'M NOT TALKING ABOUT THIS.
THANK YOU AND THEN YOU KNOW NOTE
YOUR NEXT NO MATTER WHAT YOUR TO
TOP THE LIST MISTER WEINER IS
GONNA HAVE TO WAIT FOR YOU
[inaudible]
SECOND CLEAN.
CITING HIS SUPPORT SUPPORT WE
SHOULD BE.
MORNING THANKS FOR BEING HERE.
YOU MAY BEGIN MISTER GLAZIER IT
WAS ASKING IF THAT WAS OPEN AND
CLOSE.
AT A CANDY.
I THINK PEOPLE ARE FAMILIAR WITH
THE BILL.
I YOU PASS SOMETHING SIMILAR
THAT -- MISTER LACKEY ADVANCE
FOR THOSE UNDER THE AGE OF
EIGHTEEN THE SAYS THE SAME FOR
THOSE OVER.
AND I THINK THE ARGUMENTS ARE
PRETTY PERSUASIVE IN THE
ANALYSIS AND I HAVE A WITNESS TO
SPEAK IN FAVOR IN ADDITION
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THE MORNING COMMITTEE HI MY NAME
IS MELISSA O'CONNELL I'M AN
ATTORNEY WITH THE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA INNOCENCE PROJECT AND
I'M ALSO SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
THE TWO OTHER INNOCENTS PROJECTS
IN CALIFORNIA -- WRONGFUL
CONVICTIONS DON'T START AT A
TRIAL -- THE COMPANY IN ONE
PHONE FOUR CONVICTIONS TYPICALLY
HAPPEN BECAUSE AN INVESTIGATION
HAS GONE AWRY AND SO ACCESS TO
PRE TRIAL DOCUMENTS IS CRITICAL
TO A POST CONVICTION REVIEW.
HOWEVER IT TAKES OUR OFFICES
THREE TO FOUR YEARS TO REVIEW
OUR CLIENTS CASES -- BECAUSE
WORD WORKING WITH INCOMPLETES OR
PIECEMEAL FILES BECAUSE OUR
CLIENTS DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO
POST CONVICTION DISCOVERY.
UP UNTIL LAST YEAR ONLY INMATES
SENTENCED TO LIFE WITHOUT THE
POSSIBILITY OF PAROLE OR CAPITAL
PUNISHMENT HAD RIGHT TO POST
CONVICTION DOCUMENTS.
BUT WHAT WE'VE LEARNED OVER THE
LAST THIRTY YEARS OF INNOCENCE
WORK IS THAT OUR CLIENTS ARE
MORE OFTEN SENTENCED TO HIGH
DETERMINATE SENTENCES OR FIFTEEN
OR TWENTY FIVE YEARS TO LIFE.
PUTTING THEM OUTSIDE THAT RIGHT.
THAT WAS THE IMPETUS FOR LAST
YEAR IS AB NINETEEN EIGHTY SEVEN
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER LACKEY
WHICH EXPAND EXTENDED THE
CATEGORY OF INDIVIDUALS WHO
COULD SEEK DISCOVERY.
HOWEVER THE LAW AND ITS CURRENT
FORM HAS OPENED THE DOOR TO
LITIGATION SUGGESTING THAT ONLY
THOSE INMATES CONVICTED AS OF
JANUARY ONE OF THIS YEAR.
COULD BENEFIT FROM THIS CHANGE
IN THE LAW.
BUT WE KNOW IS A STATE THAT
THERE ARE INNOCENT PEOPLE
CURRENTLY INCARCERATED IN OUR
PRISONS.
I WANTED TO JUST GIVE A BRIEF
EXAMPLE WE HAVE A CLIENT WHO WAS
SENTENCED TO THIRTY TWO YEARS TO
LIFE IN STATE PRISON -- WHEN WE
GOT INVOLVED IN HER CASE -- I A
LAWYER HAD PASSED AWAY.
THE STATE COURT HAD DESTROYED
THEIR FILE AND THE TRIAL
EXHIBITS HAVE BEEN DESTROYED IN
HER CASE.
THE STATE DENIED US ACCESS TO
POST CONVICTION DISCOVERY
BECAUSE HER SENTENCE FELL
OUTSIDE OF EXISTING LAW.
I'M CARLA SPENT SEVENTEEN YEARS
WRONGFULLY INCARCERATED AND THE
AND ABOUT FIVE AND A HALF OF
THOSE YEARS WERE SPENT BEHIND US
TRYING TO INVESTIGATE AND
LITIGATE HER CASE UNTIL SHE WAS
EXONERATED TWO MONTHS AGO -- WE
TAKE OUR RESPONSIBILITY VERY
SERIOUSLY AS INNOCENCE PROJECTS
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT THERE ARE
VICTIMS ON THE OTHER SIDE OF
THESE CASES AND THAT'S WHY A
COMPLETE AND ACCURATE REVIEW OF
THESE CASES IS CRITICAL.
AND SB SIX FIFTY ONE ALLOWS US
TO DO THAT TO MAKE SURE THAT
RIGHT FOR CONVICTIONS REMAIN
INTACT AND WRONGFUL CONVICTIONS
ARE RECTIFIED AS EXPEDITIOUSLY
AS POSSIBLE.
THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
MARCO GEORGE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER WITNESS IN
SUPPORT ANY WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE ANY QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS COMMENTS.
SEEING NONE YOU MAY CLOSE THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR JUSTICE DOESN'T.
AND THAT THE COURT ROOM DOORS
THERE'S MORE -- IN OUR EFFORT TO
TRY TO FIND JUSTICE AND THEN
THIS BILL PROVIDES THAT
OPPORTUNITY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION THANK YOU CHAIR OF
RECOGNIZED VOTE.
MAY CALL THE ROLL.
ON SB SIX FIFTY ONE THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER HI JOHN
SIR I LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE BARRICADE HAN BACKING
AND I MATHIS.
MATHIS NOT VOTING KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE I QUIRK.
QUIRK I SANTIAGO.
WICKS.
WICKS I THAT MEASURE PASSES
BRADLEY MR PORTANTINO
[inaudible]
I HAVE.
YEAH I'M HERE TO SERVE.
YOU HAVE SB. SIXTY ONE ONE
SEVENTY TWO THREE SEVENTY SIX
AND SIX TWO ZERO YES SIR.
AND I WOULD LIKE TO STATE I'VE
SPENT MORE TIME WITH YOU THEN
ALL YOUR SENATOR COLLEAGUES PUT
TOGETHER ON YOUR BILLS WE WERE
SUPPOSED TO KEEP THAT A SECRET
OKAY I'M SORRY.
DISREGARD WHAT I JUST SAID.
ALL RIGHT.
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY THANK YOU --
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS TODAY I'M
PRESENTING -- SB SIXTY ONE WHICH
BROKE WHICH PROHIBITS ANY PERSON
FROM MAKING AN APPLICATION TO
PURCHASE MORE THAN ONE FIREARM.
WITHIN A THIRTY DAY PERIOD
FIREMAN'S WILL NOT BE DELIVERED
WHATEVER THE DEALERS NOTIFY THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE THAT
WITHIN THE PRECEDING THIRTY DAY.
THE PURCHASER HAD BAITED OTHER
APPLICATION TO PURCHASE.
A FIREARM IN NINETEEN NINETY
NINE LEGISLATION WAS ENACTED TO
LIMIT THE PURCHASE OF HANDGUNS
BUT RECENT DATA SUGGEST.
THAT LONG GUNS ARE BECOMING A
SIGNIFICANT PIECE OF
CALIFORNIA'S GUN TRAFFICKING
PROBLEMS OVER THE PAST TEN YEARS
CALIFORNIANS HAVE TYPICALLY
PURCHASE MORE LONG GUNS AND HAND
GUNS.
THERE'S NO REASON WHY SOMEONE
WOULD NEED TO BUY MORE THAN ONE
LONG GONE HER MONTHS PREVENTING
THE FLOW OF GUNS IS IMPORTANT TO
PUBLIC SAFETY REGARDLESS OF
WHETHER THE FIREARM.
IS A HANDGUN OR A LONG GUN -- OR
PURCHASE NEW FROM A DEALER OR
THROUGH A PRIVATE TRANSACTION
LIMITED FIREARM SALES TO ONE GUN
PER MONTH IS A RECOGNIZED
STRATEGY. TO REDUCE GUN
TRAFFICKING AND KEEP FIREARMS
OUT OF DANGEROUS HANDS THE BILL
WAS ALSO RECENTLY AMENDED TO
HELP CLOSE ANY LOOPHOLES FROM
PERSONS UNDER THE AGE OF TWENTY
ONE YEARS.
OF AGE FOR PURCHASE OF SEMI
AUTOMATIC CENTERFIRE RIFLES BY
REQUIRING HONORABLY RETIRED
MILITARY IN LICENSE HUNTERS
UNDER THE AGE OF TWENTY ONE WHO
WISH TO ACQUIRE SEMIOTICS A
CENTERFIRE RIFLE.
BY DISLEY REQUIRING A
CERTIFICATE OF ELIGIBILITY FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE --
TODAY I HAVE.
A MANDATE FROM THE BRADY
CAMPAIGN UNITED AGAINST GUN
VIOLENCE TO TESTIFY ON BEHALF OF
SB SIXTY ONE WE THINK CUTTING
DOWN ON BULK PURCHASES IS A GOOD
IDEA.
AND OBVIOUSLY WOULD RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE WHEN
APPROPRIATE.
THANK YOU YES GOOD MORNING.
AMANDA WILCOX ON BEHALF OF BRADY
CALIFORNIA.
SO IN GENERAL OF BRADY
CALIFORNIA BELIEVES THAT HAND
GUNS AND LONG GUNS SHOULD BE
SUBJECT TO THE SAME LAWS.
IN NINETEEN NINETY NINE
LEGISLATION WAS ENACTED THAT CAP --
THE NUMBER OF HANDGUNS THAT
COULD BE.
PURCHASED IN A THIRTY DAY PERIOD
TWO ONE HAND GUN PER MONTH PER
BUYER PER MONTH -- IN THE
PURPOSE OF THAT IS.
TO PREVENT THE TRACK OF
TRAFFICKING OF HANDGUNS IT
STANDS TO REASON -- THAT OF
SOMEONE IS BUYING FIFTY GUNS AT
ONCE THERE MOST LIKELY TURN
AROUND AND SELLING THEM ON THE
BLACK MARKET FOR PROFIT -- WE
OBVIOUSLY BELIEVE THAT THAT SAME
CAPTION APPLIED TO LONG GUNS
BASED ON A PUBLIC RECORDS ACT
REQUEST THAT -- MY HUSBAND AND I
DID WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE A NUMBER
OF YEARS AGO WE FOUND THAT
EIGHTY ONE POINT 9% OF LONG GUNS
WERE SOLD AS A SINGLE
TRANSACTION.
SO THEREFORE MOST LONGER BUYERS
WILL NOT BE IMPACTED BY THIS LAW
HOWEVER AT THE OTHER END OF THE
SPECTRUM ONE INDIVIDUAL PURCHASE
A HUNDRED SEVENTY SEVEN LONG
GUNS AND ONE MONTH.
FURTHER WE FOUND THAT WHEN GUNS
WERE ACQUIRED LONG GUNS WORK
WIRED -- WITH A BALL PURCHASE
THERE MOST LIKELY TO BE LOWER
RECEIVERS WHICH AGAIN CAN BE
SOLD PERHAPS ON THE BLACK MARKET
AND BUILD UP INTO.
ILLEGAL ASSAULT WEAPONS -- SO WE
CONSIDER THIS TO BE A GOOD
STRATEGY FOR CURBING GUN
TRAFFICKING AND REDUCING OUR THE
PLAY WE HAVE OF ILLEGAL GUNS.
AND I WOULD JUST LIKE TO POINT
OUT BECAUSE I'VE HEARD THE
CONCERNED REPEATEDLY IN THIS
COMMITTEE ABOUT HOW ARE WE
IMPACTING LAW ABIDING GUN OWNERS
AND ARE WE HAVING
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT ON
CERTAIN COMMUNITIES WITH OUR
LAWS.
AND I WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT
THIS BILL PLACES THE BURDEN ON
THE GUN DEALER THEY'RE THE ONES
WHO CANNOT MAKE THE SALE WHEN
THEY'RE NOTIFIED BY DOJ THAT --
THAT THE PERSON'S ALREADY AND
PURCHASE A GUN WITHIN THE LAST
OUR THIRTY DAY PERIOD SO THE
BURDENS ON THE DEALER NOT ON THE
INDIVIDUALS KNOWING THIS LAW.
ARE FOLLOWING THE LAW FOR THAT
MATTER AND THEN FINALLY -- THE
CENTER MENTIONED THE THAT THE
BILL WAS AMENDED TO NARROW THE
EXEMPTION THAT'LL THAT ALLOWS
THOSE UNDER AGE TWENTY ONE TO
BUY CINEMA SEMI AUTOMATIC
CENTERFIRE RIFLE WHICH SADLY
SEEMS TO BE THE WEAPON OF CHOICE --
IN TODAY'S MASS SHOOTINGS THERE
ARE STILL WAYS THERE ARE
EXEMPTIONS -- FOR THOSE UNDER
TWENTY ONE TO ACQUIRE A FIREARM.
I SUCH A FIREARM BUT THERE'S
GONNA BE MORE HOOPS AND MORE
OPPORTUNITY FOR SCREENING BEFORE
THEY CAN OBTAIN SUCH A GUN WE
THINK THAT IS ALSO IN THE
INTEREST OF PUBLIC SAFETY.
THIS COMMITTEE HAS PASSED A LAW
THIS.
THIS LEGISLATION THIS POLICY
SEVERAL TIMES -- AND I TRUST
THAT YOU WILL.
ARETODAY AS WELL I OR TRY VOTE
THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER.
IN SUPPORT NAME AN ORGANIZATION.
GOOD MORNING ELIZABETH HAS BEEN --
SOME BEHALF OF THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND THE COUNTIES OF
LOS ANGELES INVENTOR AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
CALVIN QUICK BAY AREA STERN
ACTRESS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU ARE
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
MY FAVORITE [inaudible] FOR SURE.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS SAN PRESS
HAPPY TO BE HERE WITH YOU AGAIN
TODAY.
AND UNHAPPY TO HAVE TO OPPOSE
THIS PIECE OF LEGISLATION.
ON ON THE FACE OF IT -- AND WE
WILL SOON FIND OUT WHETHER A
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT CAN
ACTUALLY BE RATIONED THE
EXERCISING OF A CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHT.
AND THAT -- ISN'T IN THE
PURCHASE OF A FIREARM.
AND IF A CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT
CAN BE RATIONED IN YOU CAN BUY
MORE THAN.
ONE GONNA A MONTH.
WHAT ELSE CAN BE RATIONED?
THE ENUMERATED CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHTS.
THAT ISSUE IS GOING TO BE
DECIDED BY THE SUPREME COURT
REALLY SOON.
AND THAT MAY BE THIS LEGISLATURE
INSTEAD OF JUMPING AHEAD MY WAIT
AND SEE.
WHAT THE SUPREME COURT DOES --
AND NOT HAVE TO GO THROUGH A LOT
OF EFFORT -- NEEDLESSLY WHEN --
OUR SOLUTIONS ARE ARE ARE ARE
NOT.
IN THE RATIONING OF
CONSTITUTIONALLY ENUMERATED
RIGHTS THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE FOR THE RECORD AND
READ WITH NATIONAL RIFLE
ASSOCIATION.
WE'RE HERE IN OPPOSITION TODAY
CALIFORNIA'S HOME TO HUNDREDS
AND HUNDREDS OF GUN LAWS AND
THIS IS A CONCEPT WE HAVE HEARD
BEFORE ON FARM RATIONING AND AND
THIS IS ONE MORE LAW THAT'S
THAT'S FOCUSED ON LAW ABIDING
CITIZENS WE ALREADY HAVE LAWS.
THAT -- WHEN IT COMES TO
PURCHASING A FIREARM YOU NEED A
FARM SAFETY CERTIFICATE YOU NEED
TO UNDERGO A BACKGROUND CHECK
PHILIP A FEDERAL PAPERWORK STATE
PAPERWORK -- UNDERGO A TEN DAY
WAITING PERIOD WE ALSO OF LAWS
DEALING WITH TRAFFICKING OF
FIREARMS WITH STRAW PURCHASES.
AND THIS LAWS IS REALLY FOCUSED
ON LAW ABIDING CITIZENS BECAUSE
CRIMINALS WHO ARE OUT THERE
ACQUIRING FIREARMS REALISTIC
MEANS OR WHO MAY BE TRAFFICKING
FIREARMS.
OR ACQUIRING THEM THROUGH STRAW
PURCHASE OR ANY ANY OF THE THE
THINGS THAT WE'RE TRYING TO
TARGET ARE NOT GONNA BE IMPACTED
BY THIS BECAUSE THEY'RE NEVER
GOING TO GO TO A DEALER TO
PURCHASE.
A FIREARM THEY'RE OPERATING
OUTSIDE THE LAW THIS IS FOCUS ON
LAW ABIDING CITIZENS AND I THINK
WE SHOULD REALLY FOCUS ON THE
CRIMINAL MISUSE OF FIREARM.
RATHER THAN ADDING ONE MORE LAW
ON THOSE PEOPLE WHO ARE OUT
THERE WHO MAY BE ACQUIRING MORE
THAN ONE FIREARM FOR A VARIETY
OF PURPOSES -- INCLUDING -- COST
SAVINGS TIME SAVING SIX CETERA
BECAUSE PURCHASING A FIREARM THE
STATE IS IS A COSTLY PROCESS AND
IT REQUIRES MULTIPLE TRIPS THE
TO A DEALER AND AND SO SOMETIMES
IT'S A CONVENIENT SAYING
SOMETIMES IT'S YOU'RE GETTING
INTO A COMPETITIVE SHOOTING
SPORTS THAT MIGHT REQUIRE MORE
THAN ONE FIREARM.
AND SO I THINK THAT WE SHOULD
REALLY FOCUS ON THE CRIMINAL
MISUSE RATHER THAN THOSE WHO ARE
COMPLYING WITH OUR LAWS HERE IN
THE CITY CALIFORNIA THAT WERE IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU YES MA'AM GOOD MORNING
AYE MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE KATHY LET'S
REPRESENTING THE NATIONAL
SHOOTING SPORTS FOUNDATION
OUTDOOR SPORTS INSTALLATION
SPARKLE OF INTERNATIONAL AND
CALIFORNIA SPORTSMEN'S LOBBY ALL
IN OPPOSITION IN THIS DOES
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTS
SPORTSMAN.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS WORK
AT THE SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND PISTOL
ASSOCIATION WERE IN STRONG
OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU THANK YOU [inaudible]
OF ANY ERA OPPOSITION.
OF BRING IT TO COMMITTEE BUT
I'VE REMOVED OIL. FOUR YOU'RE
SAYING THAT THERE THERE'S TO
PREEN COURT MAYBE OPINING ON
REGULATING OR YOU ST IN THIS
LEGISLATIVE IN THIS SESSION
BEFORE OCTOBER OR TO SUBJECT
COULD COME UP NEXT YEAR ALL THIS
IS -- SCHEDULE THERE ARE GOOD
LOOKING THEY HAVEN'T.
PUT A DEFINITIVE DATE BUT
THEY'RE LOOKING AT THE VERY
BEGINNING OF NEXT SESSION WHICH
BEGINS IN OCTOBER.
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS [inaudible]
YES.
I'M THANK YOU I HAD -- TWO
QUESTIONS THE FIRST IS JUST TO
CLARIFY DOES THIS IMPACT -- THE
FOLKS WHO WILL SELL -- WHO ARE
BUYING -- WHO ARE ALSO PART OF A
BUY BACK PROGRAM [inaudible]
NO.
SOME PART OF A BUY BACK PROGRAM
OKAY SO THIS WOULD THAT'S A LIKE
A LOCAL GOVERNMENT THAT'S RIGHT
RIGHT NOW IT WOULD NOT IMPACT
THAT AT ALL OKAY.
AND THOSE HAVE BEEN VERY
SUCCESSFUL IN SEVERAL OF BEEN.
DONE IN MY DISTRICT.
OKAY SO I JUST WANTED TO CLARIFY
BECAUSE MOST FOLKS WHO ARE.
GOING TO PARTICIPATE IN A BUY
BACK PROGRAM MAY HAVE MORE THAN
ONE GUN.
THE SECOND QUESTION IS WHY ARE --
WHY IS THERE AN EXEMPTION -- TO
VETERANS AND THOSE -- WHO ARE?
HAVE AN ACTIVE MEMBERSHIP IN
ARMED FORCES NATIONAL GUARD --
NATIONAL GUARD. FOR TWO REASONS
TO STATISTICALLY THEY TEND NOT
TO BE THE BULK PURCHASERS WHO
ARE RESELLING THE GUNS TO THE
NEFARIOUS HANDS AND WE JUST
THOUGHT IT WAS A PRUDENT
EXEMPTION THAT'S NOT WHERE THE
PROBLEM LIES.
OKAY THE REASON I ASK IS BECAUSE
I GUESS THREE OF THE TEN MOST
DEADLIEST MASS SHOOTINGS --
OCCURRED BY FOLKS WHO ARE
VETERANS AND SO I CERTAINLY
CONSIDER THEM TO BE PART OF THE
CONVERSATION THAT WE'RE HAVING
WHEN WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
FIREARM SAFETY AND GUN VIOLENCE
PREVENTION.
ANY ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS -- YOU MAKE.
EIGHT YOU MAY CLOSE I WAS GONNA
DO.
MISTER CHAIR IF I COULD COMMENT
ON TWO OF THE OTHER POINTS.
THAT WERE MADE BY THE OPPOSITION.
OBVIOUSLY THE HANDGUN LAW THAT
WAS PASSED IN NINETEEN NINETY
NINE HAS NOT BEEN CHALLENGED --
AND SO THAT'S BEEN UPHELD. FOR A
LONG TIME SO WE DON'T ANTICIPATE
THAT BEING.
AN ISSUE AND FRANKLY IT'S THE
BALL PURCHASES THAT WE'RE TRYING
TO GET AT AND THAT'S WHERE --
THE BAD GUYS DO GET THE GUNS
FROM THOSE BOB FOR PURCHASE
PURSES SO WE THINK IT'S A
PRINTING AND WITH THAT I'LL
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU AND I I THINK THE THE
REASON I ASK THE OPPOSITION
ABOUT.
NGUYEN SUPREME COURT WOULD RULE
ON I USED TO WORK REGULATED.
THEY MAY BE USED TO WRITE
RESTRICTED UP BUT WHATEVER.
I TO TELL ALL ABOUT THE SAME --
THE SECOND MINUTE TALK ABOUT
REGULATED MILITIA SO -- I THINK
RIGHT NOW TODAY -- BASED ON THE
SECOND AMENDMENT WE HAVE THAT.
ABILITY TO REGULATE -- HOW WE
OPERATE WITH OUR OUR GUN SALES
AND IN USE?
AND SO CHAIR IS RECOMMENDING AND
I ON SB SIXTY ONE THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER.
CHEN SIR I LACKEY LACKEY NO
BARRICADE HAND BACKHAND HI
MATHIS.
MATHIS NO KAMLAGER-DOVE OF
KAMLAGER-DOVE OF NOT VOTING
QUIRK.
QUIRK I SANTIAGO [inaudible]
WICKS.
DON'T CALL NEEDS.
TO THANK YOU NEXT.
SB.
ONE SEVENTY TWO YES.
ONE SEVENTY TWO ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS SB.
ONE SEVENTY TWO HAS MANY FACTORS
WITHIN THE BILL ALL RELATED TO
INSURING FIREARMS ARE PROPERLY
LOCKED AND STORED.
IMPROPER STORAGE OF FIREARMS IN
THE HOME FRANKLY ARE KILLING OUR
YOUTH THE MASS MAJORITY VAST
MAJORITY OF ACCIDENTAL FIREARM
DEATH SUICIDE SENSELESS ACTS OF
VIOLENCE.
AMONG CHILDREN RELATED EASY
ACCESS TO FIREARMS EXPANDING ON
CHILD ACCESS PREVENTION -- LAWS
WILL LOWER RATES OF
UNINTENTIONAL FIREARM DEATHS
AMONGST OUR YOUTH.
AS BE.
ONE SEVENTY TWO WOULD AUTHORIZE
THE TEMPORARY TRANSFER OF A
FIREARM WITHOUT A FIREARMS
DEALER PARTICIPATION A PERSON
WHO IS EIGHTEEN YEARS.
OF AGE OR OLDER FOR SAFE KEEPING
TO PREVENT IT FROM BEING USED --
IN A SUICIDE ATTEMPT -- IT ALSO
MAKES THE CURRENT CRIME OF
CRIMINAL STORAGE APPLICABLES TO
THE STORAGE OF AN UNLOADED AS
WELL AS LOADED FIREARM.
THE BILL WOULD PLACE ON THE TEN
YEAR PROHIBITION LIST PERSONS
CONVICTED OF THIS CRIME WHICH
MEANS THAT THEY ARE PROHIBITED
FROM OWNING A FIREARM OR
AMMUNITION FOR THAT TEN YEAR
PERIOD.
I KNOW IT'S BEEN RAISED BY AT
LEAST ONE COMMITTEE MEMBER ABOUT.
OVER BURDENING THE SYSTEM AND
THAT IT'S A VALID QUESTION TO TO
ASK AND I WOULD COMMENT THAT I
KNOW -- ASSEMBLY MEMBER BAUER K.
HANDS -- COMPANION LEGISLATION --
THAT'S MOVING THROUGH THE SENATE
I HELPS TO ADDRESS THAT PROBLEM
AND ALLEVIATE THOSE CONCERNS BY
DEALING WITH -- THE WERE JUST
ONE ON MY HEAD -- THE APPS AND
ALSO -- POWER OF ATTORNEY ISSUES
TO HELP STREAMLINE THAT AND MAKE
SURE THE OJ CAN PROPERLY PROCESS
THESE THINGS SO IT'S THE RIGHT
QUESTION ASK AND I'M GLAD THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HAS THE SOLUTION --
CURRENT LAW ALSO MAKES IT A
CRIME TO KEEP A HAND GUN WITHIN
THE PROMISE OF A KNOWLEDGE THAT
A CHILD -- PERSON PROHIBITED
FROM PROFESSING OF POSSESSING A
FIREARM IS LIKELY TO GAIN ACCESS
IF THE CHILD OR PROHIBITED
PERSON OBTAINS ACCESS TO THE
HANDGUN AND CARRIES IT OFF
PROMISES.
I SB ONE SEVEN TWO WOULD MAKE
THIS CRIME APPLICABLES ALL TYPES
OF FIREARMS AGAIN THE QUESTION'S
BEEN RAISED ABOUT THAT AND
CURRENTLY IT APPLIES TO HAND
GUNS BUT NOT. TOO LONG GUNS AND
SOME OTHER NECESSITY FOR THE
BILL CURRENT LAW MAKES IT A
CRIME FOR OWNERS OF LEGAL -- OR
LEGAL OCCUPANT OF A RESIDENTS TO
STORE FIREARM IN THAT RESIDENTS
IF THE PERSON KNOWS ANOTHER
PERSON RESIDING IN THAT
RESIDENTS IS A PROHIBITED PERSON
PROPOSED.
POSSESSING A FIREARM UNLESS THE
FIREARM IS SECURED THE BILL
WOULD PUT THIS CRIME ON THE TEN
THE LIST AS WELL -- THE KEEP OUR
SENIOR SAY FACT -- WAS ALSO PART
OF THIS WHICH WOULD REQUIRE
REGULATIONS. TO FOR PROCEDURES
FOR A FIREARM AND AMMUNITION TO
BE CENTRALLY STORED IN A LOCK ON
SAFE WITHIN A REDSHIRT
RESIDENTIAL CARE FACILITY --
WHICH IS ALSO AN IMPORTANT PART
OF WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO HERE
I WOULD ALSO REQUIRE A FACILITY
TO PREPARE AND MAINTAIN
INDIVIDUAL WEAPONS INVENTORY.
PRE CHARM AND THE TYPE OF
AMMUNITION STORED WITHIN THE
FACILITY AND SUBMIT THOSE
INVENTORIES TO DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE I HAVE SEVERAL PEOPLE
HERE TO TESTIFY MONICA MILLER ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA ADVOCATES.
AND AMANDA WILCOX ON BEHALF OF
THE BRADY UNITED CAMPAIGN.
OUR AGAIN AMANDA WILCOX ON
BEHALF OF BRADY CALIFORNIA -- SO
SB ONE SIFT SEVENTY TWO
STRENGTHENS CALIFORNIA'S
EXISTING SAFE STORAGE LAWS WOULD
MAKE THE LAWS ARE CURRENTLY
APPLY. TO A LOADED.
FIREARM TO APPLY TO UNLOADED
FIREARMS AS WELL -- IN ALSO
WOULD REQUIRE -- IF THE HAND AND
THAT'S NOT CLOSE OFF PRATT
PROMISES OF PIPELINE ANY FIREARM
AS YOU HEARD.
THIS IS SIT STAY SAFE STORAGE IN
THE HOME REQUIREMENTS AND
FINALLY WOULD OPPOSE IMPOSE A
TEN YOUR FIREARM PROHIBITION AND
THOSE WHO VIOLATE THE SAFE
STORAGE LAWS WHICH ARE TO KEEP.
FIREARMS WHETHER LOADED OR NOT
WHETHER HANDGUN OR LONG GONE.
AWAY FROM CHILDREN AND FROM
PEOPLE WHO RESIDE IN THE HOME
WHO ARE PROHIBITED -- FROM
HAVING ACCESS TO FIREARMS.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT
APPROXIMATELY 65% OF SCHOOL
SHOOTINGS THE ATTACK REQUIRED
THE GUN FOR HIS FROM HIS OR HER
HOME OWN HOME OR THAT OF A
RELATIVE. FOR THESE REASONS THE
LOS ANGELES BLUE RIBBON PANEL ON
SCHOOL SAFETY RECOMMENDS THAT
STATE LAW MAKE FAILURE TO SIX
SAFELY SICKER FIREARM BASIS FOR
PROHIBITING A PERSON FROM OWNING
A FIREARM.
AGAIN IT STANDS TO REASON THAT
IF SOMEONE IS NOT RESPONSIBLE
WITH THEIR FIREARMS SAFE STORAGE
IN THE BREAKING THE LAW IN THAT
REGARD.
THAT -- A LOGICAL CONSEQUENCES A
TEMPORARY FARM PROHIBITION --
AND THEN FINALLY THAT -- THE LAW
THIS ACTUALLY WEAKENS EXISTING
LAW REGARDING -- LANDING OF OF
OF A FIREARM -- WHEN THERE'S A
RISK OF SUICIDE?
ALL RIGHT NOW WITH SOMEONE WHO
IS AT RISK OF SUICIDE IF A
FAMILY MEMBER WANTS TO GET THE
GUN OUT OF THE HOME -- AND THEY
GIVE IT TO A FRIEND TO SIFT
SECURE STORE SAFELY THEY WOULD
BE RAPED BREAKING THE LAW ALL
THE SUICIDE PREVENTION
LITERATURE OUT THERE SAYS WHEN
THERE'S A RISK OF SUICIDE.
GET THE GUN OUT OF THE HOME GIVE
IT TO A TRUSTED FRIEND OR
RELATIVE WE'RE HAPPY TELLING HIM
TO BREAK THE LAW -- BY THAT BY
THAT MESSAGING -- AND SO
THEREFORE THERE NEEDS TO BE THIS
EXEMPTION ALLOWING.
A FRIEND OF SOMEONE A TRUSTED
FRIEND TO STORE THE FIREARM AS
LONG AS THEY MEET CERTAIN
CONDITIONS -- SUCH THE SECURING
IT -- IT'S SECURE STORAGE AND
THE HAVING THE FIREARM UNLOADED
AND SO WE THINK THAT'S IMPORTANT
SUICIDE PROVENCHER PREVENTION
MEASURE I JUST MIGHT REMIND YOU
THAT OVER HALF THE GUN DEATHS IN
CALIFORNIA.
OUR PRICE SUICIDE -- AND THEN
THE RELATION THAT PROVISION
RELATED TO THE REDS RESIDENTIAL
pI'LL TURN THAT OVER TO YOU.
BUT WE ARE AT YOUR SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS MONICA
MILLER REPRESENTING CAR WHICH
I'M CONSUMER ADVOCATES FOR OUR
C. F. E. REFORM ON THE WHAT
THOSE ARE IS A RESIDENTIAL CARE
FACILITIES.
THAT WERE CREATED IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY SIX AND THEIR INTENDED TO
BE A HOME.
SET HOME BASED SETTING SO WHEN
YOU HAVE A GRANDFATHER A MOTHER
AND UNCLE SOMEONE THAT YOU'RE
CHECKING INTO A FACILITY.
AT THEIR NON MEDICAL BUT WE DO
HAVE A HIGH PERCENTAGE OF
INDIVIDUALS WITHIN THOSE
FACILITIES THAT HAVE ON
ALZHEIMER'S ARE ALL DAMAGED
RELATED DEMENTIA.
AND SO ON THERE'S NO REGULATION
REGARDING HOW YOU STORE THEIR
FIREARMS THEY CAN BRING ANYTHING
THEY WANT INTO THAT FACILITY
BECAUSE IT'S THEIR HOME
ESSENTIALLY THEY'RE RENTING A
ROOM.
IN SOMEONE'S HOME TO YOU'VE GOT
CHILDREN THERE POTENTIALLY
YOU'VE GOT CARE GIVERS YOU GOT
FAMILY VISITING SO THEY SHOULD
BE ALLOWED TO BRING IN THEIR
FIRE AND THAT THEIR
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT.
BUT WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WHEN THEY HAVE THIS FIRE ARMS ON
PREMISES THEY ARE STORED
PROPERLY AND SAFELY SO THERE
AREN'T.
ANY POTENTIAL PROBLEMS WITH
SOCIAL WORKERS ETCETERA WERE
WORKING WITH DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES COMMITTEE CARE
LICENSING DIVISION NOW TO ENSURE
THAT WE CAN IMPLEMENT THIS BILL
THAT IT MAKES SENSE.
THAT THEIR SOCIAL WORKERS ARE
SAFE WHEN THEY GOING TO DO THE
CHECKS AND SO FOR THESE REASONS
WE URGE YOUR AYE ABOUT TODAY AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU -- ANY WITNESSES
OPPOSITION -- SUPPORT I'M SORRY
SUPPORT.
I WAS LOOKING.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS ELIZABETH ASPEN US ON
BEHALF OF THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
CALVIN QUICK VERY STERN
ACTIVISTS IN SUPPORT.
AND NOW ARE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THRILLER FOR THE
RECORD AND RE WITH NATIONAL
RIFLE ASSOCIATION. FOR STUFF ONE
OF START OFF BY I THINK THAT THE
SUICIDE PREVENTION ELEMENT
ALLOWING THAT EXEMPTION.
NOT CASES IS A GREAT THING AND
THAT'S NOT WHAT OUR OPPOSITION
HINGED ON THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
WE'VE REPEATEDLY BROUGHT UP --
IN VARIOUS HEARINGS AS THERE IS
EFFORTS TO EXPAND BACKGROUND
CHECKS INCLUDING THE THIRTY DAY
CATCH ALL PROVISION THAT USED TO
ALLOW. FOR FIREARMS TO BE STORED
FOR OUR LOAN FOR ANY PURPOSE
HERE IN CALIFORNIA UP UNTIL A
COUPLE YEARS AGO SO -- OUR OUR
OPPOSITION IS HINGED ON THIS ONE
SIZE FITS ALL APPROACH TO TO
FARM STORAGE -- AND THE THE
PENALTIES THAT ARE ARE.
THIS BASS WERE YOU CAN LOSE YOUR
RIGHTS FOR UP TO TEN YEARS FOR
THIS.
MISDEMEANOR INFRACTION THIS IS.
THIS ONE SIZE FITS ALL APPROACH
COULD RENDER FARMS -- USELESS
ARE UNAVAILABLE IN SELF DEFENSE
SITUATIONS WHICH IS PROBLEMATIC --
FURTHER ON THE ELDER CARE
FACILITIES -- THE THE
REQUIREMENTS UNDER THIS BILL ARE
PRETTY ARDUOUS -- STORING
AMMUNITION SEPARATELY FROM FARMS
ARE FIRING PINS BEING PULLED OUT
OF FARMS IT'S IT'S VERY
TECHNICAL THERE'S A LOT OF
LIABILITY THAT A FACILITIES
GONNA TAKE ON ON BY DOING THIS
IT ALMOST LOOKS LIKE IT'S
DISCOURAGING.
THEM FROM DOING THIS IN THE
FIRST PLACE AND SO -- WITH THAT
WERE IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
SAMPRAS AND UP I WANT TO BRING
UP.
THE CONSTITUTIONALITY OF THIS
ISSUE THAT TENDS TO BE MY MY
DRUM -- HELLER VERSES UNITED
STATES THE FOUNDATIONAL RULING
OF THAT WAS THAT.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT COULD NOT
REQUIRE.
RESIDENTS OF HOMES TO KEEP THEIR
GUNS [inaudible]
DISASSEMBLED.
LOCKED OR OR STORED IN A MANNER
THAT THEY ARE NOT IMMEDIATELY
AVAILABLE TO THEM. FOR
PROTECTION IN THE HOME THAT'S
WHAT HELLER SAID THE INDIVIDUAL
RIGHTS AND ALL OF THAT STUFF
THAT WAS IN ADDITION BUT THAT
WAS THE FOUNDATION OF THE
LAWSUIT.
MCDONALD VERSUS CHICAGO A YEAR
AND A HALF LATER CAME BACK AND
SAID THAT.
RULING IN THAT RIGHT IS SO.
IMPORTANT TO ORDERED LIBERTY
THAT NOT A ON ONLY -- THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT STATE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS COULD NOT INFRINGE
ON THAT RIGHT SOME PEOPLE ARE
GONNA SAY WELL YOU KNOW THE
SAMPLE CITY SAN FRANCISCO CITY
AND COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO --
HAS A STATE STORAGE LAW THAT WAS
TAKEN ALL OVER THE SUPREME COURT
THE SUPREME COURT DECIDED NOT TO
TAKE THAT CASE.
THAT DOESN'T SET PRECEDENT BY
NOT TAKING THE CASE.
THE RULING ON HELLER AND
MCDONALD STILL STAND.
AND GIVEN THAT -- THE SUPREME
COURT APPEARS TO BE READY. TO
ISSUE A RULING GIVEN --
GOVERNING.
LEVEL OF SCRUTINY.
I THINK THAT IS THEIR WAY OF
SAYING OKAY ALL OF THESE OTHER
CASES ARE GOING TO BE HANDLED
THEMSELVES.
ON A LOCAL LEVEL SO WE BELIEVE
THAT THE STORAGE.
VISIONS OF THIS LAW IN THIS THAN
THE STORAGE LAWS ON THE BOOKS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA ARE
INHERENTLY UNCONSTITUTIONAL
ACCORDING TO UNITED STATES
SUPREME COURT. FOR THESE AND ALL
THE REASONS STATED BY MY
COLLEAGUES WE'RE OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE CAPITALIZE
REPRESENT THE NATIONAL SHOOTING
SPORTS FOUNDATION IN OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL WE DO SUPPORT THE
SUICIDE PREVENTION WERE IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE NATIONAL
SUICIDE PREVENTION HOTLINE.
OUR MAJOR OBJECTION IS TO THE
TEN YEAR PROBATION AND THE GOOD
SENATOR MENTIONED AB TWELVE
NINETY TWO WHEN WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THAT BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
MORE MATURE MEN MEMBERS WERE
GOOD FOR THEM TO HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA RIVAL PISTOL
ASSOCIATION WERE IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THERE WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
REBEKAH ARCADIA THANK YOU AND
WHAT I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL.
THE COMMUNITIES IN MY DISTRICT
ARE WORKING TO PASS A STORAGE
ORDINANCES BECAUSE WE HAVEN'T
DONE IT IS A STATE.
AND TWO CITIES HAVE PASSED IT
OTHERS ARE WORKING ON IT BUT THE
PATCHWORK IS ACTUALLY MUCH MORE
COMPLICATED I THINK THEN ASKED
STEPPING UP AND DOING IT ON A
STATEWIDE BASIS.
AS A MOTHER I KNOW THAT WHEN IT
COMES TO FIREARMS ONE OF THE
GREATEST RISKS THAT MY KIDS FACE
IS ON PLAY DATES WHERE THEY
MIGHT ENCOUNTER AND UNLOCKED.
AND FIREARM THAT IS LOADED AND
SO I'M NOT CRAZY MOM WHO ASKS
BEFORE MY KIDS GOING TO PLAY
DATE.
BUT I WANT TO KNOW THAT WE'RE
DOING EVERYTHING WE CAN TO KEEP
KIDS SAFE IN THE HOME BECAUSE
THAT IS OUR JOB.
AND AS TO THE OPPOSITION'S POINT
ONE OF THE CITY COUNCILS THAT IN
AN A PASSING ONE OF THESE
ORDINANCES. ONE OF THE CITY
COUNCIL MEMBERS WHO IS A GUN
OWNER HAD CONCERNS ABOUT HER
ABILITY TO ACCESS HER FIREARMS
WAS LOCKED.
AND THE COMMUNITY MEMBERS WHO
ARE PUSHING FOR IT GAVE HER A
TRIGGER LOCK AND SAID WOULD YOU
JUST GO HOME AND TRY THIS.
AND SHE WENT HOME AND IN THE
DARK JUNGLE IT'S OFF LIKE SHE
WAS ASLEEP SHE COULD UNLOCK THAT
GUN SO QUICKLY THAT SHE ENDED UP
VOTING FOR THE ORDINANCE.
SO I DON'T BELIEVE THAT THIS
DOES HAMPER THE ABILITY TO
ACCESS A FIREARM JUST BECAUSE
IT'S LOCKED WE HAVE.
SUCH AMAZING TECHNOLOGY THESE
DAYS WHERE YOU COME AGAIN USING
YOUR FINGERPRINT IN A SECOND AND
SO I JUST THINK.
THAT THIS DOESN'T HAMPER ON THE
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS AND WE
HAVE LIVES AT RISK AND SO WE
NEED TO DO EVERYTHING WE CAN.
SO I THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS --
I WOULD LOVE TO BE A PRINCIPAL
CO AUTHOR AND I HOPE EVERYONE
SUPPORTS.
THANK YOU YES.
I TO WANT TO THANK YOU -- FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD IN
ADDING TO THE CONTINUED
CONVERSATIONS THAT WERE HAVING.
AROUND GUN VIOLENCE AND GUN
VIOLENCE PREVENTION --
UNFORTUNATELY I WILL NOT BE ABLE
TO SUPPORT THIS BILL I AM VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT ADDING
ADDITIONAL CRIMES TO OUR LIST --
AND THE PENAL CODE AND ALSO JUST
HAVE SOME -- CONCERNS AROUND
ADDITIONAL -- PROHIBITIONS THAT --
WE ARE -- PLACING -- ON VARIOUS
CIVIL LIBERTIES -- THAT WE HAVE
TO TALK ABOUT THAT COME TO THIS
COMMITTEE THEM BUT I DID WANT TO
JUST SORT OF THIS STATE THAT
BECAUSE I GENERALLY DON'T -- GET
INTO THAT WHEN WE'RE HAVING OUR
YOU FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
MR COURT.
SOMEONE TO CLARIFY SOMETHING
WHEN.
I WOULD SAY THAT THE THREE OF US
IF YOU'RE SPOKE AND READ THIS
BILL.
AND FELT THAT IT APPLIED TO
RESIDENTS AS WELL AS RESIDENTIAL
FACILITIES IN TALKING WITH
COMMITTEE STAFF.
THEY THINK THE BELL ONLY RECALL.
ON STORAGE IT ONLY REPLIES.
IT ONLY APPLIES TO RESIDENTIAL
FACILITIES COULD YOU --
ELABORATE THAT BECAUSE I AM
THOUGHT TO BUILD REQUIRE.
APPLY TO ALL STORAGE.
IS IT ONLY FOR RESIDENTIAL
FACILITIES NOW THERE'S TWO
DIFFERENT PIECES OF IT THE
RESIDENTIAL FACILITIES WE'RE
CREATING A REGULATORY --
ENVIRONMENT AND THEN FOR
RESIDENCES WERE OKAY SAID THEIR
OWNERS YEAH THERE WOULD APPEAR
TO BE A DIFFERENCE [inaudible]
BETWEEN WHAT.
SO HOW COULD COMMITTEE OUR STAFF.
A PINE ON THIS -- IT DOES THE
ARM DOES THIS REQUIRE DOES THE
STORAGE REQUIREMENT AT OR I
WOULD SAY CONSEQUENCE.
APPLY TO ALL RESIDENTS OR SIMPLY
RESIDENTIAL FACILITIES.
THERE ARE TWO ELEMENTS OF THE
BILL THE RESIDENTIAL STORAGE
FACILITY.
THE RESIDENTIAL FACILITY ELEMENT --
CREATES A STANDARD.
AND THEN THERE IS AT THE
SEPARATE -- STORAGE CRIME THAT
WILL PUT YOU ON THE TEN YEAR
PROHIBITED PERSONS LIST THAT'S
UNRELATED TO THE CARE FACILITY.
ELEMENT OF THE BILL OKAY SO I
MISUNDERSTOOD STAFF THANK YOU --
I HAVE CONCERNS NOT THAT IT
ISN'T LOGICAL TO DO THIS BUT
THAT WE HAVE SO MANY PEOPLE
ALREADY ON THE LIST.
THAT YOU WOULD BE ADDING MORE
AND IT MIGHT BE DIFFICULT TO
ENFORCE AND I BELIEVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE HAS THE SAME
CONCERN.
THAT WE ALREADY HAVE TWENTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE ON THE LIST YOU
CAN'T HAVE GUNS AND THEY'RE
BEING -- THE ENFORCEMENT IS IS
NOT OCCURRING AND WE'RE JUST
ADDING MORE PEOPLE TO THE LIST.
ON THE LIST THAT'S TOO LONG
ALREADY.
THAT'S MY CONCERN ABOUT THE BILL
I WILL BE SUPPORTING IT TODAY
BUT I WISH YOU WOULD RECONSIDER
THAT PART AT THE BELL.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
A CLOSE THANK YOU -- I'M
OBVIOUSLY NOT A SUPREME COURT
JUSTICE BUT I KNOW SUPREME COURT
JUSTICES I IN THE PAST HAVE
OPINED.
ON A NARROW FOCUS WHEN KIDS ARE
INVOLVED I THINK EVEN BRETT
KAVANAUGH AS CONSERVATIVE AS HE
IS HAS.
A STATED HIS VIEWS THAT -- THERE
IS A ROLE TO BE PLAYED AS FAR AS
REGULATING FIREARMS WHEN
CHILDREN SAFETIES INVOLVED IN I
THINK AND JUSTICE SCALIA'S WELL
OPINED ON THAT -- A VERY CLEARLY
AND I THINK WE FALL INTO THAT
CATEGORY -- IN RELATION TO MR
QUIRKS COMMON SIDE I DO BELIEVE
THAT -- ASSEMBLY MEMBER BAUER K.
HANDS -- COMPANION PIECE WILL
ADDRESS SOME OF THAT.
TO MOST OF THOSE CONCERNS AND
HELP THIS BE MORE OFFICIALLY --
IMPLEMENTED SO I I THINK -- I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THAT EFFORT AND
I THINK THAT WILL HELP -- CLEAR
THAT PIECE UP -- WE THINK THIS
IS A LOGICAL EXTENSION YOU KNOW
IF YOU.
MISS USE YOUR CAR.
YOU CAN LOSE THE RIGHT.
TO HAVE YOUR CAR IF YOU -- BREAK
OTHER LAWS YOU YOU YOU.
KNOW IT'S APPROPRIATE FOR THE
GOVERNMENT TO STEP IN WHEN
YOU'RE NOT BEING RESPONSIBLE.
AND WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS SAY
IF YOU'RE A GUN OWNER YOU BETTER
BE RESPONSIBLE ANY BETTER MAKE
SURE IT DOESN'T FALL INTO THE
WRONG HANDS -- AND SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
[inaudible]
WE WILL [inaudible]
OKAY.
SO THAT WAS AGO OKAY SO -- LOOK
THERE THERE'S SOME AND WE HADN'T
ANOTHER CENTER THAT WAS ADDING
TO THE APPS LISTS WHO DID
PRESENT TODAY BECAUSE WE WERE
CONCERNED ABOUT ADDING TODAY.
TODAY ABSOLUTE SO I I THINK YOU
NEED TO RESOLVE THAT WITH
COMMITTEE MEMBERS OF OF WEEK
GETS OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE I
THINK YOU GO TO HUMAN SERVICES
AND PROBES WHERE.
SOME PROPRIOCEPTION JUST CAN BE
MADE OR CONCERNS CAN BE RESOLVED --
IF GETS OUT HERE SO HOPING THAT
WE GET THROUGH THIS AND THAT YOU
ADDRESS THAT BECAUSE QUITE
FRANKLY PROVEN TO BE CONSISTENT.
WITH WHAT WE TOLD OTHERS ABOUT
THE APPS -- LIST WE PROBABLY
GONNA HAVE TO BE CONSISTENT.
I TO GETTING FUNDING.
OR GETTING COMMITMENTS FROM THE
AG THAT HE WILL BE ABLE TO
HANDLE THE ADDITIONAL.
WORKLOAD -- WOULD BE HELPFUL.
AND SO THE CHAIRS WRECK IN MANY
IN AYE VOTE WITH THE
UNDERSTANDING THAT.
THERE NEEDS TO BE SOME URTHER
DISCUSSION ON THE APPS PART
ABSOLUTELY.
HONESTY ONE SEVENTY TWO THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE HUMAN
SERVICES COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER AYE LACKEY.
LACKEY NO BARRICADE HAND PACKING
HAD AYE MATHIS [inaudible]
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE NOT VOTING QUIRK.
I FOR TODAY.
QUIRK AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I WICKS WICKS I THAT
MEASURE PASSES SO WE HAVE ONLY
TEN MORE MINUTES BECAUSE WE HAVE
BUT WE HAVE A HARD CLOSE I'M
SORRY MR WINNER.
AND WHICH MEANS WE'LL BE COMING
BACK AT FOUR O'CLOCK.
I KNOW YOU'VE BEEN WAITING
PATIENTLY IN PERTH PEOPLE FUNDS
I PERSONALLY APOLOGIZE.
TO A BUT I'M NOT EVEN SURE WILL
BE ABLE TO FINISH WITH
[inaudible]
MR PORTANTINO'S.
IN THAT CASE CAN I DO -- SIX
TWENTY BECAUSE I HAVE THE
PASADENA POLICE TO FEAR AND WANT
TO MAKE SURE THEY GET THEIR
FLIGHTS BACK.
AND THEN WE'LL TRY TO GET. THREE
SEVENTY SIX IN KEEP IT SHORT.
I WILL TRY TO KEEP IT SHORT
THANK YOU MAN [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
COLLEAGUES TODAY I'M PRESENTING
SB SIX TWENTY WHICH WOULD
AUTHORIZE SPECIFIED LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES TO FURNISH
LIMITED INFORMATION ABOUT A
PERSON ON SUPERVISED RELEASE
WITHIN THEIR JURISDICTION -- TO
CITIES COUNTIES AND NONPROFIT
PROVIDERS OF THOSE SERVICES THE
BILL WOULD REQUIRE PERSON ON
SUPERVISED RELEASE TO BE
NOTIFIED.
THAT THEIR INFORMATION MAY BE
RELEASED FOR THIS PURPOSE AND
ALLOW THOSE PERSONS TO OPT IN TO
HAVING THEIR INFORMATION RELEASE
LET'S VERY IMPORTANT NO ONE'S
INFORMATION WOULD BE RELEASED
WITHOUT.
THAT PERSON'S PERMISSION WHEN
SOMEONE IS RELEASED FROM
INCARCERATION THE RETURN TO
THEIR CITY OF RESIDENCE WITHOUT
GUIDANCE OR THE NEEDED RESOURCES
FRANKLY TO GET.
THEIR LIFE ON OUT BACK ON TRACK
WHICH IS WHY WE HAVE ONE OF THE
HIGHEST RECIDIVISM RATES IN THE
WORLD IN LOSS OF THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY 45407%.
OF COMMUNITY MEMBERS TO RETURN
FROM INCARCERATION REPEAT OFFEND
AND ARE RE INCARCERATED WITHIN
THREE YEARS.
THIS RESULTS IN A PREDICTABLE
PREVENTABLE -- COMMITTEE
VIOLENCE AND TRAUMA IN
NEIGHBORHOODS WHAT WE RAISE OUR
CHILDREN AND CERTAINLY DOES NOT
HELP THAT PERSON RELEASED.
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICIALS HAVE A
DATA AND THE PERSONAL
INFORMATION OF EVERY PAROLE LEE
AND POST RELEASE COMMITTEE
SERVICE -- PROBATIONER HOWEVER
THEY CANNOT CONNECT THESE
PREVIOUSLY INCARCERATED
COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO SERVICE
PROVIDERS ARE RELEASE THIS
INFORMATION AS A CANNOT CONNECT
THOSE PREVIOUS INCARCERATED
DIRECTLY WITH THE SERVICE
PROVIDERS THAT CAN HELP.
IT'S HARD TO BREAK THE CYCLE OF
RECIDIVISM BY HAVING CONTACT
INFORMATION OF THOSE RETURNING
TO SOCIETY.
FOCUSING THEIR EFFORTS AND GRANT
FUNDS ON PREVIOUSLY INCARCERATED
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WE THINK IT
WOULD HELP THOSE INDIVIDUAL
SUCCEED AND FRANKLY NOT RE
OFFEND.
THIS BILL WILL ALLOW THOSE ARE
LEAVING PRISON HAVE A GREATER
ACCESS TO CASE MANAGEMENT
FINANCIAL LITERACY MENTAL HEALTH
SUBSTANCE ABUSE TREATMENT AND
IMPORTANT WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
SERVICES WITH ME TODAY I HAVE
PASADENA POLICE CHIEF.
JOHN PRESENT LIEUTENANT -- JASON
CLAWSON AND I WOULD RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE WHEN
APPROPRIATE.
CHIEF.
YES SIR THANK YOU SO PASADENA
STARTED THIS EFFORT OVER TEN
YEARS AGO ON A GRASSROOTS.
A WITH THE POLICE DEPARTMENT
WHEN NO BUDGET NO MONEY AND JUST
USING NON PROFITS IN IN A VERY
SHORT NARRATIVE HERE OVER TEN
YEARS WE'VE SEEN SUCCESS WERE
REINTEGRATION IT'S NOT RE ENTRY
WHICH IS A CALL ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
REINTEGRATION MEANS TO START
OVER WITH A STRATEGY NOT SIMPLY
START OVER SO WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
REDUCE OUR RECIDIVISM ON THE
TWELVE HUNDRED PEOPLE HAVE GONE
THROUGH OUR PROGRAM HERE IN THE
COMMUNITY.
IN PASADENA TO SEVEN POINT 5%
BUT IT'S TAKEN US TEN YEARS TO
GET THERE WE BELIEVE THIS IS A
START POINT A GAME CHANGER FOR
US TO CONNECT NONPROFIT IN OUR
COMMUNITY.
USING PROBATION AND THE B. S. C.
C. AS WELL THAT HAVE -- SYSTEMS
IN PROGRAMS THAT COULD WORK AT
THE ONSET OF RELEASE FROM PRISON
IS THE BEST TIME SOMEBODY WILL
CHANGE YOUR LIFE IT'S THE BEST
TIME TO CATCH HIM TO OPT IN.
INTO A PROGRAM.
THANK YOU.
BUT THAT IT.
OKAY AND ANY OTHER WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESS IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
DANIELS [inaudible]
GOOD -- GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS DANIEL SANCHEZ
ON BEHALF OF THE CHIEF PROBATION
OFFICERS OF CALIFORNIA.
REGRETTABLY IN OPPOSITION I DO
WANT TO A NOTE OUR OUR SHARED A
COMMON GROUND ON THE SPIRIT OF
THIS BILL -- AND CERTAINLY WE
SHARE THE THE EFFORTS OF THE
SENATOR AND OF THE CHIEF HERE
TODAY -- WHERE ARE CONCERNED
STEM FROM IS REALLY THE
MECHANISMS WITHIN THE BILL AND
APPROACH AS IT RELATES TO
CONNECTING -- PEOPLE ON
SUPERVISED RELEASE TO THESE
PROGRAMS AND SERVICES -- THE THE
FUNDAMENTAL ROLE IN MANY WAYS OF
PROBATION IS TO BE ABLE TO
CONNECT TO THOSE COMING OUT OF
BOTH PRISON -- ON PEER CS THOSE
COMING OUT OF JAIL ON MANDATORY
SUPERVISION AND THOSE ON A
PROBATION WITH US TO ALL OF THE
SERVICES THAT THIS BILL SEEKS
WHAT WE'RE VERY MUCH CONCERNED
ABOUT IS THAT ONE OF THE THINGS
THIS COMMITTEE IN THE
LEGISLATURE HAVE DONE OVER.
THE LAST MANY MANY YEARS IS
REALLY FOCUS ON THE INDIVIDUAL
LIES NATURE OF WORKING WITH
OFFENDERS AND WE RECOGNIZE THAT
THERE IS A SIGNIFICANT CRIMINAL
JUSTICERESEARCH ON RISK NEEDS
RESPONSIVITY.
THAT TALKS ABOUT THE NEED TO NOT
JUST CONNECT PEOPLE TO ANY
SERVICE BUT TO CONNECT THEM TO
SERVICES THAT BOTH ADDRESS THEIR
CRIMINAL -- CRIMINAL GENIC NEEDS
AND ALSO THE RIGHT -- SERVICES --
PROBATION WORKS IN CONCERT WITH
THE COURT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
SERVICES THAT.
ARE PROVIDED ARE ALSO IN LINE
WITH THEIR CONDITIONS OF
PROBATION AND THERE'S A WHOLE
HOST OF RISK NEEDS ASSESSMENT
CASE PLANNING AND AND REALLY
INTRICATE THINGS THAT HAPPEN
THAT WE'RE CONCERNED ARE NOT
GONNA BE ACCOUNTED FOR BY
ALLOWING.
FOR A THESE PERSON TO BE
CONNECTED -- WITHOUT ALL OF
THOSE FACTORS KIND OF BROUGHT
INTO INTO BEAR SO -- WE LOOK FOR
TO CONTINUE CONVERSATIONS BUT
FOR THOSE REASONS WERE OPPOSE
TODAY.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WHEN THIS IN OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS [inaudible]
WHO?
QUESTION.
YEAH CAN I CHEST AT CENTER
PORTANTINO TO ADDRESS THAT
BECAUSE I'M IMAGINING THAT
THERE'S QUITE.
IT WOULD BE WONDERFUL IF THERE
ARE QUITE A FEW OF THESE
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS AND IF
ONE WERE TO PUT ON A RELEASE AND
ALL THIS AND THEY'RE ALL
FLOODING YOU.
YOU KNOW.
DOES THAT BENEFITS SOMEONE HOW
ARE WE MAKING SURE THAT THEY'RE
ACTUALLY THIS IS BENEFITING
PEOPLE TO GET.
THE INFORMATION FROM THE SOUTH I
WOULD SAY ON THE BIG PICTURE
OBVIOUSLY WE KNOW WE'RE WE'RE LA
COUNTY THAT 47% AND PASADENA
PT'S AT 7%.
RECIDIVISM RATE.
IT'S WORK AND BUT IN THE
SPECIFIC I LET THE LIEUTENANT
ADDRESS THE SPECIFICS BECAUSE
HE'S DEALING DIRECTLY WITH
PROBATION SO I'VE BEEN DOING
THIS WORK FOR TEN YEARS MY NAME
IS JEFF LAWSON WITH PASADENA
PLEASE.
I'VE BEEN DOING THIS WORK FOR
OVER TEN YEARS -- WELL WE WE'VE
BEEN WORKING WITH PROBATION --
FOR SOME REASON PROBATION WON'T
TAKE ALL THESE PEOPLE TO THE
SERVICE PROVIDERS -- THAT ARE
PROVIDING SERVICES -- WE ARE THE
RECIPIENT OF A GRANT FROM THE
BUREAU STATE COMMUNITY
CORRECTIONS -- TO WHERE WE TWO
AND A HALF MILLION DOLLARS ARE
BEING FUNDED DIRECTLY TOWARDS OF
RECIDIVISM EFFORTS AND PART OF
OUR PROGRAM IS NOT JUST JOB
SKILLS FINANCIAL LITERACY WE'RE
BRINGING PEOPLE IN FOR COGNITIVE
BEHAVIORAL THERAPY.
RAPID ID SENSE OF A PATIENT AND
THESE ARE ALL YOU KNOW WHAT'S
THE SCOPE OF WORK FROM WHEN WE
APPLIED FOR THIS GRANT MONEY
FROM THE STATE.
THIS IS THE STUFF THAT WE'RE
DOING AND IT IS DRIVING DOWN THE
RECESS RECIDIVISM RATES GIVING
PEOPLE ALTERNATIVES -- TO GOING
OUT THERE COMMITTING CRIMES
MAKING OUR NEIGHBORHOODS SAFER
DRIVING DOWN OUR CRIME RATES AND
IT'S PETE IT'S ALLOWING PEOPLE
TO GET THEIR LIVES BACK ON TRACK
AND I JUST GET A JOB IT'S TO GET
CAREERS.
NO WE'VE TRIED TO GO OUT THERE
IN SOLICIT PEOPLE WHO ARE COMING
OUT OF PRISON MY BADGE WILL TELL
THEM ONE THING AND IS A
CREDIBILITY ISSUE WITH IT
BECAUSE THEY THINK I'M GOING TO
RE ARREST THEM.
THEY DON'T THINK THAT THE POLICE
ARE GOING TO HELP THEM SO BY
NEED DIRECTING PEOPLE AND
GETTING CASE MANAGERS AND SYSTEM
NAVIGATION AND CHASERS TO COME
OUT THERE AND GRAB THESE PEOPLE
AND BRING THEM INTO THE SERVICES.
IT ALLOWS FOR US THE WHOLE
COMMUNITY TO HEAL -- FOR
INSTANCE IF I KNEW THERE WAS
SOMEONE SOMEBODY SUFFERING A
MENTAL CRISIS AND I TOLD HEY.
GO OVER THERE AND GET SOME HELP
THEY'RE NEVER GOING TO GO OVER
THERE THIS ALLOWED THE PEOPLE
THAT I WORK WITH THAT I'VE ADDED
THAT I'M ALLOWING MIGHT THIS
INFORMATION TO GET INTO THEIR
HANDS. TO GO OUT AND PHYSICALLY
MAKE CONTACT AND PEOPLE THAT
HAVE BEEN IN PRISON ARE DOING
SOME OF THE WORK TOO SO THERE'S
A CREDIBILITY ISSUE WITH THEM
WITH THE PEOPLE WHO ARE TRYING
TO GET BACK.
ON THEIR FEET AND GET THEIR
CAREERS IN ORDER SO WHAT THAT'LL
SUBMIT.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS I HAVE A
COMMENT YEAH.
YEAH I JUST WOULD LIKE TO SAY
FIRST OF ALL.
I THINK THIS I KNOW OUR OWN.
TIME WHEN THE SOLDIERS QUICK AS
I CAN.
BUT I THINK THIS A BIG DEAL.
AND I THINK IT PROVIDES A
REFRESHING.
MODEL FOR LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND I DON'T SEE IT AS A AS A
THREAT TO A PROBATION I HAVE
HIGH RESPECT.
FOR I SEE IT AS A SUPPLEMENT AND
I THINK THAT -- IT'S AN OPT IN
KIND OF SITUATION AND I THINK
THAT IT'S A WIN WIN. FOR
EVERYONE IN YOUR TO BE COMMENDED
YOUR SUCCESS BECAUSE FOR SELF
AND I APPRECIATE WHAT YOU'RE
DOING AND THIS IS EXCITING.
OKAY ANY OTHER COMMENTS YOU MAY
CLOSE YEAH I THINK IT'S THE THE
SUCCESSES WORKING AND I THINK
HAVING IT BE PROACTIVE VERSUS
REACTIVE AND HAVING IT BE.
ON THE GROUND WHERE PEOPLE KNOW
THE FUNDAMENTAL NEEDS OF THOSE
RELEASED -- PEOPLE I THINK IT'S
BEING IT'S WORKING SO AND I
DON'T THINK IT'S IT'S AT ALL AN
INFRINGEMENT ON PROBATION SO.
RIGHTS RESPONSIBILITIES AND
DUTIES AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL GANGS SO.
THIS IS WHAT BOTHERS ME -- IT
LOOKS LIKE YOU HAVE TWO GREAT
PROGRAM TECH POSSIBLY HELP
PEOPLE AND WE ACT IS PISSING
MATCH GOING ON I DON'T KNOW WHAT
THE DEAL IS -- BUT IF IT GETS
OTHERS COMMITTEE AND WE GET TO
APPROACH.
IF PROBATION AND PASADENA POLICE
DEPARTMENT CANNOT WORK THIS OUT.
THEN I WILL RECOMMEND THAT WE
VOTED DOWN OR IT DOESN'T COME
OUT OF A PRO.
OF BECAUSE THIS IS JUST SILLY.
IT'S JUST SILLY BIOPIC YOU KNOW
YOU'VE GOT TWO POINT THREE
MILLION YOU GET MONEY.
THAT'S A LOT OF MONEY TO HELP A
LOT OF PEOPLE BETTER FORM THE
INCARCERATED.
AND YOU GUYS CAN'T GET LAW YOU
CAN'T FIGURE IT OUT YOU SHOULD
NOT BE IN FRONT OF US TRYING TO
FIGURE THIS OUT.
I DON'T LET ME TO PUT IT THAT
WAY BUT TO SUGGEST.
THIS IS WHAT FRUSTRATES ME ABOUT
LOCAL GOVERNMENT STATE
GOVERNMENT AND ALL THE DIFFERENT
ENTITIES BOB.
YOU HAVE X. AMOUNT OF DAYS IF
YOU DECIDE IS COMMITTEE TO WORK
IT OUT THIS PORTANTINO WHEN I'VE
ALREADY.
WHAT I'M SAYING TO YOU?
I CITY AUTHOR SO IT'S NOT
ANYTHING NEW OR SURPRISING -- SO
I'M HOPING.
THAT THE TWO CAN CAN FIGURE OUT
WHAT IS THE BEST WAY THAT YOU'VE
BEEN TO BOTH CAN WORK TOGETHER
LET'S FACE IT AT THE END OF THE
DAY.
PROBATION HAS THE AUTHORITY.
IF PROBATION SAYS DON'T GO YOUR
WAY THAT TWO POINT THREE MILLION
DOLLARS THAT YOU SEEM TO WANT TO
HOLD ONTO A DRY UP.
BECAUSE AT THE END OF THE DAY
THEY HAVE. TO REPORT TO THIS
INDIVIDUAL.
AND YES THEY CAN USE YOURS ON
THE SIDE AND ADD TO IT.
BUT IF THEY'RE SO TIED UP WITH
THE PROGRAMS THAT PROBATION
TELLS HIM TO AND THEY'RE NOT
ABLE TO ACCESS YOURS.
THAT'S A DISSERVICE TO THE
PEOPLE WERE TRYING TO
REHABILITATE.
AND WE SHOULD WE WORKING TO FIND
THE BEST.
CONTINUUM OF CARE.
PROGRAMS THAT HELP ANYBODY THAT
COMES OUT NOT TRYING TO PICK
THIS ONE VERSUS THAT ONE SO --
IF IT GETS OUT TODAY LET'S LET'S
MAKE THAT HAPPEN.
IS THERE A MOTION HELLO HAVE
BEEN.
ON SB SIX TWENTY THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER HI JOHN
SIR I LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE BARRICADE HAND PARA
QUE HANNAH I AM MATHIS.
MATHIS I KAMLAGER-DOVE.
IN ORDER TO OF NOT VOTING QUIRK.
QUIRK I SANTIAGO [inaudible]
WICKS [inaudible]
WICKS I THE MEASURE PASSES.
IF YOU WOULDN'T MIND I'M LET
MISTER WINNER COMMUNITY YOU HAVE
TO COME BACK IT FOR FOR THE LAST
ONE I GOT ONE MORE.
GOT TO COME BACK I'M SORRY
BECAUSE YES WITNESSES THEY'RE
LEAVING ALL RIGHT.
I GET FOR LESS GLAZER GO
[inaudible]
IT DOESN'T.
SO WE GOT A REPRIEVE UNTIL TEN
MINUTES UNTIL.
NOON [inaudible]
OKAY.
I'VE YES.
THANK YOU -- THEY'LL CHAIRMAN.
SENATE BILL TWENTY THREE WILL
CLOSE A LOOPHOLE IN THE AUTO
BURGLARY STATUTE TO MAKE CLEAR
THAT IF SOMEONE.
BASHES OUT THE WINDOW TO A CAR
FORCIBLY ANSWERS -- THAT THE THE
GUY IS A CRIME REGARDLESS OF
WHETHER THE CAR DOOR WAS LOCKED --
THIS IS -- COMMONSENSE -- AN
OVERDUE A CLARIFICATION OF THE
LAW AND REFLECTS WHAT MOST
PEOPLE WOULD THINK -- AUTO
BURGLARY WOULD BE -- SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE --
WITH ME TODAY I WAS NOT SZABO
FROM THE SAN FRANCISCO DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE AND BARB NOON
WITH CAL TRAVEL.
WILL BE VERY BRIEF.
GOOD MORNING DESCRIBE. TWENTY
THREE TWENTY THREE NUMBER.
ONE I GOOD MORNING JUST VERY
BRIEFLY -- THIS IS A COMMON
SENSE BILL AND THANK YOU CENTER
WINNER FOR BRINGING THIS ACTION
OR THE STATUS INITIATIVE -- OUR
BERKELEY DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACTS VISITORS THEY ARE THE
ONES I HAVE PASSPORT SOME
LUGGAGE AND ALL KINDS OF THINGS
WITH THEM AND THIS BILL ENSURES
THAT THEY'RE NOT
DISPROPORTIONATELY DENIED --
JUSTICE WHEN AND HOW TO BERKELEY
DOES OCCUR AND SO WE JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE BILL I
HAVE A TO THE CLOSEST LOCAL.
THANK YOU.
YES HI BARBARA NEED FROM
CALIFORNIA TRAVEL ASSOCIATION
JUST YOU'RE REPRESENTING THE
TRAVEL AND TOURISM.
INDUSTRY AND WE SUPPORT THIS
BILL IT CLOSES A LOOPHOLE IT'S
COMMON SENSE AND IT'S A WIN WIN.
FOR THE TOURISTS AND ALSO FOR
LAW ENFORCEMENT'S WE ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT THANKS.
THANK CHAIRMAN I DO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS AND APPLY
TO THE SEVEN THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR CENTER WHEN.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
NAME AN ORGANIZATION.
LEARN MORE SKULL FOR A DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S ASSOCIATION STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
LUCIA MUCH CHARM HAVE A
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION SUPPORT.
VENTURE PALMER ON BEHALF OF
ENTERPRISE HOLDINGS IN SUPPORT.
MEMBERS ALL ON BEHALF OF THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY SHERIFF IN
SUPPORT.
YES ORDER.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES SUPPORT ANY
WITNESS IN OPPOSITION.
MARCO GEORGE FROM THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION A
WINNER THANK THE AUTHOR AND
STAFF FOR WORKING WITH THOSE TO
CLARIFY WHAT THE USE OF FORCE
MEANS -- UNFORTUNATELY WE'RE
STILL OPPOSED ON SB TWENTY THREE
WILL TURN UNLAWFUL ENTRY INTO A
CAR WHAT MIGHT HAVE BEEN TWO
MISDEMEANORS -- MALICIOUS
MISCHIEF FOR VANDALISM BY ONE OF
THOUSANDS OF HOMELESS PEOPLE
LOOKING FOR SHELTER AND AND
URBAN AREAS INTO A FELONY.
AS WE TWENTY THREE IS
DUPLICATIVE OF EXISTING LAW AUTO
BURGLARY MAXINE PENALTIES COURTS
HAVE ACCEPTED BROKEN WINDOWS IS
EVIDENCE OF A FORCIBLE ENTRY.
AS CIRCUMSTANTIAL EVIDENCE THAT
THE VEHICLE WAS LOCKED FOR
DECADES -- FINALLY THE LOOPHOLE
THAT THE SPONSORS SEEKS TO CLOSE
AS THE RIGHT TO CONFRONT AND
CROSS EXAMINE THE OWNER RENTER
OF THE VEHICLE.
TOURISTS AND RESIDENTS ALIKE
WILL STILL HAVE TO SHOW UP TO
TESTIFY IN COURT IF THE CASE
GOES TO TRIAL.
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS CAN SEEM
LIKE AN INCONVENIENCE UNTIL YOUR
OWN RIGHTS ARE AT STAKE WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOU KNOW
ABOUT.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION [inaudible]
IN -- BUT ARE YOU IN SUPPORT YES
CLOSE STUCK IN THE SENATE PUBLIC
SAFETY.
TEMPLES ON BEHALF LOS ANGELES
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE IN SUPPORT.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS [inaudible]
COMMENT.
YOU MAY CLOSE THIS REQUEST FOR
RIVAL.
THANK YOU CHAIR SHE RECOMMENDED
I VOTE.
SB TWO ON SB TWENTY THREE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS A MANAGER
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER AYE LACKEY.
LACKEY I OUR CAN [inaudible]
MATHIS.
MATHIS I KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE NOT VOTING QUIRK.
QUIRK I SANTIAGO [inaudible]
WICKS.
WICKS NOT VOTING THAT MEASURE
SOME.
MEASURES ON CALL.
SO YOU WANT.
TO LET'S TRY ANOTHER.
ONE THANK YOU I MISTER CHAIRMAN
NYNEX UP UP ON LIKE TO PRESENT
SENATE BILL ONE THIRTY SECS.
OUR COLLEAGUE SIDE SENATE BILL
ONE THIRTY SIX REPEALS A
COMMENTING COSTLY ONE YOUR
SENTENCING ENHANCEMENT THAT
APPLIES FOR EACH PRIOR FELONY
PRISON TERM.
OR FELONY COUNTY JAIL TERM THAT
INDIVIDUAL HAS SERVED.
THIS ONE YOUR ENHANCEMENT --
REPLENISHES OFFENDERS NOT FOR
PRIOR CRIMINAL CONDUCT BUT PER
FOR PRIOR INCARCERATION --
BECAUSE IT ONLY APPLIES IF THE
PRIOR FELONY RESULTED IN JAIL
TIME IT'S IN A RATIONAL
ENHANCEMENT -- AND STATISTICS
SHOW -- DIE -- PEOPLE OF COLOR
IN LOWER INCOME PEOPLE ARE MORE
LIKELY AND THAT PRIOR FELONY TO
HAVE SERVED TIME AS OPPOSED TO
RECEIVE.
PROBATION SO THERE IS
SIGNIFICANT IRRATIONAL
DISPARITIES IN THIS PARTICULAR
ENHANCEMENTS -- WE HAVE A HOT
ABOUT A HUNDRED AND FIFTY OTHERS
SENSING ENHANCEMENTS UNDER
CALIFORNIA LAW -- PARTICULARLY
FOR VIOLENT AND SERIOUS REPEAT
OFFENDERS THERE ARE MUCH MORE
SEVERE ENHANCEMENTS IN THIS ONE
YOUR ENHANCEMENT THIS ONE YOU'RE
ENHANCE INTENDS TO BE USED FOR
LOW LEVEL -- CRIMES.
AND TIME PARTICULARLY I KNOW
THERE'S BEEN SOME DISCUSSION
ABOUT OMESTIC VIOLENCE CHILD
ABUSE.
THEY HAVE THEIR OWN ENHANCEMENTS
FOR REPEAT DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
REPEAT OUR CHILD ABUSE -- THAT
ARE MORE SEVERE OUR COURTS HAVE
ALL SORTS OF TOOLS -- TO HAVE
PEOPLE INCARCERATED FOR LONGER
PERIODS IF THAT IS APPROPRIATE
IN TERMS OF THE SENTENCING
RANGES IN TERMS OF OTHER
ENHANCEMENTS TERMS STRIKES WHERE
THAT APPLIES.
AND SO FORTH -- SO IT'S TIME TO
REPEAL THIS ENHANCEMENT WHICH
DOES NOTHING TO IMPROVE PUBLIC
SAFETY BUT IS VERY COSTLY -- AND
IS NOT NEEDED SO I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE WITH ME HERE
TODAY OUR TONY WEEKENDS AND
GENEVIEVE JONES -- RIGHT A
PUBLIC DEFENDER.
YES FIVE MINUTES A GOOD MORNING.
TOM GOOD MORNING COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY MY NAME IS TONY
WIGGINS I'M A RESIDENT SOUTHEAST
SAN DIEGO I'M HERE TODAY INFO
SUPPORT THE SENATE TO WIND OF
THE BILL.
SB ONE THIRTY SIX I PERSONALLY
WAS IMPACTED.
AND UNDERSTAND THE COMPOUND IT
DAMAGES COMPLICATION THAT SENSE
AN ENHANCEMENT CALLS AND DEFENSE
Là.
A NINETEEN NINETY THREE I WAS A
I WAS HOMELESS.
DRUG ADDICT DROUGHT [inaudible]
AND IN UNDER KANZA UNDER KUNDER
UNDERCOVER OFFICER -- ASKED ME
IF I HAVE SOME GRASS FOR SALE.
SO AS A CONSEQUENCE I GAVE HIM
SOME GRASS.
I HAD SOME PRIOR MARIJUANA
CONVICTIONS AND SO I WAS -- I
HAD TO OF SPENT TEN YEARS AT 80%
DUE TO ENHANCE.
SO WHILE SOME ARGUE THAT ONE
YEARS AN INSIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
TIME SO MANY CRUCIAL DAY'S GONNA
HAPPEN A TWELVE MONTH FOR ME.
DURING MY INCARCERATION BOTH MY
PANTS PASSED AWAY.
GRANDPARENTS SOME UNCLES THREE
BROTHERS.
AND I WAS UNABLE TO BE A WITH
HIM IN THE FINAL DAYS AND HAD TO
PROCESS THIS GROUP FROM.
A HABIT BACK I HAVE BEEN BACK
HOME -- CLEAN AND SOBER FOR
FIFTEEN YEARS DURING THIS TIME I
HAVE BEEN DEEPLY COMMITTED TO
GIVING BACK TO MY COMMUNITY.
I'M A MEMBER OF THE COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATION POSTS OF COMMUNITY
HAVE FOUND OF A LOCAL RECOVERY
PROGRAM FOR ALEX IN OUR
COMMUNITY AND ACTIVE PARTICIPANT
IN MY MáS.
AND I VOLUNTEER AT A LOCAL
CHURCH FEEDING THOSE LIVING WITH
CAPS.
I OFTEN WONDER HOW MUCH MORE I
COULD HAVE DONE FOR MY COMMUNITY
IF I HAVE SIMPLY BEEN A OFFERED
RECOVERY INSTEAD OF PRISON.
IF I HAD A CHANCE TO BEAT THAT
ADDICTION AT A YOUNGER AGE HOW
MUCH MORE COULD I HAVE TO A
SENSING THAT HAVE SMITH SIMPLY
PUNISH INDIVIDUAL FOR PAST
CRIMES.
IMPRESSION VULNERABLE PEOPLE
INTO SIGNING DISPROPORTIONATE
PLEA DEALS.
I ASKED THE COMMITTEE TO DATE
TWO OF VOTE YES ON SB ONE THIRTY
SIX OF THAT WE CAN CONTINUE TO
MOVE AWAY FROM PUNITIVE
PRACTICES.
AND MOVE TOWARD OF RESTORATION
JOBS.
THANK YOU YES.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS JAN IF YOU HAVE JONES RIGHT I
AM A DEPUTY PUBLIC DEFENDER FOR
THE COUNTY OF SAN DIEGO.
IN OUR CURRENT JUSTICE SYSTEM
TIME SERVED IS A FALSEHOOD.
SB ONE THIRTY SIX RECOGNIZE IS
THAT HE BEING MORE PRISON TIME
ON PEOPLE'S HEADS SOLELY BECAUSE
THEY'VE ALREADY SERVED TIME IN
PRISON MAKES NO SENSE.
CRITICS OFSB ONE THIRTY SIX
LIKE THE CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION FALSELY
CLAIM THAT THE UNDERLYING
PREMISE OF SB ONE THIRTY SIX IS
THAT A RECALCITRANT CRIMINAL
SHOULD BE SENTENCED THE SAME AS
A FIRST TIME OFFENDER DESPITE A
LENGTHY CRIMINAL HISTORY.
THIS ARGUMENT IGNORES OTHER
PROVISIONS THAT PROSECUTORS
ARGUE EVERY DAY IN COURT LIKE
CALIFORNIA RULE OF COURT FOUR
POINT FOUR TWO ONE BI THREE
WHICH ALLOWS A JUDGE TO CONSIDER.
A PRIOR PRISON TERM AN
AGGRAVATING FACTOR TO INCREASE
THE DEFENDANT'S SENTENCE.
SB ONE THIRTY SIX DOES NOT TAKE
AWAY THIS TOOL.
NOR THE THREE YEAR SENTENCE
ENHANCEMENTS.
NOT ONLY ARE THE ARGUMENTS
AGAINST SB ONE THIRTY SIX
DISINGENUOUS THEY ALSO IGNORE
THE REALITY OF ENHANCEMENTS.
THESE ENHANCEMENTS DO NOT REDUCE
RECIDIVISM THEY ADD TO OUR
STATES ALREADY OVERCROWDED
PRISONS.
IT IS NOW AN OFT CITED
STATISTICS THAT IN CALIFORNIA
94% OF CRIMINAL CASES AND WITH
PLEA DEALS.
EVERY TIME ONE OF MY CLIENTS
ENTER A GUILTY PLEA TO A FELONY
CONVICTION WEATHER HERE SHE IS
BEING SENTENCED TO PROBATION OR
A PRISON TERM.
I HAVE TO ADVISE THEM THAT A
POSSIBLE CONSEQUENCE OF THE PLEA
IS THAT A YEAR IN CUSTODY ABOVE
AND BEYOND OF THEIR SENTENCE CAN
BE ADDED. FOR EACH PERSON PRIOR
IN THE FUTURE.
THAT IS BECAUSE IF A PERSON IS
REVOKED ON PROBATION AND
SUBSEQUENTLY GETS SENTENCED TO
PRISON THAT TIME IN CUSTODY WILL
ALSO COUNT AS A PRISON PRIOR.
IN A LEGAL SYSTEM FRAUGHT WITH
INJUSTICES THESE TYPES OF
ENHANCEMENTS OR THE PROVERBIAL
SALT IN THE WOUND A TOOL FOR
PROSECUTORS TO OVER CARCERI BY
GETTING A SECOND THIRD AND
SOMETIMES EVEN A FOURTH BITE.
AT THE APPLE CALIFORNIA CAN DO
BETTER THAN RE PUNISHING PEOPLE
AND RECHARGING THE TAXPAYER I
URGE YOU TO VOTE IN SUPPORT OF
SB ONE THIRTY SIX THANK YOU ARE
THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT NAME AN ORGANIZATION.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
BIRDS MIKE A DOCTOR OFF ON
BEHALF OF THE ACLU OF CALIFORNIA
WE ARE PROUD CO SPONSOR AND
STRONG SUPPORT.
MARGOT GEORGE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
APRIL GRAYSON FROM THE ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION IN SUPPORT.
MICHAEL MENDOZA WITH ANTI
RECIDIVISM COLLISIONS FROM
SUPPORT.
THE WE HAVE FOUR FIFTY LA PHONE
DAN YOUR TEARS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE AND SUPPORT.
ESTONIA'S WITH ANTI RECIDIVISM
COALITION STRONG SUPPORT.
KELLY LIEU DANS MORE WITH THE
TRANS GENDER GENDER VARIANT
INTERSECTS JUSTICE PROJECT IN
SUPPORT.
CAME IN DEAN WITH THE ALLIANCE
FOR BOYS MEN OF COLOR AT POLICY
LINK IN SUPPORT.
TIRING SAYS KELLY SENIOR A
REPRESENTATION OF TRANS OF
ANARCHY INCORPORATE IS IN
SUPPORT.
MADELINE TERROR MIGRAINE WITH
THE ELLA BAKER CENTER AND
CALIFORNIANS UNITED FOR
RESPONSIBLE BUT INSTRUCTS PART.
KIM MORE WITH YOU W. IN SUPPORT.
I LANDED ON WITH THE WIDENING
GROUP REPRESENTING NEXT IN
CALIFORNIA AND STRONG SUPPORT.
GENETICALLY BUT THE NO BEHALF
THE DRUG POLICY ALLIANCE A SENSE
CO SPONSOR INSTRUCTS SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN PERSEPHONE RIGHT
WITH A C. R. U. CALIFORNIANS
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MARGOT INDO WERE WESTERN CENTER
ON LAW AND POVERTY IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS KATIE
DIXON A POLICY FELLOW WITH LEGAL
SERVICES FOR PRISONERS WITH
CHILDREN ALL OF US ARE NONE.
IN MY OPINION THIS ENHANCEMENT
IS A FORM OF DOUBLE JEOPARDY
WHICH IS A VIOLATION OF OUR
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS THANK YOU
THIS EXTRA YEAR IS VERY COSTLY I
WOULD LOVE A MINORITY.
THANK YOU THEIR MONEY AND PLEASE
THESE AND THANK YOU NAME IT
ORGANIZATION ONLY.
AN IRWIN SMART JUSTICE
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THE TORTOISE SHELL AND WE ARE
PROUD TO BE A SPONSORS.
JIM WHEN BURGER ON BEHALF OF THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
CALIFORNIA PROUD CO SPONSORS
STRONG SUPPORT.
HELLO MS BURTON.
HELLO READY.
RESERVE BURTON FOUNDER OF A NEW
WAY OF LIFE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
YES COULD YOU MAKE ROOM FOR THEM
.
CHEN NUMBER IS MY NAME'S
TYPICALLY MATTHEWS ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION.
AND WE ARE IN REGRETTABLE
OPPOSITION TO SB.
ONE THIRTY SIX UNDER CURRENT LAW
THE ONE YOU'RE ENHANCEMENT THAT
THIS BILL WOULD ELIMINATE DOES
NOT APPLY TO ANYONE WHO'S
CURRENT SENTENCE.
OR PRIOR SENTENCE WAS PROBATION.
IT DOES NOT APPLY TO ANYONE WHO
HAS NOT COMMITTED NEW A NEW
FELONY OFFENSE OR WHO HAS
REMAINED FREE OF INCARCERATION
FOR FIVE YEARS.
NOR DOES IT APPLY TO ANYONE
WHO'S PRIOR OFFENSES NO LONGER
FELONY PURSUANT TO PROP.
FORTY SEVEN UNDER EXISTING LAW
WHICH KIND OF CRIME WHICH KINDS
OF CRIMES ARE ELIGIBLE FOR THIS
ONE YOUR ENHANCEMENT.
THE PERSON CHARGED WITH FELONY
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE WITH THE
PREVIOUS FELONY CONVICTION
WITHIN THE LAST FIVE YEARS FOR
CHILD ABUSE.
A FELON IN POSSESSION OF A
FIREARM WITH A PRIOR CONVICTION
WITHIN THE LAST FIVE YEARS FOR
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
ELDER ABUSE WITH A PRIOR
CONVICTION FOR FELONY FALSE
IMPRISONMENT.
AND FINANCIAL CRIMES TARGETING
THE ELDERLY WITH A PRIOR
CONVICTION FOR EXTORTION.
THESE ARE JUST A FEW THE CRIMES
WHERE A JUDGE HAS THE DISCRETION.
TO IMPOSE A ONE HERE ENHANCEMENT.
AND WHY WOULD A JUDGE IMPOSES
ENHANCEMENT.
BECAUSE THIS PERSON IS CONVICTED
OF A SIGNIFICANT FELONY HAVING
ALREADY BEEN TO PRISON FOR A
SIGNIFICANT FELONY WITHIN THE
PREVIOUS FIVE YEARS.
INHERE SOME OTHER CRIMES IN
WHICH CURRENT LAW ALLOWS A JUDGE
THE DISCRETION TO IMPOSE A ONE
YEAR SENTENCE ENHANCEMENT.
THESE ARE ALL FELONIES WERE THE
CURRENT OFFENSE IS A SERIOUS OR
VIOLENT FELONY BUT THE PRIOR
CONVICTION IS CONSIDERED A NON
SERIOUS OR NON VIOLENT FELONY.
CARJACKING WITH A PRIOR
CONVICTION IS FOR ANIMAL CRUELTY.
FORCIBLE RAPE WHERE THE
DEFENDANT WAS CONVICTED WITHIN
THE LAST FIVE YEARS FOR ELDER
ABUSE.
LEWD ACTS ON A CHILD UNDER THE
AGE OF FOURTEEN WITH THE
CONVICTION WITHIN THE PREVIOUS
FIVE YEARS FOR CHILD
ENDANGERMENT.
INVOLUNTARY MANSLAUGHTER WITH A
PRIOR CONVICTION FOR FELONY
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
WE WOULD RESPECTFULLY SUBMIT
THAT MOST OF THE CRIMES DEEMED
NON SERIOUS OR NON VIOLENT ARE
IN FACT QUITE SERIOUS AND OR
QUITE VIOLENT.
THESE ARE NOT FIRST TIME FELONS
CONVICTED OF POSSESSORY DRUG
OFFENSES THESE ARE REPEAT THE
FELONY OFFENDERS MANY OF WHOM
HAVE COMMITTED ACTS OF VIOLENCE
AGAINST OTHERS AND ARE BACK
BEFORE JUDGE BECAUSE THEY HAVE
TARGETED MORE VICTIMS.
AFTER ALREADY.
HAVING BEEN TO PRISON.
CDA IS OFTEN ENCOURAGED TO
SUPPORT LEGISLATION THAT GIVE
BROADER DISCUSSION TO JUDGES YET
THIS BILL DOES EXACTLY THE
OPPOSITE BY TAKING AWAY THE
DISCRETION OF JUDGES TO EVALUATE
ALL THE CIRCUMSTANCES.
AND DETERMINED WHETHER
PREVIOUSLY INCARCERATED FELON
COMMITTING YET ANOTHER FELONY
WITHIN FIVE YEARS OF HIS
PREVIOUS FELONY SHOULD HAVE AN
ADDITIONAL YEAR ADDED TO A
SENTENCE.
WE TRUST THE JUDGES TO EVALUATE
ALL THE CIRCUMSTANCES IN A CASE
BEFORE THEM AND DECIDE WHETHER
THIS REPEAT FELON HAS COMMITTED
CRIMES THAT MATTER A ONE YEAR
ENHANCEMENT.
AND FOR THESE REASONS ROSS FOR
KNOW ABOUT.
THANK YOU OR ANY OTHER WITNESSES
OPPOSITION.
YOU SHOW MUCH RB HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION OPPOSITION.
MATT PERSONAL ON BEHALF OF THE
SH -- SHERIFF OF LOS ANGELES
COUNTY IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
BUT KAMLAGER-DOVE.
I JUST WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD I THINK WE
SHOULD HAVE CONTINUED
CONVERSATIONS AROUND GETTING RID
OF THE SENTENCE AND HANDS WHEN I
WOULD ASK THAT YOU WOULD
CONSIDER ME TO BE A CO AUTHOR ON
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU HAVE.
TO YES MISS WICKS -- I WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRING THE
BILL AND THE GENTLEMAN WHO
TESTIFIED AS WELL SHARING HIS
PERSONAL STORY -- YOU KNOW I
THINK WE AS A STATE ARE FINALLY
COMING TO TERMS OF THE FACT THAT
MASS INCARCERATION DOESN'T KEEP
OUR COMMUNITIES -- FOR YOU KNOW
SENTENCING ENHANCEMENTS DON'T
WORK IN FACT THEY MAKE OUR
COMMUNITIES LESS SAFE AND A
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT PEOPLE
OF COLOR IN PARTICULAR.
WE NEED TO SUPPORT THINGS LIKE
WE'RE SORT OF JUSTICE PROGRAMS
GET RID OF SENTENCING HAS BEEN
SINCE I'M JUST REALLY I'M GLAD
THAT YOU BROUGHT THIS UP AND I'D
LIKE TO ALSO BE ADDED.
AUTHOR [inaudible]
THE MISTER.
ARE YOU JUST MOVE THE BILL.
THANK YOU A CHECK TO MAKE.
INCLUDE.
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND THANK
YOU FOR THE FLEXIBILITY TODAY --
WE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE JEFF RECOMMENDING AYE WE
CALL THE ROLL.
HONESTY ONE THIRTY SIX THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER JONES SAWYER I LACKEY.
LACKEY NO BARRICADE HAND.
MATHIS.
MATHIS NO KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE AYE.
QUIRK AYE QUIRK AYE SANTIAGO SAN
DIEGO I WICKS WICKS I THAT.
IS TECH YEAH THAT THE DIAGNOSIS
HARRIS.
ARE WE WILL NOW BUDGET. SEVENTY
SIX THREE FIVE SB SH ITEM NUMBER
SEVENTEEN THREE SEVENTY SIX
PORTANTINO IS PULLED UNTIL THE
NEXT MEETING IN JULY
[inaudible]
JULY NINTH [inaudible]
M. THE WE WILL RECESS UNTIL
THREE PM.
REMOVED IT UP [inaudible]
YES